SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA ADKINS BAIT
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD PROVIDO
CORTEZ THE DALLY DOG DURAZO
AIKMAN BLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERZBERG WEST SO HER TADO JONES
CAN LONGER LAYERED LEYVA LIMO
OWN REQUIRE MELINDA'S MAN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHORT BOGUE
PAN. FORTUNE TINO ROSSI VIDEO
SKINNER STERN AMBER WHITE HOUSE
E. WIENER WILKE. MEMBERS OF A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE REAL IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR HERZBERG
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR RUBIO. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PRESIDENT- WE'RE STARTING
TODAY WITH SOME. SAD NEWS
RECEIVE WORD THIS MORNING THAT
MINORITY LEADER SCOTT WILKES
FATHER PASSED AWAY. JACK WHO IS
KNOWN AS JACQUE WILKE. MERRY TO
SCOTT'S MOTHER FOR SIXTY SEVEN
YEARS. HE AND LOIS HAD THREE
CHILDREN SCOTT OF COURSE MERION
AND JANICE FOUR GRANDCHILDREN
AND ONE GREAT GRANDCHILD JACK
WAS A LONGTIME RESIDENT OF THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY. AND WORKED IN
THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY FOR MOST
OF HIS CAREER. HE AND LOIS
ACTIVE MEMBERS UNITED METHODIST
CHURCH IN LANCASTER. LAST
EVENING MEMBERS. MARK THE
BEGINNING OF THE JEWISH NEW
YEAR ROSH HASHANAH. FOR THOSE
WHO CELEBRATE. IT STARTS WITH A
PERIOD OF TEN DAYS OF
INTROSPECTION AND ATONEMENT
CALLED DAYS OF AWE. IT'S ONE OF
THE MOST HOLY TIMES FOR THE
JEWISH FAITH. THIS S THE TIME
FOR US TO LOOK INWARD. TO
REFLECT ON THE PAST YEAR AND
PREPARE FOR THE YEAR AHEAD. IT
IS MY HOPE WE ALL INTER YEAR
FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO WITH A SENSE OF
PURPOSE AND HOPE RENEWAL AND
RESOLVE AND THAT THE NEW YEAR
MAYBE SWEET. FOR ALL OF US FOR
THOSE WITH THOSE WHO CELEBRATE
MASHONA WE PRAY. BLESSED YOU
ARE LORD OUR GOD RULER OF THE
UNIVERSE WAS GIVEN ITS LIFE AND
SUSTAINED US AND BROUGHT US TO
THIS DAY. R. J. REMEMBER US ON
THIS DAY REMEMBER US LORD GOD
FOR GOOD. RECOLLECT US FOR
BLESSINGS AND DELIVER US FOR
LIFE. IN ACCORD WITH YOUR
PROMISE OF SALVATION AND
COMPASSION SPIRITS AND BE
GRACIOUS TO US. HAVE COMPASSION
ON US AND DELIVER US FOR YOU
ARE THE COMPASSION OUR GOD AND
THE GOD OF OUR ANCESTORS REIGN
OVER THE ENTIRE UNIVERSE IN
YOUR GLORY. A MAN. SENATORS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. IN ADDITION. YOU
WILL. DO YOU. REMEMBER WE'RE
GONNA GET BEGIN TODAY WITH A
LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING NOTE
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE THIRTY
FIVE AND SENATE RULES FIFTY SIX
DEBATE MAY BE LIMITED TO A
TOTAL OF FIVE MINUTES FOR THE
AUTHOR OR FLOOR MANAGER OF THE
BILL WHICH INCLUDES OPENING AND
CLOSING STATEMENTS AND THREE
MINUTES TOTAL FOR SENATORS WHO
CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN DEBATE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
MOVE TO SENATE THIRD READING
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY SEVEN
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SENATOR
MELINDA'S WILL TAKE THIS UP ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR BORJAS. MR
MELINDA'S HERE. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO BACK TO THAT WHEN
SENATOR MELINDA IS HERE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED RED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR AUGUST THIRTIETH
THROUGH SEPTEMBER TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE POINT
TEN B. THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
REFERRED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE FILE I'M SIXTY
NINE AB THREE SIXTY ONE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTIONS WILL BE PLACED ON
TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE
S. C. R. SIXTY ONE ITEM ONE
SIXTY SEVEN A C. R. SEVEN ITEM
ONE SIXTY EIGHT A C. R. TEN
ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE AC OR
THIRTEEN. ITEM ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT ZERO THIRTY SEVEN AND
ITEM ONE SEVENTY TWO AC ARE ONE
OH ONE. SOME REQUIRE FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BACKER REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW SENATE BILL
SIXTY EIGHT FROM ENGROSSING AND
ROLLING. IN RETURN THE MEASURE
TO THE SIMPLY FOR FURTHER
ACTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK
YOU. SENATOR GONZALEZ IS THAT A
PRESIDENT- I RAISE REQUEST THAT
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE
EIGHTY THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER PACO
MISS RAY IS THE MOVE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU SENTENCE
ALSO DESK WILL NOTE. SENATOR
DODD. YES MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE- MOVE THE
FOLLOWING TWO BILLS TO
INACTIVE. THEY'LL BE AB ELEVEN
FIFTY THAT'S ITEM NUMBER. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. AN ITEM NUMBER
ONE TWENTY NINE THAT'S E. B.
FIFTEEN. EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD THE DESK WILL NOTE
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I REQUEST PERMISSION
TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL FOR SENATE BILL TWO TWO
SIX THIS LETTER IT'S BEEN
APPROVED BY BOTH CAUCUSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE ANYTHING AT THIS
TIME. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
WE WILL MOVE TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND READING FILE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILLS OF FOUR SIXTEEN AT
340-733-5890. EIGHT SEVEN
TWENTY THREE FIVE TWENTY FIVE
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED
RED. NECKS WERE MOVING TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS FILE I
DON'T WANT TO WAIT AND ONE OH
NINE WE'LL START WITH FALLON
ONE OF EIGHT THE SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
OF FINAL ITEM ONE WAY JUST A
CONFIRMATION OF SHAWNA MCCARTHY
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE NORTH
COAST REGIONAL WATER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARD. MISS MCCARTHY IS
THE DIRECTOR OF NATURAL
RESOURCES AND GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE- RISKS ARE
GUINEA RANCHERIA SHE WAS
APPROVED BY SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST EIGHTEENTH
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
DONE MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ONE TIME AND
THEN WE WILL PLACE IT ON CALL
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FACE. BACKER FOR JUST. BRADFORD
I HAVE A I DON'T ARE YOU
PROTESTING HI DALLY. DOT HI
TORONTO. HI ADNAN HI BLAZER.
GONZALEZ I DROVE. HI HURTS BERG
I WAS SO HI HER TADO. I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED BARS HI
LIVE ON I LIVE ALONE HI MCGUIRE
I MELINDA'S I MIN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A TROUBLED. PAN HI
PERSONS YOU KNOW. I BROUGHT
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN NUMBER.
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. WELL.
SENATOR MOVE THE CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THE FILE
ITEM ONE OH NINE SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THE FINAL ITEM ONE OR
NINE IS A CONFIRMATION OF THE
WALKING S. Q. L. FOR
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
HE CURRENTLY SERVES AS THE
BOARD'S CHAIR PRIOR TO HIS
INITIAL APPOINTMENT HE SERVED
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AS ASSISTANT
SECRETARY FOR FEDERAL WATER
POLICY HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
EIGHTEENTH ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE. THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED
CENTER GROVE YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TOO RISING
CONFIRMATION FOR WALKING ASK
ABOUT ALL I CAN TELL YOU THAT
IS THE DIRECTOR. OF THE WATER
BOARD HERE A STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD HE'S
TAKING ACTIVE INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE THAT WATER QUALITY
IS THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'M NOT
JUST IN CERTAIN AREAS WE HAD A
SITUATION WHERE NEEDLES OUT BY
THE BORDER OF ARIZONA AND
CALIFORNIA. LOST ITS ONLY
OPERATING WELL AND HE WAS
INSTANTANEOUSLY ENGAGED MAKING
SURE THAT THAT WATER WAS
RESTORED AND RESOURCES WERE
AVAILABLE TO THAT VERY VERY.
POOR BORDER COMMUNITY THAT WE
HAVE I CAN ALSO TELL YOU THAT
AND HE LISTENS WITH INTEREST
WHETHER HE- SUPPORTS IT 1100%
WHICH WE KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
BUT AT LEAST HE LISTENS TO THE
GROWERS THAT GROW OUR FOOD IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH OF THE
TOP THREE FOOD PRODUCING%
COUNTIES IN THE WORLD. AND HE
LISTENS TO THEIR SITUATION-
THAT THEY HAVE IN PROVIDING
FOOD SECURITY FOR OUR NATION.
WHERE WE PRODUCE 99% OF SEVERAL
QUOTES- COMMODITIES GROWN. AND-
DISRUPTION OF WATER SUPPLY.
COULD CAUSE A FEUD OF FOOD
SECURITY DISRUPTION ACROSS THE
NATION BECAUSE OF THE FOOD
PRODUCTION THAT WE HAVE. AND
HE'S- HE'S AT LEAST CONSIDERING
AND THOUGHTFUL IN HIS WAY THAT
HE APPROACHES- WATER DELIVERY
AND THE WATER SYSTEM. IT WAS
ALSO VERY VERY INSTRUMENTAL IN-
TAKING A KEY. ROLE IN MAKING
SURE THAT THE ILLEGAL. ILLEGAL-
SITES FOR WATER- ILLEGAL SITES
ARE WELLS THAT WERE PUT IN- ARE
A VIOLATION OF STATE LAW AND HE
IS COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE
THAT THAT- STOPS AS WELL SO I
WOULD ACTUALLY. I REALLY ENJOY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
WALKING ASK ABOUT FOR STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE SENATOR
DODD. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I'VE ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF- MR ASK AVAIL. I TOO
HAVE WORKED WITH HIM ON A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ISSUES
THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT. I FOUND
THEM TO BE INCREDIBLY
RESPONSIVE. AND ENGAGING AD-
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR DODSON REQUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH BENEFITS AND
I'LL BE REALLY QUICK AT THE
CHAIR HAS BEEN ACTIVE ENGAGED
INVOLVED TRYING TO BE TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO WHAT HAS BECOME
ONE OF THE STATE'S MOST.
PRESSING CRISIS ISN'T WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I.
VOTING SHARE MY APPRECIATION
FOR HIM. BEING SO EXPEDIENT I'M
DEALING WITH SOME OF THE
TOUGHEST CHALLENGES THAT ARE
FACING. COMMUNITIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU CENTER
REQUIRE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. MADAM SECRETARY CALL CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. ALAN ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS. FACE HI BRECHER
PORGES BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM HI
PROTESTING HI DOLLY DOT I
TORONTO HI ADNAN I. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROSS I HEARD BERG
HI WITH SO. HER TADO. JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE IN
HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON I URGE ALL OF THOSE. PAN
HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER NINE
HI WHAT KIND OF SKI I WINNER.
WELL. SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTEEN SENATOR DOLLY. NOT AT
HIS DESK WE WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTEEN CENTER LET
ALONE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
FIVE BY SENATOR LYNN MON AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER LEVEL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SP
FIVE THIRTY FIVE ELIMINATES
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION AND
STREAMLINED THE BIOMARKER
TESTING PROCESS PROCESS FOR
PATIENTS WITH ADVANCED
METASTATIC STAGE THREE AND FOUR
CANCER AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY INCLUDED DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION. BY SIX MONTHS
TO GIVE HEALTH PLAN SUFFICIENT
TIME TO ADJUST THEIR FORMS AND
PROSTHESES CODIFIES ALL
REGULATIONS BY THE M. H. C. AND
C. D. EYE AN AUTHORIZED THEM TO
ISSUE GUIDANCE ON
IMPLEMENTATION AND REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS TO
ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN SYSTEMS
FOR COMMUNICATING WITH THE ROLE
EACH AND ROLLING. AT THREE
THIRTY FIVE HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES AND HAS NO LISTED
OPPOSITION THANK YOU I RESPECT
THE ASPIRIN I HAVE A THANK YOU
CENTER THE MON MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE
I BACKER GORGEOUS BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM HI CORTEZ THESE. I
DALLY. DOT HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN
HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROSS I
HURTS BERG I WAS SO. I DO I
JONES. I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON FIVE WIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEANT I NEWMAN I
NELSON. I GO TO A VOTE PAM HI
FOURTEEN TINO. I BROUGHT RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I WAS
HEALTHY I WINNER. WELL. REMOVE
THE CALL RIMAC TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTEEN SENATOR DOLLY ARE YOU
PREPARED. CITADEL I WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FOUR THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR
VALLEY AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SITTARD
SELLING THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SORRY FOR MY
TARDINESS THERE- TODAY I'M
BRINGING BACK- YES BEFORE
THIRTY SIX TO LAKE TAHOE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BILL TODAY
I'M THE BILL IS- BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WITH MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE THANK YOU SIMPLY-
SENATOR DOLLY MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING THEM OUT OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA HI ADKINS I
BATES I BECKER FORGES RADFORD I
COME BY IT- I PROTESTING I DELI
HI TODD. I TORONTO HI EXAMINED
EYE LASER. GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
I HURTS BERG I WAS SO HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR I LIVE ALONE I
WHERE I MELINDA'S BY MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. I WOULD SHOW
UP BOTH CAN I PORT IN CHINO HI
RALPH. RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN- BERG I WAS ASKING I
WINNER WELL. REMOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTEEN SENATOR STERN NOT
AT HIS DESK MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY
FOUR. CENTER CORTESE FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE MADAM
PRESIDENT- RISE 22%IS CO
AUTHOR OF SB SEVEN NINETY-
EXCELLENT IS FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EXCELLENT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY BY SENATOR
STERN AN ACT RELATING TO FISH
AND WILDLIFE SENATOR CORTESE
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY REFLECT MONTHS
OF NEGOTIATION PRIMARILY
BETWEEN CENTER STERN'S OFFICE
IN THE AGENCY'S AFFECTED. THEY
WILL GIVE THE AGENCIES
FLEXIBILITY UTILIZE EXISTING
PROGRAMS WERE FEASIBLE IN
ADDITION TO A NEW PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTING GREATER ACCESS TO
ADVANCED MEDICATION CREDITS. IN
ORDER TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY PROJECTS
IN OUR STATE. SB SEVEN NINETY
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HE SAID
NO NO VOTES- I. S. THAT YOU CAN
CURRENTLY AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I FACE
HI BECKER OR JUST BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM HI PROTESTING I
DALLY FIVE DOT FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN HI LASER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. I HURTS BERG FIVE WAS
SO HYPER TIDO HI JONES. I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LABOUR I
THE MON. HI WIRE I MELINDA'S
FIVE MIN I NEWMAN I NELSON. I
GO TO A VOTE PAN HI FORTUNE
TINO I BROUGHT RUBIO. HI
SKINNER I STERN BERGER I WAKE
COUNTY. I WINNER WELL THEN
REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS WILL
NOW MOVE TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH THE FINAL ITEM ONE THIRTY
FOUR SENATOR DODD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION AN
ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES CENTER DOT. HE MET A
PROTON AND MEMBERS ABC FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IS AN ASSEMBLY
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE BILL THAT MAKES
CLARIFYING AND NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO THE A.
B. C. ACT THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
IS BILL LAST YEAR I'VE. THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA I AT KINS FIVE
EIGHT. I BACKER FOR JUST
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T. I
PROTECTING HI DALLY. I DONT.HI
TORONTO I EXAMINED EYE LASER
GONZALEZ I WROTE. HI HURTS BERG
I LISTEN I RETIRE DO I JONES I
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LIVE IN
I LIVE ALONE I MEAN WHY ARE. I
MELINDA'S I MEANT I NEWMAN I
NELSON I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH.
CAN I PORT TINA I BROUGHT.
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I'M
BERG I WHAT HOUSE KING FIVE
WINNER. WELL SENATOR MOVES TO
CALL MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
FILE AND ONE FORTY FOUR SENATOR
DODD. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. HOLD ON A SEC ARE YOU ARE
YOU READY OKAY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SEVENTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AN ACT
RELATING TO SPORT FISHING.
SENATOR DODD. I THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND SENATORS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THERE WERE
ROUGHLY TWO POINT FIVE SPORT
FISHING LICENSES ISSUED SINCE
THAT TIME WE'VE EXPERIENCED A
STEADY DECREASE IN LICENSE
SALES IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS
TRIP TROUBLING TREND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
INITIATED RECRUITMENT RETENTION
AND REACTIVATION OR AN R. THREE
ACTION PLAN. THIS PROCESS
BROUGHT A CROSS SECTION OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE TO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO TURN THIS TREND
AROUND. ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME OUT
OF THAT PROCESS IS TO CHANGE
THE WAY THE DEPARTMENT OFFERS
SPORT FISHING LICENCES.
CURRENTLY ANNUAL SPORT FISHING
LICENSES EXPIRE ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST REGARDLESS OF WHEN
THAT LIFE WAS WAS PURCHASED
THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND
AUTHORIZED INSTEAD AUTHORIZE
THE DEPARTMENT MAKE LICENSE IS
VALID FOR ONE YEAR FROM THE
DATE OF PURCHASE. JUST LIKE
YOUR CAR REGISTRATION THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD AND THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK
DRIVERS. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
MEMBERS A DISCUSSION AND OUR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA. HI
ATKINS. I BASE. I BECKER REGIS
BRADFORD I COME BY OTHER.
CORTESE I DALLY. I DON I
TORONTO I A COMMON HI GLAZER
GONZALEZ I GROSS I HEARD
SPURRED HI WEST SO HYPER TANTO
I JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I LABOR I LIVE ALONE HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN. I NEWMAN I
NELSON. I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH
CAN HI FOURTEEN TINO. I. ROSS
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN- BERG I
WAKE COUNTY FIVE WINNER WELL.
REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS
REMOVING THE FILE AND ONE FORTY
SEVEN SENATOR CABALLERO. NOT AT
HER DESK ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM. ONE FIFTY ONE.
SET UP PAST TEMPORARILY FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE SENATOR
EARLY MON. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CORIO AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS CENTER MON THANK
YOU WE HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER
WHEN HE GOT TO YOU I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AT FOUR SIX TWO WHICH
REMOVES THE UNNECESSARY
REQUIREMENT THAT CALIFORNIA
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS COMPLETE ADDITIONAL
COURSEWORK AND TRAINING HOURS
TO COMPLETE. WITH COUPLES AND
pALREADY WELL PREPARED FOR AFTER
COMPLETING ALL THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR LICENSURE AB FOUR SIX TWO
ALSO CLEARS BARRIERS IN THE
WORKFORCE PIPELINE BY REMOVING
AND THE REQUIREMENT THAT
ASSOCIATE PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS COMPLETE AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TRAINING HOURS IN A HOSPITAL OR
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH CLINIC
SETTING AS PART OF THEIR-
TRAINING. BOTH OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS ONLY EXISTING
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NIGHT OUT. THANK YOU SAID
EARLY MON MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BAIT.
I BETTER PORCHES I'D HEARD I
HAVE A DAUGHTER I THINK I DALLY
I THOUGHT I TORONTO HI EXAMINED
EYE LASER. AND SOLACE FIVE
GROVE. HI HURTS BERG I LISTEN
HI HER TADO I JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I LIVE IN I
LIVE ALONE HI WIRE. I MELINDA'S
I MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A
TOTAL OF BOTH. PAN ARCADE
FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN I'M BURKE I
LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER. WELL
CENTER MOVES TO CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY FIVE SENATOR SKINNER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ%
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY
AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING
CENTER SKINNER THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE ALLOWS DEVELOPERS
TO RECEIVE H. C. D. LOAN FUNDS
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING DURING
THE CONSTRUCTION PERIOD BY
DOING THIS WE SAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF UNNECESSARY.
INTEREST COSTS ON CONSTRUCTION
LOANS THE R. PROJECT WOULD
STILL NEED TO OBTAIN A PRIVATE
CONSTRUCTION LOAN THOUGH
SMALLER THAN THE HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IS CALCULATED THAT
THIS WOULD RESULT IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED AFFORDABLE HOMES
OVER THE NEXT PERIOD OF TIME
WITH EXISTING FUNDING SO IN
OTHER WORDS IT WOULD EXPAND OUR
ABILITY TO- TO FINANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS RECEIVED
EMAILS STORED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR EITHER THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING. NONE BEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE. I
BACKER OR JUST BRADFORD I COME
BY ADAM HI CORTEZ I DOLLY. I
THOUGHT I TORONTO HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. HI
HURTS BERG I WAS SO HYPER TIDO
I JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I LIVE ON I LIVE ALONE HI
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. HI A
TELEPHONE CAN HI PORTS IN CHINO.
I BROUGHT RUBIO. OKAY RUBIO I
SCANNER HI STERN AMBERG HI
KELSEY FIVE WINNER WELL.
SENATOR MOVED TO CALL MEMBERS
REMEMBER MOVED BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN SENATOR
CABALLERO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE SENT A COUPLE AERO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH
TWO ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON WHICH IS
DEVILISH IS TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY STANDARDS FOR
THE NEXUS STUDIES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PREPARE WHEN
IMPOSING DEVELOPMENT IMPACT
FEES. IT ALSO DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING. FOR
NEXUS STUDIES AT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MAY CHOOSE TO USE
IN ADDITION THIS BILL WILL TIE
FEES MORE CLOSELY TO THE ACTUAL
IMPACTS OF NEW DEVELOPMENT BY
REQUIRING THAT SHE'D BE
PROPORTIONATE TO THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE OF A PROPOSED UNIT. AND
IT'S AN ADDED BENEFIT OF THIS
POLICY IS THAT DEVELOPERS WILL
BE GIVEN AN INCENTIVE TO SUB
DIVIDES PROJECTS INTO SMALLER
AND MORE NATURALLY AFFORDABLE
UNITS THIS BILL IS THE PRODUCT
OF EXTENDED NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE WORKING GROUP COMPOSED OF
CITIES COUNTIES SPECIAL
DISTRICTS UTILITIES AFFORDABLE
AND MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT
DEVELOPERS AND ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS. TAKEN TOGETHER
THESE COMMON SENSEREFORMS WILL
PROVIDE CONSISTENCY CLARITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE WAY THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DETERMINE
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES IT WILL
MAKE A MEANINGFUL CHANGE TO AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF HOUSING
COST AND IS ASTEP. TOWARDS
MAKING MORE HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR MORE FAMILIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THINK CENTRE COVER EURO
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NINE
AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I AT KINS
HI EIGHT HI BECKER OR JUST
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM
HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY I DON. HI
THERE ALSO I EXAMINED EYE LASER
GONZALEZ I WROTE. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE HI WIRE I MELINDA'S
I MEAN IN I NEWMAN I NELSON I A
TROUBLE CAN. HI PORTIONS YOU
KNOW I. ROSS RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN I'M BERG I WORK OWSKI I
WINNER WELL. THE SENDER MOVED
TO CALL MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FILE AT A ONE FIFTY SIX
SENATOR HER TADO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX BY
FAMILY MEMBER RAM DEALER AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES SENATOR HER TADO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT A B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGULA THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD CREATE A
CRIPPLING BETWEEN PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS AND
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
TO MORE RAPIDLY CONNECTS
STUDENTS WITH THE CENTRAL
COUNTY SUPPORT SERVICES. THIS
MEASURE HAS RECEIVED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER HER TADO
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA. I ATKINS.
I BAIT. I BACKER. FORTRESS
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW I
PROTESTING I DALLY I THOUGHT. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN HI BLAZER
GONZALEZ I DROVE. HURTS BERG I
WEAR SO HI FOR TIGHTER HI JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA
I THE MOON. I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH.
CAN I FOURTEEN TO NO HI RALPH
VIA HI SKINNER. MIKE STERN
AMBERG HI I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER WILL. CYNDER MUSICAL
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR MCGUIRE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW AN ACT
RELATING TO PEACE OFFICERS
CENTUM ACQUIRE SO MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENT MIGHT BE ON THE ORDER
THAT IT MIGHT. HEY HART- THANK
YOU SO MUCH READING PRESENT
RISE PRISON AT SEVEN SEVEN NINE
IT'S A BIPARTISAN BILL AND
GRATEFUL TO A SYNONYM BIGELOW
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS. BUT THE
BILL ADDS THE COUNTIES OF
DELAWARE MADERA MONO AND SAN
MATTEO TO THE CURRENTLY SERVES
THIRTY TWO COUNTIES WHERE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS COULD BE INCLUDED IN
THE DEFIITION OF PEACE
OFFICER. THESE FOUR COUNTIES
ARE FACING EXTREME STAFF
SHORTAGES IS CAUSING A
SIGNIFICANT STRAIN ON THE
CURRENT DEPUTIES AT SEVEN SEVEN
NINE WOULD HELP ALLEVIATE.
STAFFING ISSUES IN THESE
COUNTIES AND AGAIN THIRTY TWO
COUNTIES ALREADY ALLOW THIS
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
pREQUIREMENT FIRST DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING. NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OUR
ARCHULETA. HI AT KINS. HI BAIT.
HI BECKER PORCHES BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI
DOLLY I DONT. HI THERE AWESOME
I A GUNMAN HI GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI
HER TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MOON I
WIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN
I NELSON I A SHOW OF BOTH PAM.
HI FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN ON BURKE FIVE
WHAT KIND OF SKI FIVE WINNER
WILK SAID REMOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE FILE
AND ONE SIXTY SIX SENATOR PAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THIRTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE BILLING
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS- HOSPITALS
ARE SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
UNINSURED PATIENTS WITH A
NOTICE REGARDING DISCOUNTED
PAYMENTS AND CHARITY CARE
OPTIONS HOWEVER MANY PATIENTS
DO NOT KNOW TO ASK FOR THIS
INFORMATION THEY DID NOT
RECEIVE IT. NOT THE TIME THE
HOSPITAL FAILED TO PROVIDE IT
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT SPECIFY
TIMING OF THE NOTICES PATIENT.
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY TWO BY
SUMMER WOULD PROVIDE SPECIFIC
TIME FRAMES FOR HOSPITALS
PROVIDE PATIENTS WITH
INFORMATION ON OPTIONS FOR
CHARITY CARE PAYMENT ASSISTANCE
A LINK TO A LIST OF THE
HOSPITAL PRICES RAISE SERVICES
AND THE INTERNET ADDRESS OF AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WILL HELP
PATIENTS NAVIGATE THE PAYMENT
AND BILLING PROCESS. I STRICTLY
AS PER NIGHT IT. THE CENTER
PANEL MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
HI BABES I BACKER OR JUST
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY I DALLY I DON. ARE YOU
THERE ALSO HI ADNAN HI PLEASE
SIR GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER. LAYERED
I LIVE IN I THE MOON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S I MEAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. CAN I
FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG ALRIGHT
CASKEY I WINNER WILKE. REMOVE
THE CLL NUMBERS REMOVING THE
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY THREE
SENATOR SKINNER. FIVE ONE
SEVENTY THREE. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE
AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION CENTER SKINNER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- MAYBE TEN THIRTY FIVE
WELL STATE MEDIA. REQUIRE
NEEDED SCHOOLS BY REQUIRING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ADOPT
RECYCLING MATERIAL STANDARDS.
FOUR STREETS AND HIGHWAYS THAT
IS AT OR ABOVE THE LEVEL
ALLOWED BY CALTRANS THE
OFFICERS OFFICERS WORKED TO-
KEEP NEAR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THE SENATORS MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE BEEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE. MY
BACKER FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE
A OTHER. HIGH PROTESTING. I.
DALLY I DOG HI TORONTO HI ADNAN
I GLAZER GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG I WENT SO HI HER TADO
I JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
HI LLEVA HI THE MON I WONDER I
MELINDA'S I'VE BEEN HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I SHOW BOTH PAM I
PERSON TINA FIVE ROTH RUBIO I
SKINNER HI STERN I'M BERG I WAS
ASKING I WINNER WELL. SENATOR
MUSICAL MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
THE FILE AND ONE SEVENTY FIVE
SENATOR DODD MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CENTERED ON THAT APPROACH AND
THE SENATORS ARE PLEASE TO
PRESENT TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FORTY FOUR. FORTY FOUR
WILL AUTHORIZE THE CREATION OF
A GREEN EMPOWERMENT ZONE FOR
THE NORTHERN WATERFRONT AREA OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY THIS SO
WE'LL PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK TO
PRIORITIZE ACCESS TO TAX
INCENTIVES GRANTS LOAN PROGRAMS
ETCETERA. THIS BILL ALSO SERVE
AS A BRIDGE TO FACILITATE THE
TRANSFER OF RESOURCES EXPERTISE
IN INFORMATION BETWEEN OUR
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS. STATE POLICY MAKERS
MUST ENSURE THAT THE TRANSITION
OF GREEN TECHNOLOGIES DONE WITH
CLARITY FORCE SIDE AND A FOCUS
ON ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF
WORKERS IN AFFECTED INDUSTRIES
IN SHORT WE MUST ENSURE THAT
ALONG WITH THE PROMISE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE WE G.
ECONOMIC JUSTICE FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD NUMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OUR
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS I BASICS BY
BECKER FORGES BRADFORD I HAVE A
DAUGHTER HI COURTESY HI DOLLY.
DODD I TORONTO HI ADNAN I
BELIEVE- GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO I HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR HI THE MOON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S I BEEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I GO TO A VOTE. ONE
FIVE FOUR TWENTY NOW. I BROUGHT.
REVERE I'VE SKINNER HYPE STERN
I'M BERG HI WE CASKEY I WINNER
WELL. REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY SIX SENATOR RUBIO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AN ACT
RELATING TO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES. VERY SORRY THAT WAS
SENATOR ROTH SORRY SENATOR
RUBIO SO WE'RE GOING TO PASS ON
FILE ON THAT ONE AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN. SENATOR EGGMAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS IN
DECLARING THE ORANGE THAT
URGENCY THERE OF SIX MEDIALLY
CENTER EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AT. AB FIVE TWENTY SIX
IS- BACK THEN IT'S JUST
BASICALLY SAYS A PODIATRIST IN
AN AMBULANCE CAN STILL GIVE THE
CODE VACCINATION I ASK FOR YOUR
AMAZON. THANK YOU SENATOR
EDMUND MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS I FACE HI BECKER.
FORGES BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM
HI CORTESE. I DALLY. FIVE DOT.
FIVE TORONTO. HI ADNAN HI LASER
AND SOLID I DROVE. HERTZBERG
FIVE WEST SO I HER TADO I JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I FLAVOR
HI HI THE MOON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF THOSE CAN
I PORT IN CHINO. I BROUGHT
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER WELL.
SENATOR MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FOUND ITEM
ONE SEVENTY NINE SENATOR DODD.
ONE SEVENTY NINE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN ACT
RELATING TO HIGHWAYS SENATOR
DODD. THAT A PRESIDENT MEMBERS-
DUE TO THE INEFFICIENCIES IN
THE CALTRANS ENCROACHMENT
PERMIT APPLICATION PROCESS SOME
PROJECTS TO DEPLOY BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE BEEN DELAYED FOR OVER A
YEAR. AB NINE FIFTY FIVE WILL
STREAMLINE THIS PROCESS BY
REQUIRING CALTRANS TO NOTIFY
PERMIT APPLICANTS OF ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS UP FRONT IN
SETTING A THIRTY DAY MILESTONE.
STONE FOR CALTRANS TO VERIFY
WHETHER SUCH ENCROACHMENT
PERMIT APPLICATION IS COMPLETE.
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY FIVE WILL
HELP US ADDRESS THE DIGIT THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. IT IS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN ON
BEHALF OF THE SEVEN MEMBER
COURT TO RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA I ATKINS. I BASE
HI BECKER. PORGES BRADFORD. BY
ADAM HI CORTESE HI DOLLY I DONT
HI TORONTO HI ADNAN I LASER AND
SOLACE I GROW. HERTZBERG I WAS
SO HI HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I LIVE ON.
THE MOON I AM A LAWYER I
MELINDA'S I MEAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I WOULD SHOW A VOGUE
PAM MY FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT
RUBIO ALL RIGHT SKINNER I STERN
NUMBER HI WHAT CASKEY I WINNER
WELL. SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SENATOR RUBIO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ. I
SIMPLY FELT ALTHOUGH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I CAUGHT
PROBABLY RISE TO RESENT. S. B.
TWELVE OH SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY MEMBER WEBER. AB
TROUBLE SEVEN WILL ESTABLISH
THE PATHWAYS TO PANDEMICS TASK
FORCE THE TASKFORCE WILL BE
TASKED WITH ANALYSING LESSONS
WE HAVE CONTINUED. TO LEARN
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AND
DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO NAVIGATE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THE
NEXT PANDEMIC IT'S NOT A MATTER
OF IF BUT WHEN. THIS PANDEMIC
HAS TOUCHED THE LIVES OF EVERY
CALIFORNIAN EVERY BUSINESS IN
OUR STATE AND HAS CHANGED THE
LIVES F SO MANY. IN SO MANY
WAYS AB TWELVE AU SEVEN MAKES A
MODEST INVESTMENT TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA HAS A ROAD AP. FOR
THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE
DEFICIENCIES WE SIGNED OUR
RESPONSE TO COOK AT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND ALLOW US TO
BETTER PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIFLES. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS IN THE
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA. I. ATKINS. HI
BABES. I BACKER. FORGES
BRADFORD. I HAVE A I DON'T. I
COURTESY. I. DALI. I DON HI
THERE ALSO HI ADMIN FIVE LASER
GONZALEZ I DROVE. HERTZBERG I
WENT SO HI HER TADO MIKE JONES
I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LABOR
HI THE MOON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S
I MEAN I NEWMAN I NELSON. I
URGE ALL OF THOSE PAN HI
FOURTEEN TINA. I BROUGHT RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN NUMBER HI I
LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER WELL.
SENATOR MOVED TO CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE THE FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY BY SENATOR BORCHERS BUT
IT WILL BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR
MELINDA'S. M. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR BURGESS
RELATIVE TO THE TWENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH SENATOR MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ON THIS SATURDAY
SEPTEMBER ELEVEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OUR NATION WILL OBSERVE THE
TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
AMERICA'S DARKEST DATING DOING
SO WILL HONOR THE HEROES OF THE
CASUALTIES OF THE MOST SHOCKING
BARBARIC IN CATASTROPHIC ACT OF
INHUMANITY AND MODERN HISTORY.
THE TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY WILL
SERVE TO RECALL THE UNITING OF
THE WORLD'S CULTURES AND
NATIONALITIES IN THE
CONDEMNATION OF TERRORISM AND
THE GREAT OUTPOURING OF CHARITY
AND COMPASSION THAT FOLLOWED
THE ATTACKS ON THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER WHICH DEMONSTRATED ONCE
AGAIN VICTORY OF THE HUMAN
SPIRIT OVER DEPRAVITY SAVAGERY
AND COWARDICE. TWENTY YEARS AGO
ON SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND ONE TERRORIST FOUR
SEPARATE AIRLINE FLIGHTS
CARRYING TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX PEOPLE ALL BOUND FOR
CALIFORNIA. THESE ACTS OF
TERRORISM BECAUSE THE
DESTRUCTION OF. THE TWO
PROMINENT WORLD TRADE CENTER
TOWERS NEARBY BUILDINGS A
PORTION OF THE PENTAGON
BUILDING IN FOR AIRLINE JETS IN
THE LOSS OF INNOCENT AMERICAN
LIVES IN COUNTLESS INJURIES TO
SO MANY OTHERS. OVER FOUR
HUNDRED PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL
GAVE THEIR LIVES IN RESPONSE TO
THOSE EMERGENCIES. TWENTY YEARS
AFTER THE ATTACKS CALIFORNIANS
AMERICANS AND PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD CONTINUE TO MOURN THE
TREMENDOUS LOSS OF INNOCENT
LIFE ON THAT HISTORIC DAY.
THESE ATTACKS WERE BY FAR THE
DEADLIEST TERROR ATTACKS EVER
LAUNCHED AGAINST THE UNITED
STATES AND BY TARGETING THE
SYMBOLS OF AMERICAN STRENGTH
AND SUCCESS THEY WERE INTENDED
TO ASSAIL THE PRINCIPLES VALUES
AND FREEDOMS OF THE UNITED
STATES AND OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO INTIMIDATE OUR
NATION. AND WEAKEN OUR RESOLVE
IT DID NOTHING OF THE KIND.
AFTER TWENTY YEARS THE THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS OF CALIFORNIANS
REMAIN WITH THE VICTIMS OF THE
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
ONE ATTACKS. IN WITH THE
VICTIMS' FAMILIES FRIENDS AND
LOVED ONES AND AS CALIFORNIANS
WE JOIN THE AMERICAN PUBLIC IN
POURING OUT THEIR HEARTS IN
GRIEF AND SYMPATHY FOR THE
FAMILY AND THE FRIENDS OF THOSE
WHO PERISHED. OR SUFFERED
INJURIES IN THE ATTACKS. WE
SALUTE AND WE REMEMBER THE
HUNDREDS OF HEROIC MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE POLICE AND FIRE
DEPARTMENTS PARAMEDICS AND
MEDICAL PERSONNEL WHO PUT THEIR
SAFETY AT RISK. AND LOSS OF
THEIR LIVES WERE SERIOUSLY
INJURED IN THEIR COURAGEOUS
EFFORTS TO PROTECT AND SERVE
THEIR FELLOW CITIZENS. WE
SHOULD ALL BE ETERNALLY
GRATEFUL TO THE VALIANT MEN AND
WOMEN OF OUR ARMED FORCES THOSE
WHO HAVE FALLEN. THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN WOUNDED AND THOSE WHO
CONTINUE TO COMBAT TERRORISM
AROUND THE WORLD. SO IT IS A
FITTING POINT IN HISTORY FOR
ALL AMERICANS TO REMIND
THEMSELVES. THAT THE UNITED
STATES IS A NATION OF HEALING
OF HOPE AND RESILIENCE. A
EXCUSE ME WE ENCOURAGE
CALIFORNIANS TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF THOSE WHO DIED
SERVING SEPTEMBER ELEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH AN ACTIVE
SERVICE TO THEIR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS WHETHER THAT'S
DONATING BLOOD OR VISITING A
NURSING YOU'RE BETTER IN TOWN
OR VOLUNTEERING AT A HOSPITAL
FOR SAYING THANK YOU TO A
VETERAN WHO SERVED LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN I ASK THAT WE NEVER
FORGET THE SACRIFICES MADE ON
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
ONE AND I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA US. SENATOR NELSON. NOT
A PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE. ON SUCH
OCCASIONS WE ALWAYS MAKE A
VALVE THAT WE WILL REMEMBER.
OFTTIMES WE DON'T. BUT THIS IS
ONE THAT WILL LIVE. AS
ROOSEVELT SAID. ELEVEN ANTHONY.
WHEN WE WERE ATTACKED PEARL
HARBOR. THIS ONE WE'LL ALSO
LIVE IN INFAMY BECAUSE WE WERE
ATTACKED. ON OUR OWN SOIL. BY
FOREIGN INFLUENCES. BENT ON
HARMING US. AS MUCH AS
VIOLENTLY AS THEY POSSIBLY
COULD. THEY SUCCEEDED MAYBE TO
A DEGREE AND BUT FOR A BRIEF
TIME. BUT NOT IN DURING THE DAY.
AMERICA HAS REMAINED STRONG.
AND WE ALL OVER PLANET CAME
FROM OUR HEARTS. THE SUPPORT
THOSE WHO WERE LOST. YOUR LOVED
ONES. AND OUR FELLOW AMERICANS.
I FONDLY REMEMBER. ALL THE
FLAGS THAT WERE IN FULL
UNFURLED IN THE HOMES AND THE
BUSINESSES. NO NOT CARS AND
TRUCKS DRIVING AROUND AMERICA.
H. AMERICAN MAKING ABOUT. THE
WE DO REMEMBER WE WILL BE
STRONG. WE WILL NOT BE DETERRED.
IT'S SAD THAT THESE OCCASIONS
POORER THAN LIFE AND OVER THE
COURSE OF HISTORY. A LONG HALF.
IT PROBABLY STILL WILL BE. BUT
THE MARK THE NATION AND ITS
PEOPLE. IS HOW WE INDOOR AND
MOVE THROUGH AND MOVE ON FROM
SUCH OCCASIONS. I GET PRETTY
DISGUSTED QUITE OFTEN WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THINGS THAT
I SEE GOING AROUND OUR COUNTRY.
BUT AT SUCH MOMENTS OF THESE.
IS WHEN THE TRUE HEART. AND SO
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHINE
FORTH GLORIOUSLY. YES THOSE
LOVED ONES ARE LOST. AND THEIR
LOVED ONES ARE GRIEVING. ND
WE- ALL THE REST OF US. STILL
STAND WITH THEM AND STAND FOR
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
OUR COUNTRY. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON SAID ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO
RISES SUPPORT SR FORTY SEVEN.
OBVIOUSLY NINE ELEVEN IS A DAY
THAT WE'LL REMEMBER FOR YEARS
AND YEARS AND CENTURIES TO COME.
WE'LL ALSO REMEMBER THE
SACRIFICE OF THE MEN AND WOMEN.
WHO AS THE BUILDINGS CAME DOWN.
RUSHED IN THOSE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIREFIGHTERS MEN
AND WOMEN HELPING EACH OTHER
VOLUNTEERING TO DIG AND DIG TO
FIND THEIR LOVED ONES THEIR
COLLEAGUES IT WAS AMAZING. MAY
HAVE DROPPED US TO OUR KNEES
BUT THE DEAD DROPPERS ALL THE
WAY DOWN AS A NATION WHICH
STOOD UP WE CAME BACK. AND CAN
YOU IMAGINE. THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO LINED UP TO JOIN OUR
MILITARY THE GOAL AND FIGHT FOR
OUR COUNTRY. WE MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR SERVICE YEAR
AFTER YEAR. DEDICATED MEN AND
WOMEN TO SERVE THIS COUNTRY IT
IS AMAZING THAT WHAT WE COULD
DO WHEN WE STAND UP TOGETHER.
AND WE SAID IT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WE ARE A COUNTRY OF MANY
BUT- BECAUSE OF ONE LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR EVERYONE. THE
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS BLAZIN
GERMAN WE ARE AMERICA. WE'VE
STOOD UP WE CAME BACK. STRONGER
THAN EVER BUT WE MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LOSS OF SO MANY
LIVES THE FAMILIES MEN AND
WOMEN WHO GAVE FOR OUR COUNTRY.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS THEY
WILL CONTINUE WE WILL FIND. MEN
AND WOMEN TO SERVE THIS GREAT
COUNTRY EVERY SINGLE DAY
BECAUSE WE ARE AMERICANS AND I
TRULY YEAH SO WE SUPPORT SR
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA SENATOR
MAN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
HELLO I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO FOR BRINGING FORWARD
THIS. IMPORTANT RESOLUTION AS
WE NEAR THE TWENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF NINE ELEVEN. I
WAS A THIRD YEAR STUDENT IN LAW
SCHOOL AT THAT TIME- IN THE
BOSTON AREA AND MANY OF MY
FRIENDS MY CLASSMATES LOST
FRIENDS AND LOVED ONES. IN
THOSE ATTACKS- AND I WANT TO
HARKEN BACK TO THE CONTEXT OF
NINE ELEVEN WE JUST HAD A
CONTESTED ELECTION. A VERY
CLOSE ELECTION- WE HAD A IT WAS
DECIDED IF IN EFFECT BY BUSH V.
GORE THE SUPREME COURT. HI
GEORGE W. BUSH HAD TAKEN
OFFICE- AND MANY WERE UPSET
WITH SOME OF HIS POLICIES. BUT
WHAT I VIVIDLY REMEMBER ABOUT
NINE ELEVEN. HE SAID AFTER THAT
ATTACK WE ALL UNITED BEHIND THE
PRESIDENT THOSE OF US WHO
AGREED WITH HIM. THOSE WHO
DISAGREE WITH HIM. WE RALLY
BEHIND OUR FIRST RESPONDERS. WE
RALLY BEHIND OUR MILITARY. AND
WHILE MANY OF US MAY HAVE HAD
MISGIVINGS ABOUT THE FOREIGN
POLICY STEPS THAT WE TOOK GOING
FORWARD. WE SUPPORTED THEM WE
SUPPORTED OUR TROOPS. WE
SUPPORTED OUR PRESIDENT WE
SUPPORTED THE DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS THAT LED US TO
THIS DECISIONS. IT WAS A MOMENT
OF UNITY. AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE TWENTY YEARS LATER. WE
SEE SO MUCH DIVISION. AND
PARTISAN BICKERING TODAY. AND I
HOPE THAT AS WE APPROACH THE
TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF NINE
ELEVEN WE CAN HARKEN BACK TO
THAT SPIRIT OF UNITY THAT WE
CAN HAVE FAITH IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS. IN OUR DEMOCRACY
THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT SUPPORT
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN FOR OUR
TROOPS FOR OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
AGAIN BECAUSE WHEN AMERICA IS
UNITED AND TOGETHER. THERE'S NO
GREATER COUNTRY IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD BUT WHEN WE ARE
DIVIDED AS WE FIND OURSELVES
TODAY- THAT IS I BELIEVE WHEN
WE ARE IN PERILOUS TIMES SO I
WANT TO THINK AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE I PERSON I VOTE. BUT
ALSO WANT US TO YOU KNOW BE
CAUTIOUS AND THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
WHAT NINE ELEVEN SHOULD MEAN.
IN THESE TIMES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU CENTERMAN
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. EVERY
PERSON ON THIS FLOOR REMEMBERS
WHERE THEY WERE AND WHAT THEY
DID ON NINE ELEVEN MUCH LIKE
THE KENNEDY ASSASSINATION THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT STICKS WITH
US AND WE'LL STICK WITH US FOR
THE REST OF OUR LIVES AND WE
TELL OUR CHILDREN OUR
GRANDCHILDREN. ABOUT NINE
ELEVEN WHERE WE WERE AND WHAT
WE DID. I HOPE ALL OF US. I
TRUST ALL OF US WILL BE ABLE TO
ALSO. TALK ABOUT HOW IT
IMPACTED OUR LIVES AND WHAT WE
DID. WHAT WE DID AS A
CONSEQUENCE SOME MAY THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE ALL OF US
MADE SOME SACRIFICE. BUT WHAT
WE DID WHAT WE DID TO. ATTACKED
SUPPORT EMBRACE THE FAMILIES OF
THOSE WHO WERE IMPACTED. WHAT
WE DID TO SUPPORT THOSE WHO ARE
STILL FEELING THE IMPACTS IF
YOU THINK IT WAS TWENTY YEARS
AGO AND THOSE IMPACTS ARE NO
LONGER BEING FELT I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO VISIT THE VA HOSPITAL. I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VISIT A VA
HOSPITAL AND SEE THAT THAT
SUFFERING THAT SACRIFICE IS
STILL WITH US. AND IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE CAN DO GOING FORWARD. I
ASKED THAT WE REMEMBER THOSE
WHO FOUGHT WITH US AND SHOULD
BLOOD WITH US. IN AFGHANISTAN.
BECAUSE NOW THEY'RE PLAYING
MANY ARE COMING TO CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA HOUSES AND HAS THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF AFGHANS
OF ANY STATE IN THE UNION THAT
WE REMEMBER THAT THAT THEY
SERVE WITH US AND SACRIFICED
WITH US. AND THAT WHEN WE TELL
THE STORY TO OUR CHILDREN OUR
GRANDCHILDREN ABOUT WHAT WE DID.
ON NINE ELEVEN AND AFTER NINE
ELEVEN WE CAN INCLUDE.
SOMETHING ABOUT WHAT WE DID FOR
THOSE WHO FOUGHT AND THOSE WHO
FOUGHT WITH US THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER ON. S. S. R. FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE I ALSO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SR FORTY SEVEN AS
MANY HAVE NOTED IT'S WAS ONE OF
THOSE DAYS THAT WILL NEVER
FORGET. IT REALLY WAS A SOMBER
DAY FOR ALL OF US HERE IN OUR
COUNTRY. BUT THE ONE THING THAT
I DO RECALL IS THAT IN THAT
DARKNESS THERE CAME LIGHT
IMMUNITY. I REMEMBER EVERY
SINGLE CAR WITH AN AMERICAN
FLAG REMEMBER PEOPLE HAD SIGNS
THAT READ WE STAND TOGETHER.
AND WE WEREN'T DIVIDED BY.
EITHER POLITICAL AFFILIATIONS
OR OTHER IT WAS JUST ONE
AMERICAN FAMILY. AND WE NEED TO
KEEP THE FOCUS ON ALL THE
PEOPLE WE LOST ON THAT DAY SO
MANY FIRST RESPONDERS SO MANY
FAMILIES. I PERSONALLY KNOW OF
A FAMILY WHO GREW UP WITHOUT A
MOTHER SHE HAPPENED TO BE IN
ONE OF THE FLIGHTS. AND AS WE
CONTINUE TO COMMEMORATE THE
TWENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT WE NEED
TO STAND TOGETHER. AND THE
TIMES OF TRAGEDY AND I KNOW
RIGHT NOW IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
GOING THROUGH SOME DARKNESS AND
NO MATTER HOW HARD TIMES ARE.
WE CONTINUE TO BE ONE AMERICAN
FAMILY SO I ENCOURAGE US TO
CONTINUE TO HONOR THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO BRAVELY HAVE FOUGHT.
DURING THE TWENTY YEARS OF WAR
FOR OUR FREEDOMS THOSE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY STILL SERVING
OVERSEAS. I HAPPEN TO BE A
MILITARY FAMILY AS WELL AND MY
FAMILY IS CURRENTLY. OVERSEAS
SERVING AND SO I WANT TO JUST
HONOR THOSE FALLEN I WANT TO
HONOR THE VICTIMS AND THE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND CONTINUE TO
PRAISE THEM FOR WHAT THEY DID
ON THAT DAY AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR SUPPORT
FOR S. R. FORTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
SENATOR HERTZBERG. PRICES
SUPPORTED THIS MEASURE THANK
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE
ELSINORE PRESENTING- CALLING
FROM FRESNO AND WANT TO JOIN IN
ON THE COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE
BY SO MANY COLLEAGUES HERE
TODAY. HE WAS TWENTY YEARS AGO.
TWENTY YEARS AGO. I REMEMBER AS
A COLLEAGUE FROM ST TALKED
ABOUT WHERE WE YOU. I WAS JUST
GETTING UP IN WILLIAMS LET'S
SEE MY OFFICE CALLS ME AND SAYS
TURN ON THE TV AS THE BUILDINGS
ARE COMING DOWN. THE CHP TOLD
US THAT WE WERE TARGET HERE AT
THE STATE CAPITOL. AND
ABANDONED ASKED US TO ABANDON
THE BUILDING INSTANTANEOUSLY
TWENTY YEARS AGO. THE GOVERNOR
SET UP SHOP OUT AT THE CHP
TRAINING CENTER. AND THE OTHER
PART OF TOWN. AND IT WAS QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY THAT WAS THE DAY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WAS
INTENDING TO TAKE UP
REDISTRICTING. THE SENATE SEATS
ASSEMBLY SEES BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION SEATS AND
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS AND WE
MISSED SESSION THE NEXT DAY AND
OUR SHINY DIE FOR THAT TWO YEAR
SESSION WAS SEPTEMBER
THIRTEENTH TWO IS QUITE
CHALLENGING WHICH SET UP SHOP
ACROSS THE STREET IN TERMS OF
HOW THE LEGISLATURE WORKED.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DEAL WITH THE EXTRAORDINARY
PANDEMONIUM. THE IMPACT ON THIS
BUILDING HAS BEEN ALL OF THE
SECURITY MEASURES WHICH YOU SEE
HERE TODAY. THE FENCE AROUND
THE BUILDING THE MAGNETOMETERS
WE HAVE AND SO MANY OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE NEW POLICIES
THAT WE HAVE. WENOW HAVE IN
THIS COUNTRY THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY ANTI TERRORISM-
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD- DESPITE
ALL THE THREATS THAT WE HEAR
FROM SO MANY OF OUR FRIENDS
OTHER ASPECTS OF GOVERNMENT. SO
MANY OF THOSE HAVE BEEN QUASHED
BY THE INCREDIBLE
PROFESSIONALISM OF THE VARIOUS
ANTI TERRORIST GROUPS THAT
EXIST.ACROSS THIS COUNTRY WE
HAVE OUR OWN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA. A HUNDRED MY OFFICE
WHO USED TO WORK FOR ME AS A
LIBRARY ASSISTANT MANY YEARS
AGO WAS NOW OUR SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND WE
CREATED THIS HOMELAND SECURITY
OFFICE. TO INTEGRATE ALL OF THE
VARIOUS BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT
THEY DIDN'T TALK TO EACH OTHER.
SO WHEN DO WE ALSO HAVE A TSA
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE THAT
ONE COULD ARGUE ABOUT
INCONVENIENCING US. WITH THOSE
FOLKS WHO CAME TO THE SYSTEM
WITH RAZOR BLADES AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT THEY DID ORDER THE
THOSE PLANES. HAVEN'T BEEN
HAPPENING. SO INDEED THERE IS
THE CAR COLLEAGUES HERE TALKED
ABOUT THE EXTRAORDINARY HUMAN
TOLL. BUT THE INGENUITY AND
IMAGINATION CREATIVITY OF THIS
COUNTRY AND OURGOVERNMENT.
HAVE CREATED EXTRAORDINARY
PROTECTIONS THAT OFTEN ARE HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF AN
INCONVENIENCE TO US BUT I THINK
AS WE- LOOK AT A DAY LIKE
TODAY. OR DAY TWENTY TWO
RECOGNIZES S. C. S. R. FORTY
SEVEN TALKS ABOUT RECOGNIZING.
THE IMPACT OF NINE ELEVEN I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND. I THINK HOW WE
RESPONDED TO IT AND HOW
SUCCESSFUL OUR GOVERNMENT HAS
BEEN. IN STOPPING SO MANY
CHALLENGES SO MANY POTENTIAL
THREATS THAT HAVE- FACED US
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND HOW WE
REFORM OUR GOVERNMENT TO MAKE
IT WORK BETTER. IN BEING
RESPONSIVE TO THE TAXPAYERS AND
PEOPLE OF THE UNITED STATES AND
OF CALIFORNIA SO THAT AMONG ALL
THE OTHER REASONS SUGGESTED BY
THE COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY.
TRANSACTION PORT OF SR FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG CENTRE TORONTO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE
SINCE IN SUPPORT. OF THE
TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH. AND IN
PARTICULAR TO OF COURSE
APPRECIATE THE SACRIFICE IN THE
LIVES OF MANY FIRST RESPONDERS.
THE HEROES AND THOSE WHO WERE
FIRST RESPONDERS BUT DIDN'T
HAVE A TITLE AS A FIRST
RESPONDER. THE THOUSANDS OF
ACTS OF HEROISM. AMERICANS FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE. HELPING ONE
ANOTHER AMERICANS BORN IN OTHER
COUNTRIES. AND I JUST WANT TO
MENTION ONE PARTICULAR GROUP
THAT WERE IMPACTED- IN THE
NORTH TOWER OF THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER AT THE VERY TOP WAS A
RESTAURANT CALLED WINDOWS ON
THE WORLD. THAT DAY THERE WERE
SEVENTY TWO OUR RESTAURANT
STAFF THAT WERE WORKING. MY
UNION THE HOTEL AND RESTAURANT
WORKERS ARE REPRESENTED THOSE
EMPLOYEES- THEY ACTUALLY WERE A
WINDOWS ON THE WORLD. THEY CAME
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD. THE
MAJORITY WERE NOT BORN HERE IN
THE US. BUT THEY WERE WORKING
AND SERVING THIS NATION JUST
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE. WE WERE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE VIDEO
OF THE EMPLOYEES AT WORK HOW
THEY WERE. COMRADES WITH EACH
OTHER THEY WORKED TOGETHER FOR
SO MANY YEARS THEY HAD A
TREMENDOUS LEVEL OF SUPPORT FOR
EACH OTHER THEIR FAMILIES FOR
EACH OTHER THEY LOVE FOR EACH
OTHER. ALL SEVENTY TWO OF
COURSE WERE WORKING THAT DAY
WERE KILLED WE PRODUCED A FILM
TO TELL THEIR STORIES. TO
PRESERVE THEIR EXPERIENCES AS
IMMIGRANT AMERICANS SO TO ALL
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES ALL
THOSE WHO PERFORMED ACTS OF
HEROISM OF. REMEMBER THE DAY
AND I. WAS JUST. A COUPLE YEARS
WE HAD OUR FIRST CHILD AND I
REMEMBER THE STORIES FROM MY-
UNCLES AND MY FATHER ABOUT.
WHEN PEARL HARBOR WAS ATTACKED
AND THERE'S MEMORY. AND IT WAS
THAT MOMENT I REALIZE THIS IS A
MEMORY THAT I WILL NEVER
FORGET. WHAT HAPPENED ON
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH SO I JUST
WANTED TO ALSO SAY WHICH HAS
BEEN SAID MANY TIMES ON THIS
FLOOR TODAY THAT WE WILL NEVER
FORGET THE PEOPLE WHO. PUT
THEIR LIVES TO THE FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO WERE GOING TO
THE ACTION WHEN PEOPLE WERE
TRYING TO LEAVE. AND GET TO
SAFETY IT WAS JUST IT'S BURNED
IN MY MEMORY OF THOSE TOWERS
COMING DOWN AND THAT ON OUR OWN
SOILS. WE WERE ATTACKED- I JUST
WANT TO SAY THE COOL THING THAT
I REMEMBER THEY CAME OUT OF IT
WAS IT DIDN'T MATTER. WHAT
POLITICAL VIEW YOU ARE FROM. WE
WERE ALL AMERICANS IN THE SAME
BOAT. AND WE STAND FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND FOR THOSE WHO
SACRIFICED WELL WE WANT TO
REMEMBER THAT DAY AND I WILL
NEVER FORGET THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING SR FORTY SEVEN- TO
THIS FLOOR AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY AS WELL.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR
PAM. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I TO A RISE IN SUPPORT
OF S. R. FORTY SEVEN AND-
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE. MAKE
COLLEAGUES HERE TALKING ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCES I REMEMBER.
BEING WOKEN UP BY PHONE CALL
ACTUALLY. MY BROTHER WHO LIVED
IN DC- CALLED AND SAID YOU NEED
TO TURN ON THE TV- BECAUSE- NOT
ONLY OF COURSE WE HAVE THE TWIN
TOWERS CAME DOWN THE PLANE THAT
FLEW INTO THE PENTAGON AS WELL
AS COURSE THE PLANE. THAT WAS
DOWNED IN PENNSYLVANIA. YEAH
AND I THINK THAT CERTAINLY IS
WE REMEMBER THAT DAY. AND THE
HEROISM OF THE FIRST RESPONDERS
AND OTHERS- THAT DAY. I HOPE
THAT WE ALSO- AND PEOPLE
REFERRED TO THIS- ALSO
REMEMBERED- THAT THE UNITY OF
OUR COUNTRY OUR PRESIDENT-
PRESIDENT BUSH- ACTUALLY
CALLING BE SURE THAT. WE DO NOT
AT LEAST AT THAT POINT TIME
TRIED TO- TO VIGILANT EYES ARE-
BLAME MUSLIMS FOR THIS ATTACK
ON OUR COUNTRY. THAT WE WERE
ALL AMERICANS NO MATTER WHAT
OUR FAITH OUR POLITICS.
ASSIGNMENT THEN FORTUNATELY DID
NOT LAST BUT AT LEAST
IMMEDIATELY AFTER. I HELD AND-
THAT KIND OF LEADERSHIP. AND SO
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT- THESE
KINDS OF A TRAGIC EVENTS AND
FOR EXAMPLE IS ALSO REFERENCE
THAT- IN RESPONSE OUR COUNTRY
HAD TO TAKE STEPS TO TRY TO
PROTECT ITSELF- YEAH WE HAD-
REFUTED AIRPORT YOU HAD TO GO
AND YELL TO METAL DETECTORS
AND- SO FORTH. WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE SITTING OUT THERE
PROTESTING AIRPORT SAYING THAT
WHITE PEOPLE TAKING MY FREEDOM
TO GO INTO THE AIRPORT- YOU HAD
A NOW NO FLY LIST NOW I THINK
THERE'S SOME DEBATE AS TO HOW
EFFECTIVE THAT WAS- BUT- YOU
KNOW YOU HAD PEOPLE WHO HAD TO
GET JACKSON ORDERED JUST FINE
WE DIDN'T. WELL CERTAINLY SOME
PEOPLE THERE PERHAPS SOME
JUSTICE IN THERE BUT PEOPLE
DIDN'T O AND PROTEST OUTSIDE
OF AIRPORTS ARE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICES ARE
SCREENED. AND AT ELECTED
OFFICIALS- FOR AGAIN TAKING
AWAY. AGAIN FOR THOSE ACTIONS.
AND I HOPE THAT AS WE REMEMBER
WHAT HAPPENED- BACK ON- NINE
ELEVEN. THAT WE OUGHT TO THINK
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
FACING TODAY AND HOW WE CAN
COME TOGETHER AS A COUNTRY. AND
LOOK AT THE FACTS I SHOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE OF THAT AND FORTY
DARK CONSPIRACY THEORIES ABOUT.
NINE ELEVEN. THEY'RE STILL OUT
THERE. HIS HAVE THINGS ON
SOCIAL. THAT CLAIM THAT NEVER
HAPPENED. R. AS A CONSPIRACY.
AND THERE EVEN SOME POLITICIANS
TODAY- FOR EXAMPLE-
CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE KELLY
GREEN TWO YEARS AGO- ACTUALLY-
TRIED FOR PERJURY THIS
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND THAT IS
NOT HOW WE SHOULD BE MAKING
POLICY DECISIONS BASED ON
CONSPIRACY THEORIES BUT ON
FACTS. AND SO AS WE CONFRONT
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE
TODAY HOPEFULLY WE WILL LOOK AT
THE FACTS WE WILL COME TOGETHER
AS A COUNTRY TO TRY TO PROTECT
OUR MUTUAL SECURITY AND SAFETY
AND THAT THE HISTORY OF- ARE
MEMBERS OF NINE ELEVEN WILL
HELP GUIDE US IN HOW OUR
COUNTRY. SHOULD TRY TO COME
TOGETHER AND- ACTOR SELVES
AGAINST THREATS AGAINST US SO
AGAIN I- SPECIALLY ASK FOR
SUPPORT FOR S. R. FORTY SEVEN
AND- HOPE WE CAN REFLECT ON THE
LESSONS THAT IT- BRINGS US
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAM MADAM HOTEL. AND PRESIDENT-
I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT THERE WILL
BE SUPPORT FOR S. R. FORTY
SEVEN TODAY. AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT- THIS IS FOUR DAYS UNTIL
WE ADJOURN- BUT I THINK IT IS
REALLY MOST APPROPRIATE. THAT
WE TAKE THE TIME TODAY. TO
HONOR THE STORIES THAT THOSE OF
YOU HAVE SHARED TODAY THOSE
THAT WE'VE HEARD OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS. THE DOCUMENTARIES
THE MOVIES THE REPORT- IT'S SO
MUCH THAT WE FEEL IN OUR HEARTS
NOT JUST- THAT WE'VE WITNESSED
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS. I
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY PROFOUND
COMMENTS OR REMARKS AT THIS
MOMENT EXCEPT THAT I THINK THAT
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE
THE TIME- AND THE STORIES
REALLY DO MATTER I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S SOMETHING MOST OF US TO-
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY WHO SAID WE ALWAYS.
REMEMBER WHERE WE WERE. IT WAS
EARLY MORNING MOST OF US DID
NOT KNOW WHAT WAS UNFOLDING
BEFORE US EVEN AS WE HEARD THE
STORIES. I WAS ON MY WAY FROM
MY EARLY MORNING BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION MEETING AS A AS A
NEW COUNCIL MEMBER. AND I KNEW
THAT MY US MIGHT. LATER TO
BECOME SPOUSE WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE ON A PLANE THAT MORNING. SO
I DIDN'T KNOW ALLIED EXCEPT I
KNEW THAT SHE WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE ON A PLANE AND SO. WE DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF CELL PHONES THAT
DAY SO I HAD TO PULL OVER. ON
EL CAJON BOULEVARD IN SAN DIEGO
TO FIND A PAY PHONE. TO TRY AND
CALL AND MAKE SURE THAT SHE WAS
NOT HEADED TO THE AIRPORT THOSE
STORIES. AND THEN TO FEEL SO
FORTUNATE LATER. BUT SHE WAS
NOT ON A PLANE. BUT SO MANY
PEOPLE WERE- WE REMEMBER THE
MEMORIES THE THOUGHTS THE
EMOTIONS ARE SO VIVID EVEN
TODAY TO THOSE OF US ARE
LISTENING TO YOUR STORIES. OF
WHERE YOU WERE AND WHAT YOU
REMEMBER AND HOW YOU TOOK IT
IN- WE REMEMBER THE BRAVERY THE
HUMANITY OF THOSE PASSENGERS ON
FLIGHT NINETY THREE WHO SAVE
THE LIVES OF COUNTLESS PEOPLE
IN THE U. S. CAPITOL. OTHER
SHRINE OF OUR DEMOCRACY. I
REMEMBER THE BRAVERY IN THE
HUMANITY OF ALL THOSE WHO RAN
INTO THE TOWERS ARE FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THE STORIES THAT
CAME OUT AFTER THAT. THOSE WHO
MIRACULOUSLY MADE IT OUT. AND
OF COURSE THOSE WHO DID NOT. I
REMEMBER THE SICK FEELING THAT
WE HAD ONE STILL REELING IN
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE GRIEF
AND ANGER TO LEARN. THAT A
BRIEF PART OF THE TERRORISTS
PREPARATIONS TOOK PLACE IN MY
OWN CITY OF SAN DIEGO. YOU'VE
HEARD ME LIKE MANY OF YOU SO
PROUD OF THE PEOPLE ON THIS
FLOOR- WHO TALK ABOUT THEIR
MILITARY SERVICE IN THEIR
MILITARY HISTORY. OF MY
FAMILY'S MILITARY SERVICE- I
AIN'T HAD A NEPHEW WHO SOON
WENT OFF TO IRAQ AFTER. NINE
ELEVEN I HAVE A NEPHEW STILL
SERVING TODAY. I REMEMBER THE
TALK ABOUT THE INCREDIBLE
MILITARY PERSONNEL AND
INSTALLATIONS. THAT I REPRESENT
IN SAN DIEGO. I OF COURSE
REMEMBER THE LOSS AND
SACRIFICES THAT SO MANY OF OUR
MILITARY FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
DURING THESE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
AND THAT'S ESPECIALLY POIGNANT
AS WE MOURN OUR RECENT LOSS OF
THIRTEEN MARINES IN AFGHANISTAN
AND JUST A WEEK OR SO AGO FIVE
SAILORS OFF THE COAST OF SAN
DIEGO. I WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO
THE COLLEAGUES FOR SPEAKING ON
THIS RESOLUTION BECAUSE IT IS
US THAT KEEPS THE MEMORY. IT IS
US THAT RECOGNIZES THE LEGACY
AND THE FABRIC IN HELL THIS IS
WOVEN INTO THE HISTORY. MUCH
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER
MENTIONED ABOUT WORLD WAR TWO.
ARE THESE THOUGHTS AND MEMORIES
REALLY MATTER. FOR US TO TAKE
IT FORWARD AND NOT FORGET.
TERRORISM FOREIGN OR DOMESTIC
HAS NO PLACE IN OUR SOCIETY ARE
IN OUR SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT.
ERICA WITH OUR FLAWS BUT ALSO
WITH OUR BRAVERY AND HUMANITY
HAS BEEN IS AND WILL BE A
BEACON FOR PEOPLE. OF THE
WORLD. SO REMEMBERING SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH AND THOSE LOVED AND
LOST IS AN IMPORTANT WAY FOR US
TO KEEP THAT BEACON FROM
BURNING OUT THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MAN PRO
TEM SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
MELINDA'S YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M CALLING
SOMEONE I THINK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS- AND SHARING.
YOUR EXPERIENCE IN REMEMBERING
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH I THINK IT
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
ENSURE WE WERE TEACHING OUR
YOUTH ABOUT THE TRAGIC EVENTS
OF THAT DAY- IF YOU DON'T
REALIZE THAT THE LAST
GENERATION OF KIDS WHO WERE
ALIVE DURING THAT TIME HAVE NOW
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL-
WHICH INCLUDES A COUPLE OF MY
OWN CHILDREN. SO I THINK WHAT
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE AND ALWAYS
REMEMBERS THAT SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH IS FOR THIS COUNTRY'S
A HALLOWED DAY IN OUR HISTORY
IT IS A DAY THAT WE REMEMBER
THOSE WHO PERISHED THOSE WHO
CONTINUE TO SUFFER TODAY THE
EFFECTS- OF WHAT HAPPENED THAT
DAY THOSE WHO WENT ON TO TRY TO
COMBAT THE FORCES THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE ACTS AND
KEEP THEM FERMENT ONCE AGAIN
COMING TO AMERICAN SOIL- THAT'S
WHAT S. R. FORTY SEVEN IS ABOUT
AND THAT'S WHAT. OUR
COMMEMORATION OF SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH IS ABOUT IS IT NOT A
TIME TO OPINE ABOUT AN ELECTION
THAT WAS OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO
OR- THE EVENTS OF AUGUST TWENTY
SIXTH OF THIS YEAR IT IS TO
HONOR THE MEMORY. OF THOSE THAT
WE LOST AND THOSE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LOSE AS A RESULT OF
AN SUING HEALTH ISSUES. FROM
THOSE ATTACKS WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA'S MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FACE I
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD I COME
BY ADAM I PROTECTING HI DOLLY.
I THOUGHT I DRAW SO I EGGMAN I
LASER IT'S ALL AS I GROW HI
HURTS BURKE I WISH SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN WATER. I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON I
MEAN WIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF
BOTH I CAN HI PERSON TINA. I.
ROSS HI RUBIO I SKINNER BY
STERN I'M BURKE I LKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL HI SENATOR
MUSICAL MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
ON TO FILE AND ONE EIGHTY THREE
SENATOR HER TADO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE AN ACT
RELATING TO FOSTER CARE CENTER
HER TADO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB TWELVE EIGHTY
THREE IS THE LATEST BILL TO
ADVANCE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
IS INCREASINGLY PLACING YOUTH
AND FAMILY SETTINGS AND
TRANSFORMING EXISTING GROUP
HOMES FOR YOUTH WHO ARE NOT YET
READY TO LIVE WITH FAMILIES CAN
RECEIVE SHORT TERM INTENSIVE
THERAPY AND SERVICES. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY THREE INCLUDES POLICY
CLARIFICATIONS AND TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS NECESSARY TO BUILD
UPON THE EFFORT AND ENSURE
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION. THE
LANGUAGE IS DEVELOPED IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN
IPHONE THE USER HER TADO
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING THAT
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA. FIVE
ADKINS. I FACE. I BACKER
GORGEOUS BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM I PROTESTING I DALLY I DON
I DRAW SO I EGGMAN FIVE LASER.
GONZALEZ HI GROVE HI HURTS BERG
I WAS SO HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED HI LISA I
THE MAIN I. WIRE I MELINDA'S.
FIVE MIN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. HI
A SHOW OF VOGUE I PAN I PERSONS
YOU KNOW I. ROSS. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN NUMBER HI HI
CASKEY. HI CLEANER I WILL I.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL FOR ELEVEN
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN ALSO SENATOR
HER TADO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
NINETY SIX BY A FAMILY MEMBER
GABRIEL AN ACT RELATING TO
CALFRESH CENTER TOM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I'M BACK WITH-
EIGHTY THREE NINETY SIX ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAPER
WHICH EXPANDS. COLLEGE STUDENT
ACCESS TO CALPERS BENEFITS BY
CLOSING THE CERTIFICATION GAP
ON CAMPUS PROGRAMS THAT QUALIFY
UNDERSTAFFED EMPLOYMENT AND
TRAINING PROGRAM STUDENT
EXEMPTION EIGHTY THREE NINETY
SIX WILL MAKE THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR
CALFRESH AND AS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TAKES FULL ADVANTAGE
OF FEDERAL RESOURCES A. B.
THREE NINE SIX RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE
AND ON THE ASSEMBLY. FLOOR
PERSPECTIVE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR LIBEL THANK YOU SENATOR HER
TADO MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OUR
FATE SEEING AND. HEARING THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARE CHILE. I. ATKINS.
I BAIT. HI BECKER GORGEOUS
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T HI
COURTESY HI DALLY I DONT. HI
THERE ALSO HI ADNAN EYE LASER
GONZALEZ I GROW I HURTS BERG.
WEST SO. HI HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MOON I REQUIRE. MELINDA'S
MAN HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN I SHOW
A FOLK I PAN I FOURTEEN TO NO I
BROUGHT. HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN BERGER HI CASKEY I WINNER
I WELL I. SIMILAR MOVES THE
CALL MEMBERS REMOVING ON THE
FILE AND ONE NINETY SENATOR
ROTH MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
AN ACT RELATING TO PROFESSIONS
AND VOCATIONS SENATOR RON.
ISN'T THIS BILL PROHIBITS A
REGISTERED SECURITY GUARD FROM
CARRYING OR USING A FIREARM OR
BATON UNLESS THE SECURITY GUARD
IS AN EMPLOYEE OF A PRIVATE
CONTROL OPERATOR LICENSEE OR AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY BEGINNING IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE THE BILL
AS A COURSE OF TRAINING IN THE
EXERCISE OF THE APPROPRIATE USE
OF FORCE TO CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR VARIOUS
CATEGORIES REGULATED BY THE
BUREAU OF SECURITY AND
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES. IN
ORDER TO BE ISSUED A FIREARMS
PERMIT. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH MEMBERS DESCRIPTION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING THEM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA. I ADKINS.
HI BABES. HI BECKER OR JUST
BRADFORD I HAVE I EVER I
PROTESTING I DALLY I DONT. HI
ALSO HI EXAMINED EYE LASER
GONZALEZ I DROVE. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MOON I REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I CHOSE
BOTH HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG HI WHAT CASKEY HI
WINNER I WILL HI THEN REMOVE
THE CALL MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY TWO
SENATOR UMBERG MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SOLACE AN ACT RELATING TO
LICENSURE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE SENATOR
OVER. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. EIGHTY ONE OH
SEVEN- SIMPLY PROVIDES
TEMPORARY LICENSING FOR
MILITARY SPOUSES WHILE THEIR
SPOUSES STATION IN CALIFORNIA-
TONIGHT BOTH. THANK YOU CENTER
AMBERG MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
THAT- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I CAN SEE
I HATE I BACKER BOARD JUST
BRADFORD. I HAVE I HAVE- OKAY I
PROTECTING I. DALI I DONT. I
TORONTO HI ADNAN I LASER
GONZALEZ HI GROVE I PURCHASED
BERG I WAS SO. I HER TADO.
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
PLAY A HI THE MOON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S. IN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I GO TO A VOTE I PAN.
FORTINO. PENN HI PERSON TINA I
BROUGHT HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN AMBERG I WAS ASKING I
WINNER. HI WELL I SENATOR MOVES
THE CALL MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FOUR SENATOR DODD.
SENATOR DODD. ONE NINETY FOUR-
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER AN ACT
RELATING TO HORSE RACING
SENATOR DODD THANK YOU I'VE
BEEN APPROACHED HIM AND MEMBERS
AT ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
ADDRESSES THE PROCESS FOR
DETERMINING COMPENSATION PAID
THE LICENSE ACCOUNT WAGERING
SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR
PROCESSING WAGERS ON LIVE HORSE
RACES. IT INCLUDES AN
ARBITRATION CLAUSE FOR
RESOLVING DISPUTES AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE WOULD CLARIFY THE
DECISION OF THE ARBITRATOR IS
NOT FINAL AND BINDING BUT
RATHER ARE SUBJECT TO JUDICIAL
REVIEW IT WOULD ADD A STANDARD
FOR THE ARBITRATOR TO APPLY IN
REACHING HIS OR HER DECISION.
THIS PROVISION WAS SUGGESTED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
THE BILL WOULD ALSO MODIFY THE
RATE OF COMPENSATION TO BE PAID
BY THE COMPANY PROCESSING THE
WAGERS DURING THE ARBITRATION
IN ANY SUBSEQUENT SUBSEQUENT
COURT CHALLENGES SO THAT THE
INTERIM. REDIFF COM. IS FAIR TO
ALL PARTIES I URGE AND I HAVE A-
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN WITH ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
FIVE BABY. HI BECKER FORGES
BRADFORD.  HAVE A-
HYPERTENSIVE I. DALI. I DON. I
ALSO. I EXAMINED. EYE LASER
GUNS ALL AS I DROVE. I HURTS
BURKE I WAS SO. I TANTO I JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I
LLEVA. I THE MON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I A CHILL OF BOTH I
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO. I
BROUGHT I REVERE FIVE SKINNER.
I STERN ON BERG I WAKE COUNTY I
WINNER I WILL. HI SENATOR MOVES
A CALL FOR EIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO RECESS SHORTLY PRIOR
TO RECESSING AND WE WILL BE
RECESSING UNTIL FIVE PM THIS
EVENING WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OUR COMMITTEE CHAIRS SO THEY
CAN LET US KNOW WHEN THEIR
COMMITTEES ARE MEETING THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING IMMEDIATELY AND
AFTER RECESS IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE OTHER MEMBERS WHO NEED TO
MAKE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
MADAM PRO TEM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THE RULES COMMITTEE
WILL READ MEET IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE AT TWO FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ADAM
PRO TEM SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MADAM PRESIDENT-
GOVERNANCE AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCES CAN BE MOVED MEETING
HALF AN HOUR AFTER EDUCATION
ADJOURNS IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE HALF HOUR AFTER
EDUCATION. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE SENATOR BRADFORD- I
GUESS PUBLIC SAFETY WILL BE
MEETING A HALF HOUR AFTER. COPE
WITH FINANCE- IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE VERY GOOD IF ANYONE NEEDS
HELP WITH- ALL OF THESE AFTER
AFTERS WILL BE HELPFUL THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO HAS
ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE. ART
MEMBERS DURING. ONE MOMENT.
SANDERS CAN- THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WILL MEET AFTER THE
FLOOR SESSION ADJOURNS IN WHEN
WE START AGAIN AT FIVE SO IN
OTHER WORDS NOT AFTER THIS
FLOOR SESSION BUT ONCE WE
RESUME FOR SESSION WHENEVER IT
AND SINCE THEN THERE AFTER THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WOULD CONVENE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER.
STAY
TUNED FOR ONE MINUTE MISTER BY
CAL SKI. MEMBERS DURING THE
RECESS WE WILL BE DOING A
GERMAN MEMORIES FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO HAVE INJURED OR%
MEMORIES TO DO WE'RE WAITING ON
ONE LAST ANNOUNCEMENT REGARDING
PUBLIC SAFETY.
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
PUBLIC SAFETY WILL NOW MEET IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE UPON THE
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
ADJOURNMENT OF SECTION FORTY
TWO OF THIRD THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MEMBERS WE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL FIVE PM
THIS EVENING.
GOOD AFTERNOON
NUMBERS WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED
WITH HER JOURNEY MEMORIES IN
JUST A COUPLE MOMENTS.
PRESIDING OFFICER SENATOR JONES
WILL BE UP WITH US. HE'S GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE AGENDA FOR
OUR JOURNEY MEMORIES WE'RE
GOING TO ASK IF YOU CAN JUST.
HOLD FOR ABOUT TWO MINUTES WILL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MEMBERS JUST
VERY BRIEFLY SO MEMBERS CENTER
WINNER. IF THE MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND THE ORDER- THAT
YOU'LL BE CALLED UPON. WITH
RESPECT TO THE GERMANS IF YOU
JUST GIVE ME YOUR ATTENTION FOR
A MOMENT. CENTER I'M BERG WILL
START. FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
WIENER SOONER WE KNOW HAS ONE
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE ADJOURNS.
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR BRADFORD
WHICH HAS TWO GERMANS. FOLLOWED
BY CENTER EGGMAN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR HER TADO WISH TO. PHOTO
BY SENATOR MEN WHO HAS WON
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR NEWMAN WHO
HAS TO INSURANCE FOLLOWED BY
CENTER PORTENT TINO. WHO HAS
FOUR. FOLLOWED BY SENATOR RUBIO.
WHO HAS SIX FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
SKINNER. FOLLOWED AGAIN BY
CENTER- NUMBER FOUR SERIES OF.
SIX FOUR BY SENATOR BATES THEN-
SENATOR DOLLY AND LASTLY
SENATOR PAN.
LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE CENTER FOR
INCOMING ORDER PLEASE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN OUR GERMAN
MEMORIES IF WE CAN BRING PROPER
REFERENCE TO THE FLOOR IN
RECOGNITION OF THE SENATORS
THAT WILL BE PRESENT PRESENTING
THEIR INSTRUMENTS IN MEMORY.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO CENTER- BERG
CENTER NUMBER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. EARLIER
TODAY. WE WILL UPON. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN RECOGNIZING
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH AND THE
IMPACTS OF SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH.
ADDITIONAL NOTES ON THE FLOOR
BEFORE YOU ARE FIVE POSTER
BOARDS THE MIDDLE POSTER BOARD.
HAS A CAPTION YOU RECOGNIZE IT
FROM JOHN FIFTEEN THIRTEEN NO
GREATER LOVE NO GREATER LOVE.
HALF MAN THAN TO LAY DOWN HIS
LIFE FOR HIS FRIENDS NO GREATER
LOVE HATH MAN TO LAY DOWN HIS
LIFE. OR HER LIFE. FOR A
COUNTRY. WHAT YOU SEE BEFORE
YOU ARE THE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT NAMES OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
WERE KILLED. AFTER NINE ELEVEN
IN AFGHANISTAN. WE SPOKE
EARLIER ABOUT THE FACT THAT
EVERY ONE OF US CAN REMEMBER
WHERE WE WERE WHAT WE WERE
DOING. AND HOW WE REACTED TO
THE ATTACK ON. NINE ELEVEN. THE
NAMES OF THESE POSTER BOARDS
ARE THOSE. HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
WOULD FOLLOW THEIR FAMILIES
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WOULD FOLLOW.
BUT WHAT FOLLOWED WAS LOST
SACRIFICE AND SUFFERING AS OF
THE DATE I ASKED THE- WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE THAT WE
REMEMBER THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
WE DON'T FORGET THOSE
SACRIFICES WE REMEMBER WE
RECOGNIZE WE DON'T FORGET.
THEIR FAMILIES. THEY REPRESENT
EVERY SINGLE DISTRICT. IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY SENATE
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF
YOU'LL RECOGNIZE NAMES. THERE
ARE SEVERAL I RECOGNIZE- TO-
NAMES ARE IN MY WALLET RIGHT
NOW. WHAT IS IMPORTANT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT FORGET.
NOT FORGET THOSE WHO MADE THAT
SACRIFICE NOT FORGET THEIR
FAMILIES. AND NOT FORGET THOSE
WHO ARE CONTINUING TO BEAR THE
SUFFERING IN THE IMPACTS OF
NINE ELEVEN AND POST NINE
ELEVEN. NOW THESE DON'T
REPRESENT ALL THOSE WHO MADE
SACRIFICES THESE SIMPLY
REPRESENT CALIFORNIANS WERE
KILLED IN ACTION IN AFGHANISTAN.
BUT IT'S USEFUL TO BRING HOME
TO ALL OF US. THOSE SACRIFICES
AND WHAT SOME OVEN DOOR ON OUR
BEHALF. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THE SENATE I ASKED TODAY THAT
WE ADJOURN IN SOLEMN MEMORY OF
THE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIANS THAT WERE. KILLED
IN ACTION IN AFGHANISTAN. THANK
YOU SENATOR NUMBER. SENATOR
WIENER YOUR RECOGNIZE NEXT
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY WITH PROFOUND SADNESS IN
MEMORY OF ONE OF THE MOST
AMAZING MEMBERS OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO- COMMUNITY- JAN
MEREKA TINY WHO PASSED AWAY ON
JULY TWENTY NINTH. HI JAN- WHO
IS MARRIED TO THE REVEREND
CECIL WILLIAMS- TOGETHER- DAY I
CREATED THE MODERN- GLIDE
CHURCH IN SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
TENDERLOIN ON A CHURCH THAT WAS
REALLY SO MUCH MORE THAN A
CHURCH THAT WELCOMED EVERYONE-
THAT- DECADES AGO BEFORE IT WAS
FASHIONABLE- WELCOMES R. O. G.
B. T. Q. PEOPLE. WALKING
HOMELESS PEOPLE MORE THAN
PEOPLE WHO WERE USING DRUGS
EVERYONE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
WELCOMING GLIDE AND JAM PLAYED
A CRITICAL ROLE IN MAKING THAT
HAPPEN. BY JOHN ALSO SERVED AS
POET LAUREATE OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND WAS A PROLIFIC AND VERY
VERY TALENTED. POET HI IT'S
HARD TO OVERSTATE HOW PROFOUND
THE LOSS ON. JAN'S VERY
UNEXPECTED. OUR IS FOR THE
PEOPLE OF SAN. SHE WAS TRUE ONE
OF THE MOTORS WHO HELPED MAKE
OUR CITY RHYME- SHE IS A
PERMANENT ICON- FOR OUR CITY.
THIS IS ALSO A CHAMPION FOR OUR
JAPANESE AMERICAN. COMMUNITY
AND- I'M GONNA MISS HER ON A
VERY PERSONAL LEVEL I COUNTED
HER- AND HONESTY SO AS FRIENDS
AND- JAN- WE LOVE YOU WE MISS
YOU WE KNOW THAT YOU ARE
RESTING ON A LOT OF POWER AND
YOU ARE LOOKING DOWN UPON US
REST IN PEACE. MR PRESIDENT I
ALSO WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
JOHN MERRICK RD. THANK YOU
SERINA SEMINARY ALSO RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR NEXT. THE GERMAN ARMY.
I THANK YOU- MR PRESIDENT I
RISE- TO REQUEST THAT THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY-
SALLY GERHARD WHO PASSED ON
JULY FOURTEENTH AT THE AGE OF
NINETY. SO IT WAS A PIONEER IN
SAN FRANCISCO ACROSS NUMEROUS
FRONTS- BLAZING NEW TRAILS IN
POLITICS TEACHING WRITING. AND
PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING ELSE YOU
DROVE INTO. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE SHE RECEIVED A TENURE
TRACK POSITION AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE WHERE SHE BECAME CEMENTED
IN HISTORY AS THE FIRST OPENLY
LESBIAN PROFESSOR. THE GAME
THAT STANDING. SHE CONTINUED TO
PUSH THE ENVELOPE AT SFC BY
ASTONISHING A WOMEN'S AND
GENDER STUDIES PROGRAM ONE OF
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND IN THE
ENTIRE NATION. HER ACTIVISM
HOWEVER DID NOT TAKE A BACKSEAT
TO HER TEACHING DUTIES RATHER
SHE CONTINUED TO PLAY A PIVOTAL
ROLE IN SAN FRANCISCO POLITICS
HELPING A LEASE SUPERVISOR
HARVEY MILK. IN HIS EFFORTS TO
DEFEAT PROPOSITION SIX. WHAT
YOU MAY RECALL WAS A HORRIFIC
STATEWIDE ANTI LGBT BALLOT
MEASURE TO BAN ON- LGBTQ PEOPLE
FROM TEACHING. SHE CONTINUED
HER WORK WHILE FINDING OUTLETS
FOR HER CREATIVITY INCLUDING
WRITING MULTIPLE FICTION AND
NON FICTION WORKS AND
ESTABLISHING A COMMUNE FOR LIKE
MINDED INDIVIDUALS IN WILLITS
ARE CALLED WOMEN'S LAND. ACROSS
ALL OF HER WORK SALLY LEFT AN
IMPASSIONED AND UNFORGETTABLE
MARK THAT WILL INSPIRE
CALIFORNIANS FOR DECADES TO
COME I SALLY REST IN PEACE- AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK. THANK
YOU SIR WINNERS YOU'RE RISKING.
FOR YOUR NEXT TO NUMBER. ONE
MOMENT. IF YOU. BUT MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO- ASSET THE
SENATOR IN MEMORY OF WALLACE
WALLY LIVING- WALLY- WHO I KNEW
PERSONALLY BECAUSE WHEN I WAS A
DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY IN SAN
FRANCISCO HE WAS A AN
INVESTIGATOR IN THE OFFICE-
BUT- WALLY'S WORK WITH SO MUCH
BROADER THAN HIS STRONG WORK AS
AN INVESTIGATOR. WHILE HE WAS A
LEADER IN THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
AND THE VETERANS COMMUNITY-
HELPING ORGANIZE EVERY YEAR OUR
MEMORIAL DAY COMMEMORATIONS IN
THE CITY- AND JUST AN ALL
AROUND GREAT LEADER AND
ACTIVISTS AND BELOVED MEMBER OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY A
THIRD GENERATION SAN FRANCISCAN
WALLY STRONGLY BELIEVE IN THE
VALUE OF SERVICE. TO THE
COMMUNITY INTO THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT AN MBA SENSE OF
SELFLESSNESS TERMINATION AND A
GENUINE DESIRE TO HELP OTHERS
AND EVERYTHING BUT HE DID. HE
WAS ONE OF A KIND. WHILE IT HAS
A DISTINGUISHED HISTORY OF
STATE AND FEDERAL SERVICE AFTER
GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE HE
SERVED NINETEEN MONTHS IN THE
ARMY DURING THE KOREAN WAR.
ONCE THIS CHARGE HE RETURNED TO
HIS FAMILY BUSINESS MANAGING
THEATERS IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
SACRAMENTO. HE CONTINUED HIS
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE BY
SERVING IN THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD RESERVE FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS. EVERY TENANT
COLONEL IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. HE WENT ON TO SERVE- AS
INVESTIGATOR AS I MENTIONED-
AND HE WAS EIGHTY SIX YEARS OLD
WHEN HE RETIRED FROM THE CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE EIGHTY SIX
YEARS OLD. HE WAS THE OLDEST
CITY EMPLOYEE AT THE TIME- THAT
HE RETIRED- HE ALSO WORKS
CLOSELY WITH THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE TO COMBAT
ANTISEMITISM. HI THROUGHOUT HIS
LIFE WALLY ALWAYS VALUED AND
PROMOTED THE GREAT
CONTRIBUTIONS OF VETERANS TO
OUR COMMUNITY. HE WAS A HIGHLY
VISIBLE LOCAL ADVOCATE FOR
VETERANS AND WAS APPOINTED BY.
MAYOR WILLIE BROWN AS THE
CITY'S DIRECTOR OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS- ON- AND SERVED. ON THE
KOREAN WAR MEMORIAL FOUNDATION
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO WAR
MEMORIAL BOARD OF TRUSTEES WELL
WE HAD AN IMMEASURABLE IMPACT
ON THE SAN FRANCISCO BETTER IN
COMMUNITY. AND FORMED AN
EVERLASTING LEGACY HE WILL BE
MISSED DEARLY. THE PASSWORD
FROM HEART FAILURE ON JULY
NINETEENTH AT. THE BEAUTIFUL
AGE OF NINETY ONE YEARS OLD HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS SON MICHAEL
HIS DAUGHTER DEBORAH AND HIS
GRANDSON MATTHEW PLEASE JOIN ME
IN ENSURING. THE SANTA AND
WHILE THESE MEMORY. THANK YOU
WIENER- YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR NEXT TO GERMAN MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT OUR
COLLEAGUES IT'S A GREAT SADNESS
THAT I RISE TO ASK THAT THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
MARGOT ROSE AND A RENOWNED AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO COMMUNITY- MARGOT WAS
IN I WAS A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN
AND GREW UP IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH. SHE GRADUATED FROM
SONOMA STATE UNIVERSITY AT
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW.
DURING HER TIME IN SAN
FRANCISCO SHE SERVED AS
DISTRICT DIRECTOR- FLORIDA AND
STATE SENATOR- AND NOW
CONGRESSMAN A FORMER MEMBER OF
THIS BODY THE GREAT JACKIE
SPEAR- AND MARGOT WAS
INCREDIBLY PERSONALLY CLOSE.
WITH NOW CONGRESSWOMAN SPEAR.
MARK WAS A NOTABLE PRESENCE IN
LOCAL STATE. AND FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT AND POLITICS. SHE
WAS PARTICULARLY TALENTED WITH
REGARDS TO HELPING
CONSTITUENTS. AND WAS NICKNAMED
QUOTE THE MIRACLE WORKER FOR
HER SUCCESS IN RESOLVING THE
TOUGHEST CONSTITUENT ISSUES. A
TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR EQUAL
RIGHTS AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
MARGOT WAS A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF CAUSES. RANGING FROM FOSTER
YOUTH SENIORS. MARGOT HAD A
QUICK WIT WARM SMILE AND A
PASSION FOR LIFE. SHE PASSED
AWAY MAY TWENTY EIGHTH- AFTER A
LONG ILLNESS AT HOME WITH HER
WIFE AND PARTNER WITH TWENTY
THREE YEARS- BY HER SIDE- SHE'S
SURVIVED BY HER WIFE KATIE
JOHNSON AND BROTHERS DAVID.
ROSEANNE AND DAN A SENIOR
PLEASE JOIN ME CALLINGS AND
TURNING THE SENATE TODAY IN
MEMORY OF MARGOT ROSE ON. THANK
YOU SIR WINTER FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY I BELIEVE YOU HAVE ONE
MORE AND YOUR FINAL THE GERMAN
MERRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- COLORS I ALSO
THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
OF HARRY DENTON- A LEGENDARY
NAME IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
NIGHTLIFE. INDUSTRY WELL LOVED
THROUGHOUT THE HOUSE TO BE T.
Q. COMMUNITY AS AN EXCEPTIONAL
NIGHT CLUBOWNER. AND WONDERFUL
FRIEND TO MANY ORIGINALLY FROM
IDAHO HARRY MOVED TO SAN
FRANCISCO DURING HIS SECOND
YEAR OF COLLEGE. AFTER A BRIEF
MOMENT WORKING IN BANKING HE
FOUND A JOB AS A BARTENDER AND
IMMEDIATELY FOUND HIS CALLING.
CURRY MANAGING LATER OWNED AT
LEAST TWELVE BARS AND NIGHT
CLUBS THROUGHOUT SAN FRANCISCO.
WITH FOR CARRYING HIS NAME AND
HIS DISTINCT SENSE OF STYLE.
HARRY WAS BEST FOR HIS
LEGENDARY LOUNGE- THE HERRIES
STARLIGHT ROOM- AT THE SIR
FRANCIS DRAKE HOTEL. ON THERE
HE CREATED THE SUNDAYS A DRAG
SHOW WHICH RAN FOR TWELVE YEARS
AND INCLUDED ACCOUNTS OF
EXTREMELY TALENTED LOCAL DR
ARTIS. HARY DESIGN OF THE
SOUTH'S FULL LENGTH GOWNS BY
HIMSELF. AND ALWAYS ENDED THE
NIGHT WITH A ROARING ROUND OF
APPLAUSE- HARRY'S LOVE SAN
FRANCISCO DID NOT GO
UNRECOGNIZED. HE RECEIVED
NUMEROUS AWARDS INCLUDING THE
WINE IN RESTAURANTS EVEN AWARD.
FROM THE- ANTI. DEFAMATION
LEAGUE IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE.
I HAD TO SEVER. MAYOR'S
PROCLAIM IS- AND HIS HONOR- ON
SAN FRANCISCO'S VIBRANT NIGHT
LIFE WOULD NOT BE WHAT IT IS
TODAY WITHOUT HARRY HIS
INFLUENCE IS FELT THROUGHOUT
THE CITY AND HAVING MISSED
GREATLY. HI HARRY PASSED AWAY
FROM NATURAL CAUSES ON AUGUST
TWENTY SECOND AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY SEVEN HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS BROTHERS BOB AND JIM IS
NIECES AND NEPHEWS AND
COUNTLESS FANS FRIENDS AND CO
WORKERS. COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A TURN IN THE SENATE AND
MEMORY OF HARRY DENTON. THANK
YOU SOONER PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES FORWARDS AFTER THE DEATH
OF THE COMMUTE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE ADJOURNS TODAY IN
THE MEMORY. OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR ARCHULETA YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THIS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. ALONG WITH TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT NAMES
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS I AM
HONORED. TO SHARE WITH YOU. THE
FIVE FROM MY DISTRICT. OR ONE
JOSH RAY WOODALL LANCE CORPORAL
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS
DOWNEY. NUMBER TWO WILLIAM
JOSEPH GILBERT SPECIALIST
UNITED STATES ARMY HACIENDA
HEIGHTS. NUMBER THREE THE
MEDIAL EPHRON IT IS OUR FIRST.
MASTER SERGEANT ARMY PICO
RIVERA NUMBER FOUR ROBERT JAMES
COTTLE SERGEANT MAJOR UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS WHITTIER.
NUMBER FIVE JOSEPH CRUZ PRIVATE
FIRST CLASS ARMY WITH HERE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SIR ARCHER FOR HONORING THE
MEMORY OF THOSE THAT HAVE
SERVED OUR COUNTRY SO VALIANTLY.
SEARCH FOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
PRESIDENT DEAR FRIEND OF MINE
TIM COYLE PASSED AWAY
UNFORTUNATELY THE VERY YOUNG
AGE ON JULY EIGHTH. KIM WAS
STARTED OUT YEARS AGO AS A
MATTER MANAGER OF CHUCK'S STEAK
HOUSE IN LA HOYA CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY TOOK A
POSITION HE HAS SEIZED
APARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT WHERE HE HELD
SEVERAL EXECUTIVE HELD SEVERAL
EXECUTIVE POSITIONS FOR MORE
THAN TEN YEARS. UNDER PRESIDENT
REAGAN AND PRESIDENT BUSH IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE HE
TRANSFERRED OVER TO SACRAMENTO
AND SERVED AS GOVERNOR WILSON'S
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
SUBSEQUENTLY HELD THE POST- AS
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING IS SO SEE
ASIAN FROM NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS WELL WE WORK
TOGETHER VERY CLOSELY.
PERMISSION MR PRESIDENT TO SHOW
PHOTOGRAPH THAT IS DISPLAYED IN
THE LOBBY OF THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S OFFICE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT OBJECTION
THANK YOU THIS IS A PHOTOGRAPH
TAKEN. IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
AND MR COYLE IS IN THE MIDDLE
OF THAT POTOGRAPH. THERE'D
BEEN A SIXTEEN YEAR STALEMATE
ABOUT SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA. AT THIS MEETING
THIS IS GONNA GO SHOOTING TEAM
OF WHICH TO HIM WAS A INTEGRAL
PART. IT RESULTED IN CREATING
PROPOSITION ONE A. AT THE TIME
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT IT WAS
SP FIFTY- DIFFERENT SP FIFTY
THEN WE'RE DEALING WITH NOW.
BUT TIM WAS INTEGRAL PART OF
THAT AND I DISPLAY THIS PICTURE
WITH A- FRAME IT'S JUST
PROPOSITION ONE A SCHOOL BOND
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
NEGOTIATING TEAM. AND IT WAS
TERMS GENIUS IN SO MANY
RESPECTS TO COME UP WITH THIS.
RECORD BREAKING COMPROMISE THAT
IS FORMED THE FOUNDATION OF
EVERY SCHOOL BOND SINCE THEN WE
DID A B. SIXTEEN MY EASURE IN
THE U. S. TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO AND TWO
THOUSAND FOUR THAT ARNOLD DID A
COUPLE AND THEN. THE INDUSTRY
DID SOME BUT IT REALLY WAS AN
ELEGANT SOLUTION TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO BE ABLE TO BUILD MORE
SCHOOLS ON THE ONE HAND HOW TO
MODERNIZE SCHOOLS INNER CITIES
AND THE LIKE AND IT WAS PRETTY
INCREDIBLE. AND IT IS HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE LOST HIM
WHAT A GREAT GREAT TALENT HE
RETIRED FROM ACTIVE LOBBYING.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX. BUT
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO WRITE-
BUT PUT IT PERIODICALLY ON
PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES IN VARIOUS
ONLINE. IN VARIOUS ONLINE
OUTLETS. HE LOVES TO COOK IN
HIS WAY IN HIS IT HIM IN HIS
WIFE'S HOME THROUGH OFTEN WERE
DESIGNATION OF THE WHOLE QUOTE
PLAN HOLIDAY CELEBRATIONS. TIM
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE SUSAN
SUGGESTED HIS SONS CHRIS HIS
WIFE BOBBIE JO KEVIN SIBLINGS-
MATT COYLE. AND JANET WOLF CHEF
WHOSE HUSBAND WAS GENIUS
UNFORTUNATELY PASSED AWAY M.
HELMER HUSBAND JORGE. JENNY
CUNNINGHAM HUSBAND TOM
CELEBRATION FOR LIFE WAS HELD
SOME BACK IN AUGUST I WANTED
THE SENATE BODY TO RECOGNIZE
HIS EXTRAORDINARY CONTRIBUTIONS
AND ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
HIS MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG PLEASE BRING
MR QUAYLE'S NAME TO THE DESK
AND BE RECOGNIZED IN A GERMAN
IN MEMORY BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. NEXT REAL
RECOGNIZE SINNER BRADFORD.
CENTRE BRADFORD. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND I RISE TO GERMAN.
IN MEMORY. OF A GREAT
INDIVIDUAL A FOOTBALL LEGEND.
NONE OTHER THAN SAM LEWIS
CUNNINGHAM JUNIOR BETTER KNOWN
AS SAM BAM CUNNINGHAM SAM
PASSED AWAY THIS MORNING IN
INGLEWOOD. HE WAS BORN IN SANTA
BARBARA NINETEEN FIFTY AND HE
PLAYED COLLEGE FOOTBALL AS WE
ALL KNOW FOR U. S. C. SAM WAS
NOT ONLY A GREAT FOOTBALL
PLAYER HE WAS A. GREAT.
INDIVIDUAL HE WAS A GOOD FRIEND
AND JUST A HUMBLE SPIRIT-
UNLESS PEOPLE KNEW WHO HE WAS
WHEN YOU WALKED UP HE WAS
UNASSUMING AND- DIDN'T CARE
ABOUT BEING RECOGNIZED BUT ONCE
HE WAS RECOGNIZED SHE WAS A
CENTER OF ATTRACTION. AND IT'S
OFTEN SAID THAT CM CHANGED
FOOTBALL FOREVER. HIS
PERFORMANCE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
AGAINST ALABAMA MANY SAY HOPE
TO DO MORE FOR RECRUITING OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THE
SOUTHEAST CONFERENCE IN THE
SOUTH. THAN ANY OTHER EVENT
BEAR BRYANT WAS NOTED AS SAYING
I HAVE TO GET ME SOME OF THEM
REFERRED TO BLACK PLAYERS AFTER
SAM DECIMATED THIS TEAM. TIM
O'BRIEN'S FORMER ASSISTANT- WHO
COACHED AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
ALABAMA. ONE SAID SAM
CUNNINGHAM DID MORE TO
INTEGRATE ALABAMA IN SIXTY
MINUTES THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
DID IN TWENTY YEARS HE WAS
SELECTED THE FIRST ROUND IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE DRAFT
NFL DRAFT AND PLAYED TEN
SEASONS FOR THE NEW ENGLAND
PATRIOTS AS FULL BACK. HE
BECAME THE PATRIOTS ALL TIME
LEADING RUSHER IT WAS
INTERJECTED INTO THE COLLEGE
HALL OF FAME. AND IN THE
PATRIOTS HALL OF FAME IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN. HE PASSED AWAY AS
I STATED THIS MORNING IN
INGLEWOOD AT HOME. WITH HIS
LOVING WIFE SEEN IVORY WHICH
MANY OF YOU PROBABLY KNOW SHE
SERVED AS CHIEF OF STAFF FOR
SENATOR ROD RIGHT BOTH HERE IN
THE SENATE. AND IN THE SIMPLY.
AND HIS LOVING DAUGHTER SAMADI
WHO IS A DEPUTY TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- AUTUMN BURKEAND- HE
ALSO LEAVES TO CHERISH HIS
MEMORY HIS YOUNGER BROTHER.
RANDALL CUNNINGHAM WHO ALSO WAS
A COLLEGE STANDOUT FOOTBALL
PLAYER IN NFL GREAT IN ITS OWN
RIGHT. MEMBERS I ACTUALLY DO
TURN IN THE MEMORY OF THE
AMAZING INDIVIDUALS THAT. IN
SAM BAM CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU
SIR BRADFORD- YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR NEXT A GERMAN MEMORY.
I STAND TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF A YOUNG MAN BY THE
NAME OF VANCE TREVOR ROBINSON A
NAME THAT PROBABLY. MEANS
NOTHING TO MANY OF THE FOLKS HE
WAS A TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD YOUNG
MAN WHO LIVED IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD AND I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF CALLING. A FRIEND
BORN IN INGLEWOOD IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE VANCE WAS RAISED BY
HIS GRANDPARENTS IN GARDENA
RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER FROM
ME. VANCE WAS EDUCATED AT
GARDENA SCHOOLS HE ATTENDED MY
ALMA MATER PRETTY ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL THEN HE WENT ON TO MARIA
REGINA MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HE
GRADUATED FROM SERRA. HIGH
SCHOOL. VANCE WAS A RABBIT
STUDENT ATHLETE WHO ENJOYED
PLAYING A WIDE VARIETY OF
SPORTS FROM BASEBALL FOOTBALL
IN BASKETBALL IT WAS TO
BASEBALL THAT I MADAM AS A TEN
YEAR OLD I WAS BLESSED TO COACH
FOR SIXTEEN YEARS AND HE WAS
ONE OF THE YOUNG MAN WHO.
IMPACTED MY LIFE AND ALLOWED ME
TO INSTILL WHAT LITTLE I KNEW
ABOUT BASEBALL INTO HIM BUT-
BELIEVE HE INSTILLED MORE AND
WITH ME AND HIS. LOVE FOR LIFE
IS. FUNNY SENSE OF HUMOR AND HE
WOULD. KIND OF DESCRIBED AS- A
KNOW IT ALL BUT NOT IN A COCKY
SINCE HE WAS A KNOW IT ALL
BECAUSE HE'S A WELL READ
INQUISITIVE T. EIGHTY WAS A
PRECOCIOUS KID. AND I ENJOYED
EVERY MINUTE OF HIM PLAYING
WITH ME- IT IS FUNNY STORY WE
MADE THE PLAYOFFS THAT YEAR.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY. VANCE WAS
ABLE TO PLAY BECAUSE- THE WEEK
LEADING UP TO THE PLAYOFFS HE'S
RIDING HIS MINI. RT GETS HIT.
AND GOT BANGED UP PRETTY BAD
NOTHING SERIOUS BUT- HE WAS IN
CRUTCHES AND- KASTEN MOST KIDS
WOULD HAVE STAYED AT HOME
RECUPERATING IN AND MANY IN
THERE- INJURIES VANCE WAS ON
THE TEAM BENCH CHEERING FOR HIS
COLLEAGUES- IN THAT PLAYOFF AND
THAT'S WHO. VANCE WAS- HE JUST
IT'S AMAZING YOUNG MAN. HE
ALSO- TO ATTEND A REGGIE BUSH'S
FOOTBALL CAMP IN SAN DIEGO-
THROUGH THE CAMPAIGN MET MANY
NFL PLAYERS AND EVEN PRESENTED
THEM WITH NFL FOOTBALL SIGNED
BY A LOT OF THE HALL OF FAMERS.
PANTS EVEN PLAYED AT DODGER
STADIUM AFTER PLAYING FOR ME
WITH HIS LITTLE LEAGUE TEAM.
WON A DIVISION TITLE. THE SOUTH
CHORDS HIGH SCHOOL PENCE MADE
AVIATION HISTORY. HE WAS THE
YOUNG IS. INDIVIDUAL TO SOLO IN
UNITED STATES HE DID IT ON THE
SIXTEENTH BIRTHDAY OUR HEART OR
MEMORIAL AIRPORT RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER FROM MY HOUSE. MOST
STUDENTS STARTED. TRAINING FOR
AS A PILOT AT SIXTEEN BUT FANS
COULDN'T WAIT HE STARTED AT
FOURTEEN AS STATED HE WAS JUST
ALWAYS AHEAD OF HIS TIME I JUST
ALWAYS ENGAGED INQUISITIVE. AND
WANTED TO LEARN HE LOGGED MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOURS
IN THE AIR. AND IT WAS HIS
DREAM TO BECOME A COMMERCIAL
PILOT AND HAD HE NOT BEEN TAKEN
AWAY FROM US SO. SUDDENLY ENDS
HE I HAVE NO DOUBT HE WOULD
HAVE DONE THAT. HI AS LONG AS
WELL AS MANY OTHER- LIKE THE
DEFICIENCY OF RECOGNIZES
INCREDIBLE ACHIEVEMENTS AND HIS
HARD WORK IN JUST A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME. PENCE STRONGLY
BELIEVE WHATEVER YOUR MIND CAN
CONCEIVE YOU WILL ACHIEVE
BECAUSE IF IT'S MEANT TO BE
IT'S UP TO ME. IT HAS A STATED
HE WAS SHARP HE WAS SMART HE
WAS ENTHUSIASTIC. HE WAS FUNNY-
HE WAS JUST ALL AROUND
SPORTSMAN JUST SAID GREAT
INDIVIDUAL. AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK HIS GRANDFATHER FOR.
ALWAYS KEEPING ME UP TO DATE ON
WHAT VANCE WAS INVOLVED IN HIS
MEMORY WILL BE KEPT ALIVE BY
THE PEOPLE WHO EMBRACED HIM- MY
BRACES PRODUCTION UNITS IN THE
COUNTLESS OTHERS WHO INSPIRED
BY HIS LEGACY- TO CREATE AND
THAT HE CREATED AT SUCH A YOUNG
AGE AGAIN ICE EXTEND MY DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO HIS GRANDPARENTS.
AND TO ALL OF HIS FRIENDS AND
THE FOLKS IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
MEMBERS ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF VANCE TREVOR
ROBINSON. THESE ARE REFERENCING
HAVE ONE MORE GERMAN MEMORY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ENJOYMENT MEMORY. YES THIS
FINAL JOURNEY MEMORIES OF
INDIVIDUAL WHO REALLY NEEDS NO
INTRODUCTION IN THIS BUILDING
MALCOLM BENNETT I WOULD SAY
REALTOR EXTRAORDINAIRE WHO- HAS
BEEN A ACTIVE MEMBER OF
ADVOCATING FOR LEGISLATION AND
RIGHT FOR. NOT ONLY PROPERTY
OWNERS BUT TENANTS AS WELL- HE
WAS A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
UNDERSERVED APARTMENT OWNERS IN
UNINCORPORATED AREAS OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN THE WOOD AND
OF COURSE LONG BEACH WORDS
OFFICE WAS. FOR FORTY SIX YEARS
HE SPENT IN THE HOUSING
INDUSTRY FROM WORKING IN
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY TO
BECOMING A REALTOR AND I REAL
ESTATE BROKER MAPPING DEDICATED
HIS LIFE TO BECOMING ONE OF THE
MOST EXPERIENCED REALTORS IN
THE COUNTY. WITH IMMENSE
FAMILIARITY WITH PROPERTY
SALES AS A LICENSED BROKER
CONTRACTOR. MR BENNETT- CAREER
AND RENTAL HOUSING INDUSTRY
INCLUDES THE CREATION OF HIS
REAL ESTATE FIRM INTERNATIONAL
REALTY AND INVESTMENT SPACE IN
LONG BEACHWHICH PROVIDED
MANAGEMENT SALES AND
ACQUISITIONS. OF INCOME
PRODUCING PROPERTIES- HE
RECEIVED IN MANY NATIONAL
STATEWIDE AND LOCAL WARDS- MR
BENNETT WAS I WHO WAS KNOWN
RIGHT AS I STATED. AS A LOCAL
ICON ON- SIX AND STATE AND NOW
SO WHEN IT CAME TO. A HOUSING
ISSUES IT WAS LAST YEAR WHEN I
WAS APPOINTED. VICE CHAIR OF
THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY TASK
FORCE AND WE REDUCE THE
LEGISLATION. FOR THE TENANT
LANDLORD. PROTECTION ACT IT WAS
MR BENNETT WHO I FIRST SOUGHT
OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WAS
COVERING ALL ASPECTS OF MAKING
SURE THAT WE NOT ONLY PROTECTED
TENANTS BUT THE LANDLORDS AS
WELL- HE WAS EAGER TO ENGAGE ME
AND AS MANY- LEGISLATORS-
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER ON THIS
ISSUE. AND HE MADE SURE THAT HE
LOOKED OUT AGAIN NOT ONLY FOR
THE TENANT BUT THE LANDLORD AS
WELL. AND HE NEVER CAME WITH A
ADVERSARIAL APPROACH YOUR ANGER
HE WAS ALWAYS WITH A SMILE AND
MISTER B. LET ME SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO HERE YOU ALWAYS TRY TO
FIND A WAY. TO MAKE IT WORK AND
THAT'S HOW WE WERE ABLE TO PASS
THAT PEACEFUL LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR BECAUSE OF MISTER MISTER
BENNETT'S- HELP HE WAS ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE MINORITY OF
APARTMENT OWNERS ASSOCIATION.
AND THAT SPOKE OUT AGAINST A
PUBLIC POLICIES THAT WAS
HARMFUL TO THE INDUSTRY-
STATED. IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN BENNETT WAS HONORED
WITH LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT
AWARDS BY THE BLACK BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION FOR HIS WORK. THAT
HE HAD DONE ON BEHALF OF REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRY IN ITS HISTORY.
OF VOLUNTEER SERVICE WITH A
VARIETY OF REAL ESTATE
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. MR MR BENNETT WAS ALSO
CLOSELY INVOLVED WITH PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT. FOR THE MANY
APARTMENT OWNERS OF LOS ANGELES
HISTORICALLY BLACK CHURCHES.
THOSE WHO KNEW HIM BEST POINTED
TO HIS HIS SUCCESSFUL
MANAGEMENT AS BEING A FUNCTION
OF TREATING RESIDENTS LIKE
FAMILY. IF A RESIDENT FELL
BEHIND ON RENT HE WILL WORK
WITH THEM. TO HELP THEM- PAY
THEIR DEBT. INCLUDING DOING
DIFFERENT JOBS ON SITE UNTIL
THEY COULD. GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET- AGAIN HE WAS A COMMUNITY
ICON IN FOR. FOURTH TERM SHE
SERVED AS THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF SOUTH CENTRAL
REGIONAL CENTER FOR THE
DISABLED AND TWO TERMS AS
PRESIDENT OF THE CRIPPLED
CHILDREN'S SOCIETY- NASTY MR
BENNETT SERVED AS AN EXPERT
WITNESS FOR SEVERAL
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES AND
WAS INDUCTED INTO THE CARESS
CONGRESSIONAL FAME. RECORDS FOR
OUTSTANDING. COMMUNITY SERVICE
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. ON I
JUST CALLED MALCOLM BENNETT.
WOULD TRAVEL TO SACRAMENTO
AGAIN ON A REGULAR BASIS TO
PASSIONATELY ADVOCATE FOR THE
REPORT IN INDUSTRY AND IN
AUGUST HE WAS FAMILIAR FIGURE.
WALKING THROUGH THIS BUILDING
FOR THE LAST TWENTY. THIRTY
PLUS YEARS HE WAS WELL KNOWN AS
A COP IN AN OVEN VISOR HERO TO
MANY MENTOR HE WAS A FRIEND OF
MINE. HE WAS A KIND SPIRIT
CARING MENTOR ENDED IN
DEDICATION TO BETTERING THE
LIVES OF THOSE AROUND HIM AND
HE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED I WAS
BLESSED TO HAVE HIM AS A
FRIEND. AND HE HAS IMPACTED MY
LIFE HE WAS A FATHER HUSBAND
BENEFACTOR PHILANTHROPIST
ENTREPRENEUR LEADER AND A
BROTHER TO ALL OF US. MEMBERS
ASKED THAT WE TURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MALCOLM BENNETT.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD IF
YOU'D PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
FORWARDS TO THE DESK. SO THAT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO GO NEXT TO
CENTER ADMIN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR WHO TARO HERTADO WHO
HAS TO. CENTER MAN AND THEN
CENTER FORTINO. CENTER ADMIN
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO ASK THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF MY
COUSIN. DEBRA LYNN FASCIO. MY
COUSIN DEBBIE WAS JUST SIXTY
FIVE YEARS OLD AND SHE DIED
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHT TWO
THOUSAND ONE- IN PORTER BILL
SURROUNDED BY HER FAMILY. SHE
IS PRECEDED IN HER DEATH BY HER
PARENTS LESLIE JONES MY AUNT
BARBARA JEAN EGGMAN JONES AND
HER BROTHER STEPHEN JONES. MY
COUSIN DEBBIE WAS BORN IN PORT
OF ILL THEY RELOCATED TO CASTRO
VALLEY WHEN SHE WAS A YOUNG
CHILD AND THEN. AND SHE WAS THE
OLDEST OF SIX CHILDREN SO SHE
WAS A NATURAL CARE GIVER- THEY
MOVED BACK DOWN TO PORT THOSE
ARE YOUNG ADULTS WHERE SHE
COMPLETED HER EDUCATION. AS THE
ELDEST CHILD AND PEOPLE HAVE
HEARD ME TALK ABOUT MY AUNT WHO
SUFFERED FROM PRETTY PROFOUND
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND MY
COUSIN DEBBIE BEING THE OLDEST-
IT WAS HER ROLE TO TRY TO TAKE
CARE OF MY AUNT AS BEST SHE
COULD- AND THAT OFTEN INCLUDED
FIGHTING ON THE STREETS AND
TRYING TO GET AROUND TO HELP-
MY AUNT AND MY COUSIN SINCE
WORKED- FARMERS. DIFFERENCES
OAKLAND. AND SO FOR EVERYBODY
WHO LOVES FARMERS MARKETS IN
THOSE FRESH FRUITS AND PRODUCE
IN HONEY. THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
BACK IN THE FIELDS PICKING
THAT. PACKING IT UP THE NIGHT
BEFORE AND GETTING UP BEFORE
DAWN TO BE ABLE TO DRIVE TO THE
MARKET TO GET IT THERE FOR
FOLKS. IT TAKES A LOT OF
ORGANIZATION AND A LOT OF HARD
WORK TO GET THOSE THINGS DONE.
AND I'M PROUD TO SAY MY COUSIN
DEBBIE WAS A LARGE PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY FOR YEARS AND YEARS-
SHE IS. WEAK LIKE MY COUSIN I
DID NOT AGREE ON A WHOLE LOT OF
THINGS POLITICALLY. UP WE ALL
CERTAINLY AGREED ON THE VALUE
OF FAMILY THE VALUE OF HARD
WORK. AND THE VALUE OF GOOD
COOKING AND FOOD- WE ALSO
AGREED. THAT OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND NEEDS
HELP- I COULD NOT SEE MY COUSIN
WITHOUT HER. EX ADDING ME TO
PLEASE DO SOMETHING TO HELP FIX
OUR SYSTEM AND- IS CERTAINLY
DEBBIE I HAVE TRIED MY VERY
BEST AND WILL CONTINUE. THAT IN
YOUR MEMORY. DEBBIE WAS A GREAT
COOK VERY ACTIVE IN HER CHURCH
COMMUNITY. AGAIN EVEN THOUGH
SHE WAS JUST SIXTY FIVE GROWN
UP IN THE VALLEY AND HAVING A
HARD LIFE FULL OF WORK. LIFE
AGES YOU QUICKLY SO WELL DEBBIE
WAS A CARE GIVER AND COULD BE
VERY SOFT YOU CAN ALSO BE VERY
STRONG. SHE WAS THE QUEEN BEE
OF HER FAMILY. AND I'M SURE- UP
IN HEAVEN MY DAD AND HER MOM
AND HER GRANDMOTHER MOM JUDY
ARE PREPARING THE TABLE. FOR
HER AND THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE-
ONE OF THE BEST MEALS YOU'LL
EVER HAVE SO. I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF MY
COUSIN DEBBIE AND SHE LEAVES
BEHIND TO MOURN HER HER HUSBAND
RICHARD. SHE KNOWS AND SHE WAS
IN HIGH SCHOOL- AND I AND MY
COUSINS- DAVID. AT SANDRA.
MICHELLE IN FREDDIE- SHE WILL
BE LOVED AND MISSED FOREVER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
EDMUND- PLEASE BRING YOUR
COUSIN'S NAME FORWARD TO THE
DESK. AND THE C. CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WILL. ADJOURN IN
MEMORY IN HER NAME TODAY THANK
YOU. NEXT SENATOR TODD. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND- MY
CONDOLENCES TO- DEBBIE AND- THE
FOSTER FAMILY AS WELL AS B.
HEDMAN FAMILY- SHE WILL BE
MISSED AND I THOUGHT ABOUT AND
OF COURSE- SOMEONE TO REALLY
LOOK TOWARDS OF OVER CREATING
LEGISLATION HERE IN ADVOCATING
ON BEHALF OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
ASK THAT THE SENATE ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY OF CAROL MILLS WHO
PASSED AWAY JULY FOURTEENTH
AFTER BATTLING ALS. CARROLL
SERVED AS A REPRESENTATIVE ON
THE FRONT AND UNIFIED SCHOOL
BOARD FOR NEARLY TWO DECADES.
IN THAT TIME SHE WAS RELENTLESS
IN HER FIGHT ON BEHALF OF
STUDENTS FROM SECURING AIR
CONDITIONING IN SCHOOLS.
CUSTOMERS CAN BE INTERNATIONAL
BACCALAUREATE PROGRAM IN FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND
SHE NEVER STOPPED THE GIRL WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH ALS SHE
CONTINUED HER ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF STUDENTS AT FRESNO
UST. SHE WAS COMMITTED BUT THAT
SHE ATTENDED MEETINGS EVEN
WHILE HER HEALTH DECLINED TO
THE POINT SHE WAS IN A
WHEELCHAIR AND HAD TO
COMMUNICATE USING THE COMPUTER
GENERATED VOICE. CAROL HAD A
DEEP IMPACT ON FRESNO AND TO
ALL WHO KNEW HER AND THE
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN. MADE BETTER
THROUGH HER SERVICE. AND
DEDICATION. SO WE ADJOURNED
TODAY'S SESSION IN MEMORY OF
CAROL MILLS. THANK YOU SENATOR
HER TADO. PLEASE BRING THE NAME
FORWARD SO THEY CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
ANOTHER ATTORNEY MEMORY MEMORY
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO ASK
THE SENATE ADJOURNED THE MEMORY
OF FRANCISCO VEHICLE MASS WHO
PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST TWENTY
FIFTH. AS A YOUNG BOY FRANCISCO
IMMIGRATED FROM. GENERAL DATA
AND NOBLE YOUR MEDICAL TO
CALIFORNIA WHERE SHE BEGAN
WORKING IN THE FIELDS AT THE
FARM WORKER AND THIS IS WHERE
HE STARTED HIS FAMILY. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO FRANCISCO
BEGAN HIS CAREER AS A FARMER
EVENTUALLY BUYING HIS OWN FARM.
OVER THE YEARS HE GREW TOMATOES
RAISINS AND WINE GRAPES PEACHES
AND LATER LEMONS. HIS RANCH
JUST OUTSIDE THE CITY OF SINGER
WAS HOME TO MANY HAPPY MEMORIES
FOR HIS FAMILY AND ESPECIALLY
HIS GRANDCHILDREN. FROM
FRANCISCO IS REMEMBERED BY HIS
FAMILY AND THE COMMUNITY FOR
BEING A GREAT COOK. HAVING AN
INFECTIOUS SMILE AND A GOOD
SENSE OF HUMOR. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE GUADALUPE VEHICLE
MINUS SIX CHILDREN AND
SEVENTEEN GRANDCHILDREN AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. I ASK
AGAIN THAT THE SENATE ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY OF FRANCISCO VEHICLE
MASS WHO PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST
TWENTY FIFTH THANK YOU SENATOR
HER TADO PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. I DO
NOT SEE SENATOR MITCHELL SAID
AND I'M SORRY PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I ASKED THE SENATE
TO TURN TODAY IN MEMORY OF DR
YOUNG HE MIGHT KONG WHO IS
PERHAPS ONE OF THE WORLD'S.
MOST WELL KNOWN. FOR MY PURPOSE
AND COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS IN THE
KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. DR HONG
WAS A BELOVED HUSBAND AND
FATHER OF FOUR. WHO CAME TO
THIS COUNTRY FROM SOUTH KOREA
IN NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR IS AN
EXCHANGE STUDENT. HE GRADUATED
FROM UCLA IN NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE WITH A DEGREE IN CHEMISTRY.
HE HAD TO WORK HIS WAY THROUGH
COLLEGE. AND FINISHES LAST
SEMESTER UCLA ON TUITION
BORROWED FROM HIS MATH
PROFESSOR. AND THAT ACTIVE
COMPASSION INSPIRE A LIFELONG
DETERMINATION TO SUCCEED. AND
ADD TO EVENTUALLY ESTABLISH A
FOUNDATION THAT PROVIDED
SCHOLARSHIPS TO COLLEGE
STUDENTS PAYING IT FORWARD.
AFTER GRADUATION DR HONG BEGAN
HIS CAREER WORKING FOR A
COMPANY IN CHEMICAL RESEARCH.
ALONG THE WAY HE DEVELOPED A
COATING FOR PAINT THAT HAD
SIGNIFICANT COMMERCIAL PROMISE.
HE BELIEVE THAT HIGH
PERFORMANCE COIL COATINGS SUCH
AS YOU DEVELOP WOULD BE LESS
HARMFUL TO THE ENVIRONMENT AND
THAT HE COULD DEVELOP MORE OF
THESE. HIS WIFE COMMITTED TO
THE HARD WORK AND DEDICATION IT
WOULD TAKE TO BECOME A
SUCCESSFUL ENTREPRENEUR. HE
FOUNDED DURA COAT IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX. THE RECORD IS NOW
ONE OF THE LARGEST PAINT
PRODUCT COMPANIES IN THE WORLD.
AND DR HONG CHAIRED THE COMPANY
UNTIL HIS PASSING EARLIER THIS
YEAR. DR HONG WAS COMMITTED TO
ITS COMMUNITY AND WAS
INCREDIBLY TERRIBLE. IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AFTER CIVIL
UNREST IN LOS ANGELES.
FOLLOWING THE TRIAL OF POLICE
OFFICERS INVOLVED IN THE
ARRESTS AND BEATING OF RODNEY
KING- HONG DEDICATED HIMSELF TO
PROMOTING CULTURAL
UNDERSTANDING AND TOLERANCE. HE
FOUNDED AND SERVED AS CHAIRMAN
OF A FOUNDATION DEDICATED TO
PRESERVING THE MEMORY OF THEIR
SON ANG TRONG HO. AN EARLY
LEADER OF THE LOCAL CREAM
MERICAN IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. HE
ALSO FOUNDED THE M. L. HONG
FOUNDATION PICKING THE FIRST
INITIAL FROM HIM AND HIS WIFE
LORI. IN TWO THOUSAND ONE WHICH
IS DONATED TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS TWO. DIFFERENT CROSSES
HUNG HIMSELF DONATED TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF TWO ENDOWED
CHAIRS. AT UCLA'S DEPARTMENT OF
CHEMISTRY AND BIOCHEMISTRY. BAG
GIFT CREATED THE DR BIANCHI
HONG ENDOWED CHAIR AND POLYMER
SCIENCE AND A DOCUMENT ON THE
HONG ENDOWED CHAIR IN MATERIALS
INNOVATION. WHICH SUPPORTS
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH WITH
APPLICATIONS RANGING FROM
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY.
DR HONG WAS AWARDED THE ORDER
OF CIVIL MERIT CHAMELEON METAL
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE IN ORDER
OF CIVIL MERIT ROSE OF SHARON
MEDAL THE HIGHEST MEDAL GIVEN
TO CIVILIANS IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. BY THE GOVERNMENT OF
SOUTH KOREA. PONG PONG PASSED
AWAY ONE YEAR AFTER HIS WIFE
LAURIE YOUNG HELP HONG WITH
WHOM HE WAS MARRIED NEARLY%
FORTY YEARS. HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS CHILDREN CINDY MICHELLE
CHRISTINE AND DAVID HONG. HIS
GRANDDAUGHTER FINAL PHONE CALL
RAN IN FIVE YOUNGER SIBLINGS
BOOKIE HONG MANN KI HONG. LEE
SOOK HEE HAN AN EMPTY JAIL. DR
HANS LIFE IS A REALLY
EMBODIMENT OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM AND WHAT THIS COUNTRY CAN
OFFER AND WHAT IMMIGRANTS LIKE
HIM LIKE MY PARENTS CAN OFFER
TO THIS COUNTRY. HE'S GONE BUT
HIS MEMORY WILL HOPEFULLY NEVER
BE FORGOTTEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTERMAN PLEASE BRING HIS
SAME FORWARD SO HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BUT
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE SENATOR
PORTENT TINO. THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT- TODAY I RISE. TO
PASS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF THE LANE- CATHERINE HADLEY
ROBINSON WHO WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE. SHE IS
THE WIDOW OF THE LATE MAC
ROBINSON WHO WAS IN NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX SILVER MEDALIST
SILVER MEDALIST IN THE TWO
HUNDRED METERS IN BERLIN
GERMANY. AN OLDER BROTHER OF
BASEBALL LEGEND JACKIE
ROBINSON. SHE PASSED AWAY
WEDNESDAY AUGUST EIGHTEENTH.
DELANO NATIVE WAS A NATIVE OF
THOMASVILLE GEORGIA AND WAS THE
EIGHTH OF FIFTEEN CHILDREN. SHE
WAS ALSO THE HOMECOMING QUEEN
IN HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE. SHE SETTLED IN
PASADENA AND MERRI MAC ROBINSON
IN NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE. TO THE
UNION WERE BORN WAYNE ROBINSON
KATHY ROBINSON YOUNG. BETTY
ROBINSON COLEMAN WILLIAM
ROBINSON ROSE ROBINSON AND
EDWIN ROBINSON EDWARD ROBINSON.
ALONG WITH RAISING CHILDREN SHE
IMAC. ALSO RAISED- KENNY
ROBINSON PHILLIP ROBINSON
DONALD ROBINSON IN THE RAIN
ROBINSON HICKS. AS A LONGTIME
MEMBER OF SCOTT UNITED
METHODIST CHURCH DELANO SANG
WITH THE CHURCH CHOIR. SOCIALLY
ALONGSIDE MAX SHE ENJOYED
VOLUNTEERING AT THE ARC OF
JESSE OWENS GAMES AND SPECIAL
OLYMPICS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SHE ATTENDED MANY
EVENTS WHICH PROMOTED THE
DODGERS MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL
AND THE TEAM USA OLYMPICS I CAN
TELL YOU SHE WAS AN AMBASSADOR
FOR. HERSELF FOR THE ROBINSON
FAMILY LEGACY AND FOR THE
DODGERS AND COULD ALWAYS BE
SEEN AROUND TOWN WEARING ONE OF
THE MEN- JACKIE ROBINSON'S
DODGER JACKETS. HERE WAS IN
NURSING WHERE THE EXPERIENCE
SHE ATTAINED ASSISTED HER IN
TAKING CARE OF HER BELOVED
HUSBAND MACK ROBINSON UNTIL HIS
UNTIMELY DEATH MARCH TWELFTH
TWO THOUSAND. DELANO LOVED HER
CITY AND REPRESENTED THE FAMILY
SEVERAL TIMES IN THE BLACK
PASADENA'S BLACK HISTORY
PARADE. IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
THE PASADENA JOURNAL RECOGNIZED
HER AS ONE OF THE WOMEN OF
ACHIEVEMENT IN PASADENA. SHE
LEAVES MANY GRANDCHILDREN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN SIBLINGS FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS TO CHERISH HER
MEMORY AND IT WAS ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO SEE HER AROUND TOWN
WITH A BIG SMILE AND JUST TO
HEAR IT THE WONDERFUL STORIES
ABOUT. PASADENA JACK ROCK
JACKIE ROBINSON AND MAC
ROBINSON SHE WILL SURELY BE
MISSED AND I AM PLEASED TO SEE
US ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER PROTEIN- MAKE
SURE HER NAME S BROUGHT
FORWARD SO SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE. TO ASK THE SENATE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF SAVI
TO FRANKIE AND- SAVI WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN TWENTY NINE IN A
RUN AFTER COMPLETING HER HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION. IN VIA
WRAPPED IN LEBANON SHE WAS
AWARDED A SCHOLARSHIP TO ATTEND
THE AMERICAN INTERNATIONAL
COLLEGE IN MASSACHUSETTS. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE SOBBING AND
HER BROTHER MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
AND FOUNDED THE WESTERN
DISPOSAL COMPANY LATER KNOWN AS
WESTERN WASTE INDUSTRIES. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX SAVI MARRIED
HER HUSBAND OF SIXTY THREE
YEARS RALPH TO FRANK IN AND
THEY WERE BLESSED WITH THREE
CHILDREN. RICHARD SANDRA AND
GRAY. A LIFELONG ADVOCATE FOR
EDUCATION OUR YOUTH AND WOMEN
AROUND THE WORLD SAVI
TIRELESSLY SERVED COUNTLESS
ORGANIZATIONS BENEFITING THAT
THE ASPIRIN. ARMENIA AND
ARTSAKH. AFTER THE TRAGIC LOSS
OF THEIR SON RICHARD IN
NINETEEN NINETY SAVI AND RALPH
HELPED ESTABLISH ST MARY'S
RICHARDS. TO FRANKIE IN
PRESCHOOL LAST YEAR THE SCHOOL
CELEBRATED ITS FORTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF PROVIDING
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION TO OUR
COMMUNITIES CHILDREN. SOBBING
AND- ESTABLISHED THE RICHARD TO
FRANK IN MEMORIAL FUND
SUPPORTING COLLEGE STUDENTS OF
ARMENIA. OF ARMENIAN DESCENT
WERE PARTICIPATING IN THE
ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA'S
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM IN
WASHINGTON DC. SOBBING WAS A
LONGTIME SUPPORTER OF THE
ARMENIAN INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S
ASSOCIATION LOS ANGELES
AFFILIATE THE ARMENIAN
MISSIONARY ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA FOR FRIEND AND CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS IN THE U. S. C.
INSTITUTE OF ARMENIAN STUDIES
JUST TO NAME A FEW OF HER CIVIC
ACTIVITIES. SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER HUSBAND RALPH DAUGHTER
SANDRA AND SON IN LAW PAUL HER
SON GREG AND DAUGHTER IN LAW
CAROLINE HER BROTHER COSTLY.
AND HIS FAMILY AND HER
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN HER FAMILY AND
FRIENDS IN THE COUNTLESS
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE LIVES SHE
TOUCHED WILL FOREVER CHERISH
HER MEMORY AND CELEBRATE HER
LEGACY OF INVALUABLE SERVICE
BOTH TO CALIFORNIA TO THE
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY. AND TO THE
GREATER SOCIETY AND HER LOSS IS
TRULY HEARTFELT ACROSS OUR
COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME RICHARD IN HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU SENATOR
FORTINO PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
OR MORE ALLIES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR PARDON TINA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT HIGHRISE TEST
THE STATE SENATE TWO GERMAN IN
THE MEMORY. OF A GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE MEREDITH REYNOLDS. HIS
LIFE WILL NOT FIT IN ONE PAGE
SHE WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY IN SO
MANY WAYS A SCHOLAR A
COLLEGIATE ATHLETE. LAWYER
CHILD ADVOCATE COMMUNITY
ACTIVIST AND MENTOR COUNSELOR
FRIEND WIFE. MOTHER YEAH SHE
WAS ALSO IN THE- MEREDITH NEVER
STOP SHARING HER WISDOM HUMOR
SPARKLE IN LOVE UNTIL THE DAY
SHE LEFT US. SHE ALSO WAS THE
BIGGEST GROUPING FOR THE BAND
MISPLACED PRIORITIES I LIKE TO
THINK I WAS A GROUPIE THE BAND
BUT MEREDITH NEVER MISS ONE OF
THEIR CONCERTS OF COURSE. HER
HUSBAND WAS ONE OF THE LEADERS
OF THE BAND BUT SHE WAS ALWAYS
IN THE PARK AT THEIR CONCERTS
CHEERING ON THE BAND'S AS IF
SHE WAS AT WOODSTOCK. A DECADE
SERVING THE COMMUNITY OF
WALKING OUT OF FLINT REGION
BEYOND HER IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITIES FILLED SO MANY
ROLES THAT THEY WOULD FILL
WHOLE PAGES. OF ALL OF THE
NOTEWORTHY ACCOMPLISHMENTS SHE
SERVED ON THE LOCKING AND
UNIFIED SCHOOL GOVERNING BOARD
FROM NINETEEN NINETY TO TWO
THOUSAND TWO. AND AS PRESIDENT
SHE WAS THE FIRST WOMAN TO BE
PRESIDENT OF THE LOCKING YADA
EDUCATION FOUNDATION IN
NINETEEN. EIGHTY EIGHT NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE NINETEEN NINETY
SCHOOL YEARS SERVING ON THE LCF
PARKS AND RECREATION
COMMISSION. SHE OVERSAW THE
BUILDING OF THE PAVILION AND
REDESIGNING A PLAYGROUND AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THREE NEW
BATHROOMS SERVING AS BOND CHAIR
WOMAN SHE RAISED TWENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION. SHE FACILITATED
THE JOINT USE AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE CITY AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND SHE SPEARHEADED
THE FIVE STAR COALITION BETWEEN
BLOCKING OUT OF GLENDALE
BURBANK SOUTH PASADENA AND
PASADENA SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHERE
SHE ADVOCATED. FOR THE ON STATE
LEGISLATION AND OTHER ISSUES
BENEFITING FROM OUR SCHOOL
CHILDREN. HER LEGACY WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME AND HER LAST DAYS. HER
ONLY REQUEST. WAS I WANT TO
GIVE MONEY TO CHILDREN
SUFFERING FROM CANCER. BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT ANY CHILD TO GO
THROUGH THIS BUT SHE WENT
THROUGH SO SHE PUT MONEY WHERE
HER MOUTH WAS AND SHE- PRESSED.
TO HELP OTHER CANCER. VICTIMS
IN CANCER RESEARCH THE REDDIT
REYNOLDS FAMILY AND MANY PEOPLE
MERIDA TOUCH ARE HONORED TO
SUPPORT OUR WISHES AND THEY
CREATED THE MEREDITH REYNOLDS
FOUNDATION FOR CHILD CANCER
RESEARCH. AND MERIT IS SURVIVED
BY HER FAMILY HER HUSBAND TOM
DAUGHTERS ALEX AND BRITNEY. AND
IT IS WITH DEEP RESPECT AND
SOLEMN HEART THAT I TURNED IN
MEMORY OF MEREDITH RENTS. THANK
YOU SENATOR FORTINO PLEASE
BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE
MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. SENATOR FOURTEEN. THANK
YOU MAY FOR. I RISE TO ASK THE
STATE SENATE TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY. OF DR TRUDELL JONES
SKINNER. ON FRIDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SEVENTH. NOT ONLY DID I
LOSE A FRIEND. THE PASADENA
ALTADENA COMMUNITY LOST A
BELOVED COMMUNITY MEMBER DOCTOR
TO TELL JOHN SKINNER. DR
SKINNER WAS BORN AUGUST TENTH
NINETEEN SIXTY IN ARKANSAS.
THAT YOU ATTENDED STEVENS HIGH
SCHOOL AND GRADUATED IN THE
CLASS OF NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
AS THIS AS IT SALUTATORIAN AND
WAS A PART AND WAS A PART OF
PART OF THE NATIONAL HONOR
SOCIETY. DR SKINNER WENT ON TO
ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY OF
ARKANSAS AND AFTER GRADUATING
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO HER LIFE
JOURNEY. AS BEING AN EDUCATOR
WOULD BEGIN SHE MOVED TO DALLAS
TEXAS AND JOINED FIRST BAPTIST
CHURCH OF HAMILTON PARK WHERE
SHE MET AND MARRIED THE
REVEREND TYRONE SKINNER IN JULY
TWENTY NINTH NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. SHORTLY THEREAFTER THE
SCANNERS MOVED TO SACRAMENTO
AND THEN EVENTUALLY- THE PASTOR
WAS APPOINTED PASTOR OF
METROPOLITAN BAPTIST CHURCH IN
ALTADENA CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY
MOVED INTO THE TWENTY FIFTH
SENATE DISTRICT. DR SKINNER
WORKED FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
AS AN EDUCATOR AND
ADMINISTRATOR WITHIN THE
PASADENA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT DURING HER
PROFESSIONAL CAREER SHE
RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS AND IS
SHE EXCEEDED. IN HER PERSONAL
EDUCATION OBTAINING A MASTERS
DEGREE IN EDUCATION FROM CAL
POLY POMONA IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE AND A DOCTOR'S DEGREE IN
EDUCATION LEADERSHIP FROM AZUSA
PACIFIC IN NINETEEN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. TRUDELL
PARTICIPATED IN NUMEROUS
ORGANIZATIONS OF WHICH SHE MADE
A SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT AT THE
TIME OF HER UNFORTUNATE PASSING
SHE WAS A MEMBER OF THE PASSING
A GRAD GRAD CHAPTER OF ALPHA
KAPPA ALPHA SORORITY.
INCORPORATED THE A. S. A. P. S.
A. C. S. E. A. AND A. S. HA
PASSE P. A. S. C. WHERE SHE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING TO
PRODUCE THE ANNUAL BLACK RED
RIGHTS OF PASSAGE. EVENT ALSO
HELD AT METROPOLITAN BAPTIST
CHURCH. SHE WAS ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. OPERANDI HIM FOR
TOGETHER ON AN- EVENT ENTITLED
THE FIRST LADY'S HEALTH
INITIATIVE. IN OUR CHURCH LIFE
THAT METROPOLITAN BAPTIST
CHURCH TRUDELL PARTICIPATED IN
THE CHILDREN'S MINISTRY THE
YOUTH MINISTRY SUNDAY SCHOOL
VACATION BIBLE SCHOOL THE
DEACONESS MINISTRY. WHERE SHE
SERVED AS A CHAIR PERSON.
TRIGGERING MINISTRY PASTORAL
LEADERSHIP. RUSSIAN EDUCATION
THE WESTERN BAPTIST STATE
CONVENTION AND THE NATIONAL
BAPTIST CONVENTION SHE ALSO
ASSISTED HER HUSBAND PASTOR
TYRONE SKINNER BY ACTING AS THE
PASTORAL LIAISON FOR SUN FIRST
STUDY LESSONS AND CHURCH
COMMUNICATIONS AND EMAIL
MESSAGES SHE WAS A TRUE COLOR
IN BOTH THE ACADEMIC AND CHURCH
COMMUNITY. SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER HUSBAND TYRONE SKINNER HER
CHILDREN TYLER JORDAN SKINNER
AND TREAT ME BRIANNA SKINNER.
THE LAST TIME I WAS AT
METROPOLITAN BAPTIST CHURCH.
THE TRINITY WELCOMED ME INTO
THE CHURCH AND WAS. EMULATING
HER MOTHER'S LEADERSHIP BY
TAKING SUCH A LEADERSHIP ROLE
IN THAT SUNDAY SERVICE AND I
KNOW THE FAMILY IS DEEPLY.
DEEPLY DEPRESSED TODAY BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE HER SPARK IN HER AND
IT IS WONDERFUL TO SEE HOW MUCH
OF A WONDERFUL. EXAMPLE SHE SET
FOR HER CHILDREN AND HOW THEY
CARRY ON HER LEGACY DR SKINNER
WAS TRULY MESSED AND BY THE
CHURCH BY THE PASADENA SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND BY THE GREATER
COMMUNITY IN PASADENA ALTADENA.
AND I THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME-
JOURNEY IN HER MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU SENATOR FORTINO
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FOREST SO
SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
IMMORTALIZED BUT CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR RUBIO
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY WITH GREAT
SADNESS I ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
STANLEY EUGENE WHITE STAN WAS A
GRADUATE OF BALL PARK HIGH
SCHOOL AND LATER GRADUATED FROM
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY HE
MADE HIS LIFE IN SAN DIEGO
AFTER GRADUATING HE WORKED FOR
NEIL STEREO WHERE HE QUICKLY
ADVANCED AND THE COMPANY AND
EVENTUALLY PURCHASED THREE OF
THE STORES TO CREATE SANDOVAL
STEREO. AND WORK TIRELESSLY
UNTIL HIS RETIREMENT. GROWING
UP STAMPS PLAYED BASEBALL IN
THE SITE LITTLE LEAGUE IN
BALDWIN PARK AND ALSO
PARTICIPATED IN JUNIOR ALL
AMERICAN **** TIME. HIS DAD
JACK WHITE WITH HIS COACH AND
EVENTUALLY PRESIDENT OF BOTH
THOSE LEAKS. HE SHARED A CLOSE
LIFETIME RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS
FATHER. AND WITH HIS BIGGEST
FAN WHEN HIS FATHER JACK WHITE
BECAME THE FIRST ELECTED MAYOR
OF THE CITY OF BALDWIN PARK IN
THE EIGHTIES. AS HE GREW OLDER
AND HAD HIS OWN FAMILY DOWN
ALSO BECAME A COACH TO HIS SON
JACK. AND MULTIPLE SPORTS AND
WAS A SUPPORTER OF LA COSTA
CANYON HIGH SCHOOL IN HIS
COMMUNITY EVENTS NEED US HE WAS
AN AVID. BOATER AND SPENT MANY
SUMMERS TEACHING PEOPLE HOW TO
WATER SKI IN THE COLORADO RIVER.
IN SPITE OF SEVERAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES FROM HIS EARLY
YEARS. STAM LED TO A VERY FULL
LIFE FILLED ITH FUN
ADVENTUROUS. STAN WAS BRAVE AND
VERY RESILIENT. HE TRIED TO
MAKE IT TO SEPTEMBER TO SEE HIS
SON WALKED DOWN THE AISLE WITH
HIS BRIGHT. UNFORTUNATELY HE
DIDN'T MAKE IT BUT CHECK NOW
THAT YOUR FATHER IS ALWAYS WITH
YOU. STANNIS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE SARAH HIS SONS JACK AND
SIMON HIS DAUGHTER SUSIE HIS
MOTHER EDNA AND SISTERS ANGIE
AND JACKIE WHITE AND HIS NEPHEW
MICHAEL. STAN WAS CONSIDER
FAMILY TO ME. AND HE WILL BE
MESS HE WAS GONE TOO SOON AND
YOU'LL FOREVER BE IN OUR HEARTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY I RISE AND GREAT
SADNESS TO A TORRENT AND THE
MEMORY OF ANTONIO TONY DAMIAN.
ON SATURDAY JULY TWENTY FOURTH
AND TONIO A LOVING SON BROTHER
UNCLE FRIEND HUSBAND AND FATHER
TO THREE CHILDREN. PASSED AWAY
AT THE AGE OF FORTY TELL.
ANTONIO WAS BORN ON AUGUST
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. THE LOS ANGELES TO
DANIEL AND CONSUELO DAMIEN HE
GRADUATED FROM BALDWIN PARK
HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX WHERE HE PLAYED BOTH
VARSITY BASEBALL AND FOOTBALL.
SHORTLY AFTER GRADUATING FROM
HIGH SCHOOL HE'S OPEN TO
WIRELESS BUSINESS WITH HIS
BROTHER DANNY DAMIEN. THAT LED
HIM INTO A WIRELESS INDUSTRY
WHERE HE HAD A CAREER AS A
MANAGER FOR AT&T. ON JULY
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWELVE HE
MARRIED GLORIA HERNANDEZ THE
RACE THREE CHILDREN MANUAL
ASHLEY AND ALEXIS TONY HAD A
PASSION FOR BARBECUING HE ALSO
LOVE SPORTS AND ENJOYED GOING
TO TRIP WITH HIS FAMILY. HE
ALWAYS MADE TIME TO VISIT HIS
MOTHER AND SPOILED HER BY
TAKING HER SHOPPING AND OUT TO
EAT. ON WEEKENDS HE WAS KNOWN
FOR HIS SKIN CONTAGIOUS LAUGH
IS INFECTIOUS LOVE AND IS KIND
AND COMPASSIONATE SPIRIT. I HAD
THE HONOR OF SPENDING TIME WITH
HIM AND HIS FAMILY. AND I WILL
TRULY MISS HIM HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS MOM CONSUELO WIFE GLORIA
ASKING ALEXIS HIS BROTHER
CARDINALS AND DANNY WHO'S A
DEAR FRIEND. SISTER CARMEN AND
SEVERAL NIECES AND NEPHEWS.
ONCE AGAIN WE WILL MISS YOU
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE AND
SADNESS TO A TURN IN THE MEMORY
OF CAPTAIN JOSEPH. DEXTER
BORTOLOTTI FROM BALDWIN PARK
CAPTAIN BARRED A LOT HE WAS A
BELOVED HUSBAND OF HELEN FATHER
IF MIA DOMINIQUE AND VICTORIA
AND WAS CHERISHED CHERISHED
FRIEND TO ALL THOSE WHO KNEW
HIM INCLUDING MYSELF. WORKING
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AROUND IN
HIS FAMILY CAPTAIN PART A LOT
HE FOLLOW THE FOOTSTEPS OF HIS
FATHER JAMES BARTOLOTTA E. WHO
SERVED AS AN INVESTIGATOR WITH
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HE SERVED
MULTIPLE ROLES THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER HE SERVED AS A PATROL
OFFICER FIELD TRAINING OFFICER
DETECTIVE. AND ARE CAUGHT IN
TASK FORCE MEMBER HE WAS
PROMOTED TO SERGEANT IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE AND SUPERVISED THE
PATROL AND DETECTIVE URALS. HE
WAS LATER PROMOTED TO
LIEUTENANT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. COMMANDING THE SAME
GIRLS RESPECT. HE WAS ALSO. A
CLEAR DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT
AND HE WORKED TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THE UTMOST
RESPECT AND GAVE IT ALL THE
IMPORTANCE THAT IT REQUIRED. IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN HE WAS PROMOTED
TO CAPTAIN AND OVERSAW BOTH
DIVISIONS OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT CAPTAIN BARRED A LOT
HE WAS APPOINTED TO ACTING
POLICE CHIEF IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
ENTER A POLICE CHIEF IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AFTER SERVING MY
COMMUNITY THE CITY OF BALDWIN
PARK FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS PART
A LOT HE RECENTLY RETIRED. HE
ENJOYED HIS RETIRED LIFE OF
BEING A FULL TIME DAD AND WAS
AN AVID DIRT BIKE RIDER HIS
UNTIMELY PASSING HOWEVER WAS
LEFT A VOID AND SO MANY HEARTS
INCLUDING MINE. WE THANK
CAPTAIN BARTOLOTTA E. FOR
KEEPING OUR FRIENDS AND FAMILY
SAFE IN THE CITY OF BALDWIN
PARK. AND MY PRAYERS AND
CONDOLENCES GO OUT TO HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE FOR
USERNAME FOR THREE MAYBE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I AM SURE
IN IN MEMORY OF FRANCESCA OCHO
A TEACHER AND ACTIVIST FROM UP
WITH THEM. MRS CHILL PASSED
AWAY EARLIER THIS YEAR FROM
COVENT NINETEEN A VIRUS WHICH
HASTAKEN THE LIVES OF SO MANY
OF OUR LOVED ONES. MRS CHOICE
SURVIVED BY HER TWO CHILDREN
AND G. K. AND GILDA WHO BOTH
REMEMBER HER AS A STRONG
ADVOCATE WHO BELIEVED IN EQUAL
RIGHTS AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THIS WAS REFLECTED IN HER
EVERYDAY ACTIONS AT HOME AT
WORK AND ON THE STREETS WHERE
SHE OFTEN ATTEND A PROTEST IN
SUPPORT OF WORKERS. IMMIGRANTS
TEACHERS MEDICARE FRAUD AND
MUCH MORE. TEACHING WITH HER
PASSION DESPITE BEING TEASED AT
A YOUNG AGE BY OTHER STUDENTS
BECAUSE SHE WAS. SELLING IN A
TRUCK GREW TO LOVE SCHOOL WHICH
LED HER TO BECOME AN EDUCATOR.
SHE RECEIVED HER BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN SPANISH LANGUAGE AND
LITERATURE AND HER TEACHING
CREDENTIALS FROM CAL STATE LOS
ANGELES. SHE ALSO MET HER
FUTURE HUSBAND HENRY WHOLESALE.
AT CAL STATE THEY ENDED UP
TEACHING A LOT ASANDA HEIGHTS
AND LOCK WITH THEM. UNTIL I
STARTED SUBSTITUTE TEACHING AND
BE A SEND UP WHEN THE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. AND NINETEEN
SEVENTY SHE WAS OFFERED A JOB
AT SPARK JUNIOR. HIGH SHE OFTEN
SAYS SHE COULD SEE HERSELF
TEACHING NOWHERE ELSE. BUT
THERE SHE TRULY LOVED HER
STUDENTS AND HER COMMUNITY. BUT
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS- TRUST
BENNETT'S PARKS IS MARKED WITH
HER LEGACY BRINGING JOY INTO
LITERATURE AND ADVOCATING FOR
WORKING CLASS IN SPANISH
SPEAKING STUDENTS SHE WAS NAMED
TEACHER OF THE YEAR FOR THE
DISTRICT IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE ADMIRED FOR HER
OUTSPOKENNESS AND THE EASE WITH
WHICH SHE INTERACTED WITH
PEOPLE. AFTER RETURNING AND TWO
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT OR CHAR
REMAINED COMMITTED TO THE
COMMUNITY WORKING FOR
EDUCATIONAL TRANSFORMATION AND
EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION ON THE
ASEAN DOLLOP WENT THEY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD.
TO RECOGNIZE THEIR MOTHER'S
HARD WORK AND LEGACY THE-
TAUGHT CHILDREN AND HE CAN KILL
THAT DECIDED TO GIVE AWARDS IN
THEIR MOTHER'S HONOR TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE COMMITTED TO
THE SOCIAL GOOD. AND ARE
ENGAGED AND BETTER AND BETTER
IN SOCIETY THROUGH SOCIAL
ACTIVISM FOR COMMUNITY WORK
HOTEL I LOVING MOTHER TEACHER
AND MENTOR WILL BE SURELY
MISSED BY MANY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY I TURN IN THE
MEMORY OF HARRY ANDERSON FROM
WEST COVINA MR ANDERSON A
NATIVE OF NEW BRUNSWICK CANADA
CREW UP IN NORTH DAKOTA HE CAME
TO CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FOLLOWING HIS GRADUATION FROM
NORTH DAKOTA STATE UNIVERSITY
WHERE HE WORKED AS A CIVIL
ENGINEER FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HE FIRST BEGAN VOLUNTEERING
WITH YOUTH PROGRAMS BUT HE
BECAME A COACH FOR HIS SON
BREAKS LITTLE LEAGUE TEAMS.
HELP WITH HIS DAUGHTER JULIE
SOFTBALL TEAM AND BECAME A
LEADER IN WOODCRAFT RANGERS
UPON HIS RETIREMENT IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR HE JOINED THAT
COULD BE IN A SOUTH HILLS CO
ONENESS AN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO CHANGING THE WORLD
ONE COMMUNITY AND ONE CHILD AT
A TIME SOME OF THEIR EFFORTS
INCLUDE MEALS ON WHEELS HOLDING
BASKETBALL CLINICS FOR LOCAL
BOYS AND GIRLS FUNDRAISING FOR
SCHOLARSHIPS AND SPONSORING KEY
CLUBS. TO NAME A FEW. HE FOUND
HIS NICHE WHEN HE TOOK OVER THE
HELM OF THE EXISTING KEEP CLUB.
WAS ABLE TO CHARTER NEW ONES
AND EVEN FORMED A SUCCESSFUL
BUILDERS CLUB AT SIERRA VISTA
MIDDLE SCHOOL. MR ANDERSON
EARNED THE RESPECT AND
FRIENDSHIP OF SO MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THE CASINO AND WEST
COVINA AREA. WE THANK HIM FOR
HIS LONG TIME COMMITMENT TO
UPLIFT IN ARE YOU. AND HE WILL
SURELY BE MISSED BY HIS FRIENDS
AND FAMILY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MORE LIES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY ARE RICE AND
SADNESS TO TURN IN THE MEMORY
OF HER MEN ARE. FAST ALSO KNOWN
AS BOB. MR FAST DIED
UNEXPECTEDLY IN MINNESOTA ON
JUNE FIFTH AT THE AGE OF NINETY
THREE. HE'S REMEMBERED MOST
NOTABLY FOR SERVING THE
COMMUNITY OF WEST COVINA ASKED
CITY MANAGER FROM NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. TO NINETEEN NINETY
HE BEGAN HIS CAREER AT WEST
COVINA CITY HALL AS A PUBLIC
SERVICE DIRECTOR. AND WAS
PROMOTED TO ASSISTANT CITY
MANAGER BEFORE MOVING INTO THE
ROLE AS CITY MANAGER FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS. HERMAN IS
REMEMBERED BY COLLEAGUES AS A
LEADER. IN MANAGING THE CITY
COUNCIL IN FORMULATING A GREAT
EXECUTIVE TEAM. HE WAS
PASSIONATE ABOUT INVESTING IN
EMPLOYEE DEVELOPMENT. AND THEIR
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS HE HAS MARK
IN LEGACY IN THE COMMUNITY WILL
HERMAN SASSA SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF TWENTY SIX YEARS.
JENSEN HAS THREE CHILDREN MARY
KAY BOB AND PATTY. AND HIS
STEPSONS BRADLEY MARK AND JOHN.
TEN GRAND CHILDREN SIX GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. AND TWO. LITTLE
DOGGIES. STIR FAST LEFT LONG
LASTING IMPACT ON THE LVES OF
SO MANY AND WILL BE MISSED BY
MANY. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE
BRING USING FORWARD SO HE MAY
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON TO
SENATOR SKINNER SENATOR SKINNER.
THERE IS NOT C. SENATOR SKINNER
PRESENT SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
SENATOR UMBERG SENT OVER PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES. IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE TO. HONOR
THE LIFE IN PUBLIC SERVICE OF
JUDGE GREG MILLENNIALS- JUDGE
WILLIAMS WAS A DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANT ORANGE COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGE LOVING FATHER
HUSBAND AND I'VE BEEN A FRIEND
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS HE WAS
BORN IN BRITAIN COLORADO GROUP
WITH TEN SIBLINGS IN CORONA
CALIFORNIA. HE CHANGED HIS-
BLOOD AGREE FROM USC AN
UNDERGRADUATE UCLA AFTER
GRADUATING BEGAN HIS CAREER
WORKING AS A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR LOSANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
SERVED IN THAT ROLE FOR A FEW
YEARS AND THEN TURN TO PRIVATE
PRACTICE WE SPECIALIZE IN
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE PRODUCTS
LIABILITY INSURANCE BAD FAITH.
AND PERSONAL INJURY LITIGATION
DURING THIS TIME HE SERVED AS A
MENTOR TO MANY MANY MANY IN THE
LEGAL COMMUNITY- AFTER SERVING
THIRTY SEVEN YEARS IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE HE WAS APPOINTED TO
THE BENCH IN ORANGE COUNTY HE
SPENT FOURTEEN YEARS IN THIS
POSITION SERVING ORANGE COUNTY-
AND DURING THIS TIME AGAIN HE
WAS A MENTOR TO TOO MANY-
INCLUDING ME. HE WAS A FRIEND
OF THOUGHTFUL KIND. HE ALSO.
WAS A CO FOUNDER OF THE SPANISH
BAR ASSOCIATION AND PAST
PRESIDENT AMERICAN BOARD OF
TRIAL ADVOCATES THE ORANGE
COUNTY CHAPTER. OF HE- WAS NOT
A PROUD MAN BUT HE WAS VERY
PROUD OF HIS FAMILY- AS WIFE
DIANE HIS CHILDREN MATTHEW
LAURA PATRICK MOLLY. CEDED HIS
STEP DAUGHTER JENNIFER AND
SIXTEEN GRANDCHILDREN ON HIS
SISTER AS YOU KNOW WAS ALSO
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE VERY PROUD
OF HER SERVICE. AS WELL AS
OTHER SIBLINGS VERA ROSIE
MARGIE AND ANGIE- I ASKED TODAY
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG PLEASE BRING HIS
SAME FORWARDS WE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR UMBERG. MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES- IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE TO HONOR
THE LIFE OF MARY KATE KANE OF
FORMER DEAN OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF LAW I'M A GRADUATE OF
HASTINGS AND AS SUCH IT'S EVEN
GREATER HONOR TO RECOGNIZE HER.
YOUR IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. THEN CAME WAS BORN
RAISED IN DETROIT SHE WAS A
GRADUATE UNIVERSITY MISSION
WOULD BOTH BE IN ENGLISH AND A
JD IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
AFTER GRADUATING SHE BECAME CO
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
SCIENCE FOUNDATION PROJECT ON
PRIVACY IN SOCIAL SCIENCE
RESEARCH DATA. THAT SHOULD BE A
TEACHING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR THE STATE UNIVERSITY OF
NEW YORK AND THREE YEARS LATER
SHE CAME TO HASTINGS- SO
PROCEDURE WAS MARY KAY KEYNES
AREA OF INTEREST AND EXPERTISE-
AND SHE HAS A NUMBER OF
STUDENTS TODAY WHO ARE
LITIGATORS WHO. STILL RECALL
THE LESSONS THAT WERE TAUGHT BY
DEAN CAIN THAT SHE CO AUTHORED
THE HORN BOOK ON CIVIL
PROCEDURE AND HEARTBROKEN LAW
FEDERAL COURTS AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF. OTHER TREATISES.
SUCH SERVICE CALL REPORT
AMERICAN LAWS INSTITUTE COMPLEX
LITIGATION PROJECT DEVELOP.
PROPOSALS FOR HANDING
MULTIPARTY MULTI FORM DISPUTES
IN FEDERAL AND STATE COURTS.
AFTER MORE THAN A DECADE ON THE
FACULTY OF HASTINGS BECAME THE
ACADEMIC DEAN IN NINETEEN
NINETY IN THE DEAN OVERALL DEAN
OF UC HASTINGS AND WAS THE
FIRST FEMALE DEAN IN OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN YEARS WERE
PREVIOUSLY MEN AT ALL FILLED
POSITION. SHE WAS. THE PERSON
WHO MADE A DIFFERENCE MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN SAN FRANCISCO
MADE  DIFFERENCE IN THE LAW
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY MADE A
DIFFERENCE. IN COUNTLESS
STUDENTS LIVES AND THEIR
DEDICATION TO THE PROFESSION.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR GIVING%
ME A MOMENT TO. RECOGNIZE DEAN
CAIN N. TO ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU SENATOR
AMBERG PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FOR IT SO SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES IT'S MY SAD
PRIVILEGE TO REMEMBER THE LIFE
OF SERRA MARIA ADLER- SIR MARIA
ADLER WAS BORN ON SEPTEMBER
FOURTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY SIX
SHE GREW UP IN MALLS IN
CAMBRIDGE MASSACHUSETTS AND
GRADUATED SMITH COLLEGE AND WAS
AWARDED A PHD FROM HARVARD
UNIVERSITY IN NINETEEN. SEVENTY
FIVE- HER ACADEMIC CREDENTIALS
COURSE ROOM PACKABLE SHE BECAME
A PROFESSOR AT SCRIPPS COLLEGE
IN CLAREMONT WHERE SHE LED
TEACHING OF ITALIAN STUDIES FOR
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS BEFORE
RETIRING IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND SUBSEQUENTLY
UNVEILED PROFESSORSHIP OF AND
OUT OF ITALIAN WAS CREATED IN
HER NAME. PRIOR TO TEACHING AT
SCRIPT SHE TAUGHT AT SIGN A
GEORGETOWN WELLESLEY HARVARD
WITH A CONCENTRATION IN SCIENCE
FICTION THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND WOMEN POINTS OF THE
ITALIAN RENAISSANCE. FOUR YEARS
AGO SERVER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
ALS. A DISEASE THAT- CAUSE
GREAT SUFFERING DESPITE THIS
SHE CONTINUED LIVING A LIFE
WITH DIGNITY AND GRACE
CHERISHING HER BLESSINGS AND
SPREADING JOY TO PEOPLE AROUND
HER- I WAS PRIVILEGED TO KNOW
SIR WE ONLY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
RECOGNIZE A- HANDFUL OF
CALIFORNIANS AND SHE IS.
DEFINITELY DESERVING OF
RECOGNITION GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
LIVES THAT SHE ENRICHED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BOTH ACADEMICALLY AS
WELL AS IN THE COMMUNITY- WE
RECOGNIZE ALSO HER CONTRIBUTION
TO HER FAMILY HER HUSBAND. BOB-
VERY VERY ACCOMPLISHED PERSON
IN HIS OWN RIGHT- IT YOU
WOULDN'T KNOW IT BECAUSE HE
WASN'T BOASTFUL BUT HE WAS
EXTREMELY PROUD HE WAS
EXTREMELY PROUD OF SERRA AND
EXTREMELY PROUD OF HER
CHILDREN. AND HER CHILDREN
CORRESPONDENT AND ALL THOSE WHO
KNEW HER MR- IN PARTICULAR- SON
JONES WIFE KERRY DAUGHTER
CAROLINE HUSBAND- TRISTEN AND
THE FOUR GRANDCHILDREN BEN.
PENNY LIANA. HALEY SERIES
BROTHER HIS WIFE MAD MAX PEYSER
AND CLAUDIA BOND OF NEW YORK-
SIR YOU'LL BE MISSED AT TRINITY
ARMEL. THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FOR SO
SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR UMBERG.
MAN PRESENT CALLINGS IT'S MY
PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO RISE TO
HONOR THE LIFE OF JUSTICE. SAID
WALLIN- JUST AS LONG WAS A
RETIRED CALIFORNIA FOURTH
DISTRICT APPELLATE COURT
JUSTICE HE WAS BORN RAISED IN
MINNEAPOLIS TO PARENTS WHO WERE
BOTH LABOR ORGANIZERS VERY VERY
PROUD OF HIS PARENTS VERY VERY
PROUD OF HIS FAMILY- E
GRADUATED FROM WASHBURN SENIOR
HIGH SCHOOL THE FIRST MEMBERS
EXTENDED FAMILY TO GO TO
COLLEGE. HE ALSO GRADUATED
UNIVERSITY MINNESOTA WITH A
POLITICAL SCIENCE DEGREE AND
LATER FROM UNIVERSITY OF
MINNESOTA. LAW SCHOOL ****
LAUDE IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
AND WAS A RABID GOAL FOR FAN.
AS A LAWYER- JUST AS WELL JOIN
THE LAW FIRM KINDLE INDIANS IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND SPENT THE
REST OF HIS LIFE AS A
CALIFORNIAN. DURING HIS CAREER
HE SERVED AS A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR. ANY RETURN THE
CANDLE IN ANDERSON AFTER HE-
SERVED AS A PROSECUTOR UNTIL HE
WAS APPOINTED SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. THAT TIME HE WAS ONLY
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND WAS
THE YOUNGEST SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE IN CALIFORNIA. NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO HE WAS ELEVATED THE
NEWLY CREATED CALIFORNIA COURT
OF APPEAL FOURTH DISTRICT. WAS
REELECTED TWICE TO THE OFFICE.
HE HANDLED A NUMBER OF NOTABLE
CASES INCLUDING A GOLDEN WEST
BASEBALL VERSUS CITY OF
ANAHEIM. CONCERNING THE
OWNERSHIP OF THE PARKING LOT
SURROUNDING ANAHEIM STADIUM. HE
WAS RECOGNIZED AND RECEIVE THE
FRANKLIN G. WEST AWARD FROM THE
ORANGE COUNTY BAR ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS THE- MOST PRESTIGIOUS
AWARD. BESTOWED UPON A MEMBER
OF THE BAR IN ORANGE COUNTY. HE
WAS A LIFELONG FAN OF ALL OTHER
MINNESOTA SPORTS TEAMS AND IF
YOU EVER HAD A COUPLE HOURS TO
SPARE YOU COULD CALL JUSTICE
WON'T ASK YOU ABOUT ANYTHING
CONCERNING POLITICS OR
POLITICAL MEMORABILIA AND HE
COULD CERTAINLY FILL WHATEVER
TIME YOU MIGHT HAVE. AN
EXTRAORDINARY LIFE- HE WAS
EXTREMELY PROUD OF HIS FAMILY-
AND HE WOULD SAY HIS GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT IS. HIS FOUR
CHILDREN. AMY MATT INDIAN ALEX-
HE PASSED AWAY SADLY MAY TWENTY
EIGHTH SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY.
CALLING SIDE FACET WE ADJOURNED
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. BETTER
PRESENT COLLEAGUES- I RISE TO
REMEMBER MARGIE RICE A LOCAL
LEADER A LIFELONG ADVOCATE IN
THE COMMUNITY WESTMINSTER- SHE
WAS BORN IN NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE IN ALABAMA. AND AS SHE
CONTINUED TO HAVE THAT SORT OF
STRENGTH THE BACKBONE FROM
BEING BORN POOR HER MOTHER DIED
JUST ONE DAY AFTER BIRTH AND
STEP MOTHER WOULD PASS AWAY
JUST TWELVE YEARS LATER. SHE
WAS MARRIED AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTEEN HAD HER FIRST CHILD
HE SEES ME SHE WAS MARRIED AT
THE AGE OF SIXTEEN HAD HER
FIRST CHILD THE AGE OF
SEVENTEEN. AND SHE STRUGGLED TO
SECURE A BETTER LIFE AND MOVED
WITH HER FAMILY TO SANTA
BARBARA WHERE SHE WORKED
PICKING GRAPES. LATER SHE
MOVED- TO THE CITY OF
WESTMINSTER WERE HUSBAND
SECURED A- JOB WORKING IN A
FIBRE GLASS MANUFACTURING
FACILITY- HER NEWFOUND ECONOMIC
SECURITY AS IT WERE ALLOWED HER
TO FOCUS ON HER FAMILY IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND SHE DID. AND SHE
WAS A DEDICATED MEMBER THE
COMMUNITY WHETHER WAS THE PTA
OR LEGAL LITTLE LEAGUE. AND
THEN SHE BEGAN A POLITICAL
CAREER AT THE WESTMINSTER
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE SHE SPENT
SEVENTEEN YEARS. AS THE VOICE
OF PARENTS AND CHILDREN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR SHE WAS
ELECTED TO WESTMINSTER CITY
COUNCIL. IN THAT VICTORY BEGAN
A TWENTY TWO YEAR JOURNEY IN
CITY GOVERNMENT COULDN'T
TWELVE. WHEN SHE SERVED AS
MAYOR OF WESTMINSTER- MARGIE
WAS KNOWN AS BEING OUTSPOKEN
AND TOUGH AND INDEED SHE WAS.
HER TOUGHNESS HOWEVER WAS ONLY
A THIN VENEER OVER HER HEART OF
GOLD HAVING WORKED WITH MARGIE
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS. I'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WIN A
CERTAIN VISION DEDICATION
LEADERSHIP THAT LED THE CITY OF
WESTMINSTER TO EXPERIENCE MORE
CHANGE THAN ANYONE. EVER BEFORE
HER. AFTER TENURE ON THE CITY
COUNCI SHE CONTINUED SERVICE
ON THE WESTMINSTER SANITATION
DISTRICT UNTIL HER PASSING SHE
IS DEARLY MISSED. BY THE
COMMUNITY WESTMINSTER IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND- FAMILY WHICH
INCLUDES FOUR CHILDREN NINETEEN
GRANDCHILDREN THIRTY TWO. GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND ELEVEN GREAT
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN MARGIE
WE'LL MISS YOU. THANK YOU
NUMBER WITH THAT WE TURN HER
MEMORY THANK YOU SENATOR AMBER
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FORWARD
SO SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE SENATOR UMBERG
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES- I.
S. C. JOIN ME IN AND
RECOGNIZING AND HONORING THE
LIFE OF JOHN CEDARBURG JOHN AND
I WERE BOTH IN THE US
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE- ONE POINT
OUR LIVES AND I HAD THE HONOR
TO KNOW JOHN IS A HUMBLE MAN
WHO DEVOTED THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
OF HIS LIFE TO THE PROFESSION
AND TRIAL ADVOCACY. HE SPENT A
LIFETIME WORKING TO MASTER THE
ART OF TRYING CASES AND INDEED
WAS A MASTER OF THE ART. HE
SHARED HIS WISDOM IN MENTORING.
TO MANY MANY MANY ATTORNEYS
INCLUDING ME- JOHN RECEIVED HIS
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND HIS JURIS
DOCTORATE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN. WHERE HE PLAYED FOR
THE UNIVERSITY'S FOOTBALL TEAM
AS A RUNNING BACK. THAT WAS A
PART OF THE TEAM THAT WON THE
CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE SEASON NOW ONE OF
MY FOND MEMORIES OF JOHN IS
ATTENDING A UCLA MICHIGAN GAME
WHEN MICHIGAN RECOVERED AN
ONSIDE. KICK IN THE VERY LAST
SECONDS OF THE GAME AND WENT ON
TO SCORE AND BEAT UCLA I THINK
BY ONE OR TWO POINTS. JOHN WAS
A NOT A BOASTFUL PERSON BUT WAS
INSUFFERABLE WHEN IT CAME TO
MICHIGAN. FOOTBALL HE IN
NINETEEN NINETY. HE BECAME AN
INSTRUCTOR AT THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF TRIAL ADVOCACY AND
US ATTORNEY GENERAL'S TRIAL
INSTITUTE. HE JOINED QUINN
EMANUEL URQUHART AND SULLIVAN
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE WHERE YOU
CONTINUE TO TRY COMPLEX CASES
AND CONTINUED TO MENTOR. YOUNG
LAWYERS ENTERING THE PROFESSION.
HE WAS KIND KEINE GENEROUS AND
DEPENDABLE WE ALL OWE A DEBT OF
GRATITUDE TO JOHN FOR HIS
UNSELFISH UNSELFISHNESS IS
WISDOM IN THE THINGS HE DID
LIFT OTHERS. WITHOUT DRAWING
ATTENTION TO HIMSELF HE'S
DEARLY MISSED BY HIS WIFE PAULA
HE AND HIS FAMILY AND ALL HIS
COLLEAGUES AT QUINN EMANUEL.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG PLEASE
FOR USING FORWARD SO HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES- I RISE
THE DATA S. THAT WE ADJOURN. IN
COMMEMORATION LIFE OF ARCHIE
GOOSE MON THE DISPATCH OF THE
GARDEN GROVE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
ARCHIE GOES MOM WAS BORN
SEPTEMBER FIVE NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO WAS RAISED IN LOS ANGELES
HE GRADUATED IN GARFIELD HIGH
SCHOOL. HE WAS HUMBLE AND A
VERY HOSPITABLE PERSON- AND
MAYBE THAT'S WHY HE FOUND A
CALLING IN PUBLIC SERVICE
DISPATCHER GOODMAN FIRST SERVED
AS RESERVE FIREFIGHTER IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. AND ON APRIL
SIXTH TWO THOUSAND SIX HE
JOINED. THAT SUPERVISOR IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN ARCHIE'S WORK
ETHIC PERSONALITY AND DEMEANOR
WERE. WE'RE JUST A CHARISMATIC
FOR ALL WHO KNEW HIM DURING HIS
CAREER HE TRAINED COUNTLESS NEW
DISPATCHERS AND SERVES THE
TACTICAL SWAT DISPATCHER
VOLUNTEERED FOR NUMEROUS
COMMITTEES. INCLUDING B. WELL
ORANGE COUNTY HE WAS A FAMIL
MAN ALWAYS MADE SURE HIS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS WERE HIS PRIORITIES
A MUSIC LOVER AND A NOVICE
MUSICIAN PLAY THE CONGA DRUMS
AND- WAS TAKING UP- A BASELESS
LESSONS HE PASSED AWAY WAY TOO
EARLY ON JULY TWENTY SEVENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS SURVIVED
AND MISSED BY HIS WIFE ROSE A-
DOG DAUGHTER ASHLEY AND SON
ETHAN. COLLEAGUES I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY THANK YOU SENATOR AMBERG
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BUT CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE THANK YOU. SANDERS
CAN- DID YOU WANT TO PRESENT
YOUR ADJOURN IN MEMORY. YOU MAY
GO TO THE- CENTER THERE THAT
WOULD BE PERFECT. SANDERS CAN-
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS HI
TODAY I ASK THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY FOR ANTONIO
BERRY FLORIO. ANTONIO GRADUATED
FROM UC SANTA CRUZ WITH DEAN'S
HONORS IN POLITICAL SCIENCE AND
GOVERNMENT AFTER HIS GRADUATION
ANTONIOSERVED AS AN INTERN AT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FOR OAKLAND
YOUTH A NONPROFIT IN OAKLAND
WHOSE MISSION IS TO FIND TO
FUNDAMENTALLY SHIFT THE WAY WE
RESPOND TO YOUTHFUL RON DOING.
FROM PUNITIVE APPROACHES THAT
INFLICT HARM TO RESTORATIVE
APPROACHES THAT REPAIR HARM.
ANTONIO HAD JUST BEGUN WHAT WAS
SURE TO BE A LONG AND FRUITFUL
CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE
WORKING FOR A LOCAL LOBBYING
FIRM WHEN HE TRAGICALLY PASSED
ON APRIL TWENTY NINTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ANTONIO AS AN
INTERN IN MY CAPITOL OFFICE IN
THE SUMMER OF TWENTY NINETEEN
HE WAS INCREDILY SMART
TALENTED INQUISITIVE HARD
WORKING WITH A HEART OF GOLD.
HE WAS A JOY IN THE OFFICE YET
A SUNNY SMILE ATTITUDE GO
ALWAYS WILLING TO DO WHATEVER
WE ASK HIM TO DO. HE ASKED US
LOTS OF QUESTIONS IN THE OFFICE
WHY WERE CERTAIN POLICIES IN
PLACE HE WANTED TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT ENERGY POLICY. AN AREA
THAT HIS FATHER FORMER CPUC
COMMISSIONER AND SENIOR
ATTORNEY FOR TURN MIKE FLORIO.
ENJOYED OVER FORTY YEAR CAREER.
AND TONIO ALSO HAD MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR OFFICES
WORK ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
AN ISSUE THAT HIS MOTHER ELLEN
BERRY IS NATIONALLY RENOWNED
FOR. ANTONIO'S LAST POST ON
FACEBOOK IS A TESTAMENT TO HIS
ASTUTE MIND AND HIS DEEP DESIRE
TO RIGHT THE INJUSTICES. THAT
WE FACE. IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL
TREATISE ON HOW TO BEGIN
SOLVING THE DEEP DIVISIONS IN
OUR SOCIETY AROUND THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT. AND ON
THE UNFORTUNATE RISING DISTRUST
IN OUR POLICE. THIS IS WHAT
ANTONIO BROUGHT. SOLVING THIS
ISSUE SHOULDN'T INVOLVE SOLELY
PROSECUTING THE COP WE HAVE TO
SHIFT OUR ENTIRE CULTURE
TOWARDS ONE OF INTEGRATING
COMMUNITIES HEALING UNDERLYING
TRAUMAS OF ALL PEOPLE AND
REINSTALLING YOUR CONSCIOUS
ATTITUDE OF LIVING WITH
CHARACTER AND PURPOSE. I
BELIEVE THAT ONE SHOULD LISTEN
BEFORE ONE SPEAKS AND I BELIEVE
THERE IS NEVER A JUSTIFICATION
FOR HATRED. BUT IN FACT
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE THAT
TREATING OTHERS WITH
UNCONDITIONAL LOVE IS BOTH
HEALING AND RESTORATIVE. AND
TONY WERE SURVIVED BY HIS
MOTHER ELLEN BERRY FATHER MIKE
FLORIO HIS SISTER. AND HIS
FRIENDS AND MANY OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO WILL BE DEARLY
MISSED AND THE WORLD WAS ROBBED
OF A TRUE. PUBLIC SERVANT LET
US ENSURE THAT ANTONIO'S CALL
TO ACTION WILL NOT BE IN VAIN
AND MAY WE TREAT EACH OTHER
WITH UNCONDITIONAL LOVE IN
ANTONIO'S NAME. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO MAYBE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAN LOEB WHO
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY ONE ON JULY TWENTY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DAN
EFFORTS AND COMMITMENT TO HIS
CONSTITUENTS SHOULD BE AN
INSPIRATION TO ALL OF US WHO
SERVE TODAY. THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER HE WORKED TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT. TO
MAKE IT MORE RESPONSIVE AND
BUSINESS FRIENDLY. AFTER
SERVING IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY DAN SERVED ON THE YUBA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. WHILE
SERVING AS A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. HE WE HE
WORKED TO BRING NEW BUSINESSES
AND MANUFACTURING TO THE NORTH
ST GROWING THE ECONOMY AND
CREATING JOBS. IN THE ASSEMBLY
DAN LET REPUBLICAN EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS
CLIMATE. BY FIGHTING AGAINST
OVER REGULATION PROTECTING THE
STATE'S JOBS AND WORKING
TOWARDS TRUE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
FOR THE GOLDEN STATE AFTER THE
RECESSION. DAN WAS A NORMAL
FAMILY MAN AND A PATRIOT
HONORING HIS FATHER SERVICE AND
MORE WORK TO HE WAS ABLE TO
ORGANIZE A LOCAL. VETERANS
MEMORIAL COMMITTEE TO RAISE
OVER THREE INTERN FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN PRIVATE
FUNDS TO CONSTRUCT TWO WORLD
CLASS. VETERANS MEMORIALS. IN
YOU BUT IN THE US CENTER AREA
HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE PEGGY
AND DAUGHTER CHENEY. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF THE
HONORABLE SENTIMENT DOWN LOW.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALI PLEASE
BRING THE SAME FORWARD SO HE
MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS I AM LOOKING FOR I WILL
GO WITH SENATOR PAM PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS TODAY HI RISE TO JOIN
A MEMORY THE MEMBER OF OUR
SENATE FAMILY TYLER JONATHAN
WILCOX. TYLER WAS A BELOVED SON
BROTHER NEPHEW COUSIN UNCLE AND
FRIEND. WHO LEFT THIS WORLD FAR
TOO SOON ON FRIDAY AUGUST
TWENTIETH TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AT THE AGE
OF ONLY THIRTY SIX. THE CARD
WAS CLEARED LAST SUMMER. CARLOS
BORN ON SEPTEMBER SEVENTEENTH
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
PLACERVILLE CALIFORNIA HE GREW
UP IN THE SECOND- NEIGHBORHOOD
OF FLAME PARK GRADUATE FROM C.
K. MCCLATCHY HIGH SCHOOL IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. HE ATTENDED
ORANGE COAST COLLEGE WHO IS A
MEMBER OF THE CREW TEAM. THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN HE HAS WORKED IN
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE
REPROGRAPHICS DEPARTMENT. TYLER
WAS A BIG HEARTED GENEROUS
GOOFY AND FUN LOVING THERE'S A
NATURALIS AN ANIMAL LOVER FROM
A YOUNG AGE AND REMEMBERED
ALMOST EVERYTHING HE HAD EVER
LEARNED THOSE YET ALMOST IN
PHOTOGRAPHIC MEMORY. HE LOVED
THE OUTDOORS TAKING EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO- CAMPING HIKING
CYCLING. WE WALK AROUND THE
BLOCK WITH THE LOVE THE DOG
KODA. TYLER ALSO LOVE VIDEO
GAMES SPECIALLY BORDERLANDS
THREE WHERE HE AND HIS BROTHER
JORDAN OFTEN EMPLOYED OFTEN
ENJOYED PLAYING COOPERATIVE THE
SIDE BY SIDE. THE OUTRAGEOUS
ARRANGEMENT TECHNOLOGY. IN
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY TYLER
DIAGNOSED WITH GLIOBLASTOMA A
VERY AGGRESSIVE FORM OF BRAIN
CANCER. TYLER FACED A SITUATION
WITH. MORE BRACE HE MET
HUMILITY AND COURAGE THAN
ANYONE IMAGINED POSSIBLE. HE
WAS LOVING AFFECTIONATE AND
APPRECIATIVE TO THE VERY END A
TRAIT OFTEN REMARKED UPON BY
NURSES AND CAREGIVERS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY TODAY
SECTION IN HONOR OF TYLER A
MEMBER OF OUR SENATE FAMILY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN PLEASE BRING HIS SAME
FORWARD SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BUT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. MEMBERS I AM
LOOKING FOR SENATOR BATES OR
SENATOR ROTH TO PRESENT THEIR
ADJOURN IN MEMORIES.
THE SENATE
IS STILL IN RECESS UNTIL FIVE
PM.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SADDAM HI RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF A DEAR FRIEND AND
CERTAINLY A BELOVED MEMBER OF
THE COMMUNITY OF LAGOON IN A
GAL JANICE MOVING ANY WHO
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY AT HIS
HOME IN LAGUNA GAL ON MARCH
FOURTEENTH. DENNIS GREW UP IN A
TIME WHEN EVERYONE KNEW THEIR
NEIGHBORS NAMES AND COLLECTED
BOTTLES FOR SPENDING MONEY HE
GRADUATED FROM MONTEBELLO HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE HE MET HIS WIFE
DONNA. DENNIS A LISTED IN IN
LISTED IN THE AIR FORCE IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE WHERE HE
WAS TRAINED AS AN ELECTRONIC
ENGINEER WORKING ON THE EARLY
MODEL AIRBORNE WARNING AND
CONTROL SYSTEM. BEFORE GOING
OFF TO SERVE IN THE KOREAN WAR
HE AND DONNA GOT MARRIED
HONEYMOONING AT THE NEWLY
OPENED DISNEYLAND IN ANAHEIM
AFTER HIS MILITARY SERVICE
DENNIS HAD A SUCCESSFUL CAREER
IN THE ELEVEN ELECTRONICS AND
LASER INDUSTRY SPANNING FROM
NINETEEN SIXTY. TO HIS
RETIREMENT FROM TEST SYSTEMS
INTERNATIONAL AS PRESIDENT AND
OWNER IN TWENTY THIRTEEN. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO DENNIS
MOVED HIS FAMILY TO LOOK GOOD
IN A GAL TO OPEN A RADIO SHACK
STORE WHILE HE WAS STILL
INVOLVED IN HIS BUSINESS SYSTEM
INTERNATIONAL- HE BECAME A
LEADER. R. S. A. THANK YOU FOR
NEAR AT RADIO SHACK YOU BE A
LEADER IN MANY LOCAL CB RADIO
GROUPS HIS LOVE FOR THE OCEAN
LET HIM AND DONNA BECOMING
CERTIFIED SCUBA DIVERS THEY
ENJOYED MANY YEARS SPEAR
FISHING OFF THE COAST OF PALACE
VERDES AND CATALINA FOR FISH
AND LOBSTER MUCH OF DENNIS'S
LIFE WAS CENTERED AROUND THE
ACTIVITIES OF HIS WIFE AND
CHILDREN SCOUTING CUB SCOUTS
BOY SCOUTS AND GIRL SCOUTS
BECAME A COMMON DENOMINATOR FOR
THE FAMILY. DENNIS HAD BEEN
CALLED THE PILLAR OF THE
COMMUNITY BY THEN TO GILBERT
TENTACLE RESERVED FOR HIS
PIONEERING SPIRIT BRINGS SCOUTS
TO WORK THE TREE GROVES HIS
LEADERSHIP AND MENTORING GAVE
MANY SCOUTS LESSONS IN LIFE TO
BECOME FUTURE COMMUNITY LEADERS
HE WAS RECOGNIZED FOR HIS MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE CITY OF
LOGAN INDIGO BY BEING NAMED THE
CITIZEN OF THE YEAR IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE. AS A VETERAN OF
THE KOREAN WAR DENNIS HAD A
PASSION FOR SUPPORTING MEMBERS
OF THE MILITARY BY COORDINATING
THE DONATION OF THOUSANDS OF
POUNDS OF NUTS POPCORN AND
OTHER TREATS AND PERSONALLY
DELIVERING THEM TO THE FIRST
BATTALION FOURTH MARINES DENNIS
IS DEEPLY MISSED BY HIS FAMILY
FRIENDS AND HIS COMMUNITY.
THERE WAS A CELEBRATION OF LIFE
FOR HIM LAST SATURDAY AND LOOK
GOOD IN A GAL HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE DONNA AND MICHAEL AND
HIS FAMILY AND DAUGHTER KAREN
AND HER FAMILY I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN DENNIS'S MEMORY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WELCOME BACK FROM OUR
RECESS WE ARE BACK TO OUR
NORMAL BUSINESS OF THE DAY.
MEMBERS IF I CAN ASK YOU TO
TAKE YOUR SEATS PLEASE AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MEMBERS IF I
CAN ASK YOU TO TAKE YOUR SEATS
PLEASE. AND WITHOUT OBJECTION I
WILL BE GOING TO SENATOR ROTH
FOREIGN ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
SENATOR RALPH PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT. IT WAS AUGUST.
TWENTY SIX TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE AND ABOUT TEN DAYS BEFORE A
CONTINGENT OF UNITED STATES
MARINES AND ATTACHED NAVY
PERSONNEL. ALONG WITH ELEMENTS
OF THE ARMY'S EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE DIVISION AND OTHERS.
HAD DEPLOYED TO KABUL TO SECURE
THE HAMID KARZAI INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT. AND ENSURE THE
EVENTUAL EVACUATION OF OVER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICANS.
AFGHANS AND OTHER FOREIGN
NATIONALS. MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN SEEKING TO ESCAPE FROM
THOSE WHO WOULD DO THEM HARM.
IT WAS CALLED OPERATION
FREEDOM'S SENTINEL. THOSE BRAVE
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN PATROLLING
THE WIRE THAT DAY THE WIRE AT
THE ABBEY GATE TO THAT AIRPORT.
DID NOT QUESTION WHY THEY WERE
THERE OR THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THEIR DEPLOYMENT.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO THEY KNEW
THE ANSWER. THE COUNTRY NEEDED
THEM. ITS PRINCIPAL OF DEVOTION
TO DUTY WITHOUT REGARD TO ONE'S
COMFORT TOWARDS SAFETY THE
CONCEPTS OF PERSONAL COURAGE
AND SELFLESS SERVICE ARE WHAT
CHARACTERIZE OUR MEN AND WOMEN
IN UNIFORM AS THEY KEEP US SAFE.
ALWAYS HAVE. ALWAYS WILL. EVEN
ON AUGUST TWENTY SIX WHEN SOME
WESTERN GOVERNMENTS WARNED
THEIR CITIZENS CITIZENS TRYING
TO ESCAPE FROM AFGHANISTAN TO
STAY AWAY FROM THE AIRPORT THAT
DAY. THOSE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN
PATROLLING THE WORD DIDN'T
LEAVE THEIR POSTS. BECAUSE THEY
WOULDN'T DO THAT HOWEVER. SO
THAT SAME DAY AT ABOUT EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS AT SIX PM LOCAL
TIME THERE. AS THEY CONTINUE TO
STAND WATCH AT THE ABBEY GATE
PROTECTING OTHERS AND TRYING TO
KEEP THEM SAFE. AS YOU KNOW A
POWERFUL TERRORIST BOMB BLAST
ROCKED THAT GATE. FILLING
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE AND
WOUNDING COUNTLESS OTHERS.
INCLUDED IN THOSE TRAGICALLY
KILLED WERE THIRTEEN BRAVE US
SERVICE MEN AND WOMEN. ONE OF
WHOM TWENTY YEAR OLD LANCE
CORPORAL KAREEM TO COULD BE
CALLED NORCO CALIFORNIA WITHIN
THE THIRTY FIRST SENATE
DISTRICT. HOME REPORTS INDICATE
THE LANCE CORPORAL MCCURLEY.
WAS ATTEMPTING TO RESCUE ONE
MORE CHILD FROM OUTSIDE THE
WIRE AT THE TIME TIME THAT BOMB
WENT OFF. THE LANCE CORPORAL
THE CREW IT WAS A PROUD MEMBER
OF THE SECOND BATTALION FIRST
MARINE REGIMENT FIRST MARINE
DIVISION STATIONED AT CAMP
PENDLETON. IN THIS GREAT STATE.
HE GRADUATED FROM NORCO HIGH IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND WHILE
THERE. HE PARTICIPATED IN AIR
FORCE JUNIOR ROTC. BUT HIS DAD
STEVE SAID. HE REALLY ALWAYS
WANTED TO BE A UNITED STATES
MARINE. I DON'T BLAME THEM. HIS
CLASSMATES COMMUNITY FRIENDS
TEACHERS AND OTHERS DESCRIBED
HIM AS A LEADER. WITH A BIG
HEART AS CARING AND COMPASSION
THAT IS SUPER CONFIDENT IN
EVERYTHING HE DID. AS
CHARISMATIC. ALTHOUGH LANCE
CORPORAL MCCURRY WAS ONLY WITH
US ON THIS EARTH FOR TWENTY
VERY VERY SHORT YEARS HE
CLEARLY LEFT AN INDELIBLE MARK
ON HIS COMMUNITY AND THOSE WITH
WHOM HE INTERACTED. AS THE NEWS
OF HIS TRAGIC DEATH SPREAD
ACROSS HIS COMMUNITY AND OUR
REGION AND THE STATE. THE
IMPACT OF HIS LIFE AND HIS
DEATH TRULY HIT HOME. THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS GATHER TO HONOR
HIM WITH VARIOUS MEMORIAL
GATHERINGS WITH A HIKE. WITH A
SALUTE TO HIS MIRROR MEMORY.
CLEARLY HE MADE A DIFFERENCE.
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF OUR
MILITARY DO NOT HESITATE WHEN
CALL TO ACTION. ONE OF THE
RESPONDING TO CONFLICTS OR TO
HUMANITARIAN CRISES IN FOREIGN
LANDS THEY DON'T QUESTION. THEY
JUST SHOW UP SALUTE SMARTLY AND
PERFORM THEIR DUTY TO THE BEST
OF THEIR ABILITY. AND THEN SOME.
DAY AFTER DAY NIGHT AFTER NIGHT
REGARDLESS OF THE THREAT OF
DANGER TO THEMSELVES. OR TO
OTHERS. THEY REPRESENT THE BEST
OF US. LANCE CORPORAL MIKKO E.
REPRESENTED THE BEST OF US. SO
AS WE LEAVE HERE TODAY LET'S
REMEMBER HIS SACRIFICE AND THE
SACRIFICE OF THE OTHER
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN KILLED OR
WOUNDED IN ACTION AND PLEDGE TO
DO ALL THAT WE CAN TO MODEL OUR
LIVES IN SERVICE. AS THEY DID.
SEMPER FI MARINE. MADAM
PRESIDENT AFTER MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LAKE ELSINORE OFFERS A FEW
WORDS MAY WE HAVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE IN HONOR OF LANCE
CORPORAL KAREEM TO KUWAIT
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH CENTER
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU AN
SENATORS I WANT TO- I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE FOR THE
BEAUTIFUL TRIBUTE THAT HE JUST
PAID TO LEEDS PERPENDICULARLY
ON WHO WAS HIS CONSTITUENT I
TOO WOULD LIKE TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF KAREEM I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS PAST SATURDAY
TO ATTEND A VIGIL FOR LANCE
CORPORAL NICK- USABLE AS A
TWELVE OTHER MILITARY MEMBERS
WHO WERE KILLED IN THAT BLAST.
AND HIS MOTHER AND STEPFATHER
IN FAMILY SHARED SOME THINGS
WITH ME ABOUT KAREEM AT THAT
THEY ASKED THAT I WOULD SHARE
WITH ALL OF YOU SO THAT
EVERYONE KNOWS REALLY WHO
KAREEM WISE SO IF I MAY. THE
FIRST. THANK YOU ALL FOR
RECOGNIZING OUR SON BROTHER
UNCLE AND FRIEND UNITED STATES
MARINE LANCE CORPORAL KAREEM
THE QB. WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE THAT
EVERY LIFE GIVEN IN DEFENSE OF
THIS GREAT NATION IS JUST AS
SPECIAL AND SIGNIFICANT AS ARE
LOST. THIS IS OUR SECOND STORY
AND HOW WE WOULD LIKE HIS
LEGACY TO BE REMEMBERED. OUR
SON WAS BORN KARIM MAY LEAD
GRANT MACU E. ON JANUARY FOURTH
TWO THOUSAND ONE. SADLY HE WAS
ONE OF THE THIRTEEN HE PASSED
IN THE SUICIDE BOMBING IN KABUL
AFGHANISTAN. ON AUGUST TWENTY
SIX TWENTY TWENTY ONE. HE DIED
NOT ONLY DEFENDING THIS COUNTRY
AND ITS INTEREST BUT ON THAT
DAY SPECIFICALLY WHILE
DEFENDING OTHERS. ULTIMATELY
GOING BACK TO RETRIEVE ANOTHER
FAMILY WITH A CHILD TO BRING
THEMTO SAFETY DURING THE CHAOS
BEFORE THE BLAST. IT WOULD BE
OUR SONS LAST SELFLESS ACT.
WHAT YOU WILL NOT READ IN THE
PAPER OR SEE ON THE NEWS IS
THAT OUR SON WAS NOT A VICTIM.
SINCE THE AGE OF FIVE. KAREEM
WANTED TO BE A MARINE. HE GREW
UP PLAYING AIRSOFT CAMPING AND
HIKING IN OUR HILLS IN TENTH
GRADE HE WOULD FOLLOW THE
MARINE RECRUITERS AROUND
TELLING THEM HE WANTED TO BE A
MARINE. AND HE SHOWED THEM HOW
MANY PUSHUPS OR PULL UP SO HE
COULD DO. WHEN CREAM WAS ASKED
BY HIS COMMANDING OFFICER AND
HIS HIGH SCHOOL JUNIOR ROTC
CLASS TO SHARE SOMETHING ABOUT
THEMSELVES. AND WHAT THEY
WANTEDTO BE HE REPLIED. I'M
GOING TO BE A MARINE. IN HIS
COMMANDING OFFICER REPLIED. IS
THERE ANYTHING ELSE WE SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT YOU. IN CREAM
REPLIED YEP I'M GOING TO BE A
MARINE. GROWING UP OUR SON WAS
ALSO CHAMPIONED YOU TO WRESTLE
WRESTLER. WINNING GOLD MEDALS
IN BOTH NATIONAL AND WORLD
COMPETITIONS. HE OFTEN
CHALLENGED HIMSELF BY WRESTLING
YOUNG MEN BIGGER THAN HIMSELF
STRIVING TO IMPROVE. AND THIS
WAS NOT JUST A PHYSICAL TRAIT
BUT REPRESENTED OUR SON'S HEART.
CREAMS ARE INVALUABLE DEFINED
WHEN HE GAVE HIS LIFE AND FAITH
TO JESUS CHRIST IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AT THE HARVEST VESSEL
INTO A STADIUM. HE WAS BAPTIZED
THE SAME HERE WITH OUR FAMILY
GRACE FELLOWSHIP CHURCH IN
NORCO CALIFORNIA IT IS THROUGH.
HIS FAITH AND CONVICTIONS THAT
NUMEROUS SELFLESS ACTS WERE
DONE FOR OTHERS FROM A SIMPLE
SET UP A TOY DOG TAGS GIVEN TO
A NEIGHBORHOOD FRIEND AS A
CHILD. HELPING A NEIGHBOR
BEFORE BEING DEPLOYED WITH
MOVING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
GRAVEL EVEN THOUGH HE NEVER MET
HIM BEFORE. TO HAVING HIS
FELLOW MARINES WHO DIDN'T LIVE
LOCALLY AND WHO HAD NO PLACE O
GO VISIT WITH OUR FAMILY IN OUR
HOME ESPECIALLY ON HOLIDAYS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY DURING HIS FIRST
YEAR AS A MARINE KARIM DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF MONEY TO GET A
GIFT THAT HE THOUGHT WAS
SUITABLE FOR HIS MOM. SO HE
LEFT A NOTE ON YOUR PILLOW
PROMISING TO SPOIL HER NEXT
YEAR WHEN HE HAD MORE MONEY.
AND HE FULFILLED THAT PROMISE
BUYING YOUR PAINTING SHOES
SLIPPERS BODY WASHES AND MORE
FOR HER BIRTHDAY THE NEXT YEAR.
IF YOU'VE SEEN THE VIDEO OF OUR
SUN ROOF AND BEFRIENDING A
PRECIOUS LITTLE GIRL. PLEASE
NOTE THAT HE BOUGHT CANDY FOR
THOSE CHILDREN WITH HIS OWN
MONEY KNOWING THAT THEY WERE
TERRIFIED TRYING TO COMFORT
THEM. IN THE SAME VIDEO HE GAVE
HER FATHER A DRINK MIX PACKETS.
WE GIVE WATER TO THOSE WHO NEED
IT THESE ARE GIVEN OF HIS
HEART. ALL WHILE PROVIDING A
SERVICE ASKED OF HIM AND HIS
FELLOW MARINES. IN CLOSING WE
WOULD LIKE YOU TO KNOW THAT YOU
SENT ONE OF THIS NATION'S
FINEST EXAMPLES. OF WHAT CREAMS
FAITH MARINE CORPS IN THIS
COUNTRY STANDS FOR. AS A FAMILY
NATION AND COMMUNITY. WE HAVE
LOST ONE OF OUR FINEST EXAMPLES
AS WELL. HE NEVER WANTED TO BE
CALLED A HERO. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY HE DIED BEING ONE
AND WE ARE PROUD TO CALL HIM OR
SEND. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME AND I
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN LANCE
CORPORAL CURRIE MCCURRY'S
MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MELINDA AS MEMBERS OF I
CAN ASK YOU ALL TO STAND SO
THAT WE MAY HAVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE FOR. MARINE CORPS LANCE
CORPORAL NICU E.
THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH
AND SENATOR MELINDA THIS.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AT THIS
MOMENT. WITHOUT OBJECTION
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE THIRTY
THREE POINT ONE JOINT RULE
SIXTY ONE WILL BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW SOMEBODY BILLS SIX
SEVENTY AND TEN FIFTY FIVE TO
BE AMENDED AFTER THE DEADLINE
THE REQUEST HAS BEEN APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE'RE
IS- SENATOR SKINNER FOR PERCY
RISE OF MOTION. FOR AN ACTOR
YES PLEASE PROCEED. ON THE
REQUEST FOR THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE FILE ITEM TO A ONE. THE B.
TWO FIFTY TWO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REQUESTS TO THE INACTIVE FILE
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. VERY
GOOD WE'RE NOW GOING. ONE MORE
WHO MIGHT SIT SENATOR COME
LONGER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY TWO THE INACTIVE FILE
THE DESK WILL KNOW THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. ALL RIGHT VERY
GOOD WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE AND
ONE NINETY FIVE SENATOR AIKMAN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMES ASSEMBLYMEMBER X. SKEWS
ME SENATOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT THAT'S OKAY. I
AM PROUD TO RISE TODAY TO- TO
DO CENTER THIS SUMMER CRISTY
GARCIA'S AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE.
WHICH CLARIFIES THAT RAPE IS
RAPE REGARDLESS OF ONE'S
MARITAL STATUS I RESPECT FOR
YOU ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK
YOU SENATOR EDMUND AND MEMBERS
WE STILL DO NOT HAVE A FULL
HOUSE WILL BE GOING TO THE ROLE
ONE TIME AND PUTTING MEASURES
ON CALL MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA.
FIVE ATKINS. I FACE. HI BACKER.
HI FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE I
GOTTA. I PROTECTING. I DALLY I
DON FIVE TORONTO HI EGGMAN FIVE
LASER I CONSOLIDATE I GROVE
FIVE HURTS BERG. WEST SO. HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON. HI
WIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN. HI I.
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO. I
ROCKED I REVIEW HI SKINNER I
STERN ON BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. SENATOR MOVES A
CALL MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
FILE AND ONE NINETY SIX SENATOR
OCHO BOTH MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAZE AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING
CENTER- TROUBLED. MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEN MAINS
THIS LEGISLATION IS ONE SMALL
PIECE IN A LARGER PUSH TO MAKE
HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. IMPACT AND
DEVELOPMENT FEES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNDER DENSITY BONUS LAW
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECT THE
OVERALL COST OF THE PROJECT AND
ARE OFTEN PASS ALONG TO BUYERS
IN THE FORM OF HIGHER HOME
PRICES OR CAN EVEN PREVENT
PROJECTS FROM MOVING FORWARD.
AS WE SEEK TO ENCOURAGE
DEVELOPERS TO MAXIMIZE
AFFORDABLE UNITS HE DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE TO DISSUADE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE UNITS WITHIN A
DENSITY BONUS APPLICATION BY
IMPOSING THESE EXCESSIVE FEES.
IN ORDER TO FIX THIS EIGHTY
FIVE SEVENTY ONE SIMPLY
PROHIBITS IMPOSING CERTAIN FEES
FOR DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS. SENATE FOR MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED TO AVOID CHAPTER
RING OUT ISSUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SENATOR CHOI BOGUE
MEMBERS ANY. DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THE-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BAIT. FIVE BACKER HI FORGES
BRADFORD. I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTESE FIVE DALLY. HI TODD. I
TORONTO. I EGGMAN FIVE LASER I
CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROVE FIVE
HURTS BURKE. WEST SO. HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA I THE MON FIVE WIRE
FIVE MELINDA'S. FIVE MIN FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I UNTIL A VOTE
HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS
HI RUBIO I SKINNER. HI STERN
I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT HI WHAT
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL. SENATOR
MUSICAL MEMBERS RUBY ON THE
FILE AND ONE NINETY NINE
SENATOR OCHO ABODE AND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FIFTEEN BY FAMILY
MEMBER CHAN AN ACT RELATING TO
TRUST PAST ZERO TO BOOK. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FIFTEEN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAN. EIGHTY
FIVE FIFTEEN CLARIFIES
TRESPASSING PROVISIONS TO
PROTECT REPOSSESSION AGENCIES
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES WHILE
SEARCHING FOR COLLATERAL.
HOWEVER UNDER THIS BILL THEY
WOULD STILL BE SUBJECT TO
TRESPASSING LAWS AT PRIVATE AND
SECURE LOCATIONS. THIS BILL
SIMPLY PROVIDES NEEDED
CLARIFICATION TO ENSURE THAT
TRUST WE PROFESSORS ARE NOT
PUNISHED OR ARRESTED FOR
DRIVING A VEHICLE ONTO A
PROPERTY OF ANOTHER PERSON WHEN
SEARCHING FOR COLLATERAL OR
REPOSSESS THE COLLATERAL. AND
IF A BLIND COMPLETING THE
SEARCH THEY LEAVE THE PRIVATE
PROPERTY IMMEDIATELY. THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
IN BOTH CHAMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR OTOBO THE
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BASE HI BECKER ARI FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE I HAVE- I
CORTESE I DALLY. I DONT I
TORONTO I ADMIN I. GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES I DROVE FIVE
FIRSTS BURKE. WESO HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MOMENT I WILL GO
THERE HI MELINDA'S I MAN I
NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN ARE YOU A
TRAVEL BOOK I PAN I FORTUNE
TINO I BROUGHT I REVERE I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG ALL
RIGHT HI FORECASTING I WINNER I
WILL. SENATOR MOVES THE CALL
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM TWO ZERO THREE
SENATOR MAN ARE YOU PREPARED.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRI NORRIS
AN ACT RELATING TO FIREARMS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I DON'T KNOW
WHY I'M DOING THAT TONIGHT
SENATOR MAN OKAY. THANKS
SENATOR- MADAM PRESIDENT- THIS
BILL CLOSES THE LOOPHOLE BY
UPDATING THE DEFINITION OF
SEASONAL FIREARMS FOR GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS. TO ALSO INCLUDE GHOST
GUNS HI IT IS AN UNDETECTABLE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION IN PAST
SEVENTY FIVE ZERO ID SIMPLY FOR
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU CENTERMAN
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA. I AT
KINS. I BASE. FIVE BACKER HI
FORGES BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM
HI FOR TESTING I DALLY. HI TODD
HI TORONTO. HI EGGMAN FIVE
LASER HI CONSOLIDATES FIVE
GROVE HI EXPERTS BERG. WESTERN
HER TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LIVE ON HI I THE MOON
I REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
BOTH I PAN FIVE PORTS IN CHINO
HI ROTH I REVIEW. I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG HI HI WE CASKEY
FIVE WINNER I WILL. SENATOR
MUSICAL MEMBERS REMOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM TWO ZERO FOUR SENATOR
ROTH MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
THIRTY FIVE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS. SENATOR ROB
THIRTY MINUTE PRESIDENT THIS
BILL IS THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE
VETERINARY MEDICINE MEDICAL
BOARD. WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
LICENSING AND REGULATION OF
VETERINARIANS VETERINARY
TECHNICIANS AND VETERINARY
PREMISES. THE BILL CONTAINS
SEVERAL POLICY CHANGES
IDENTIFIED BY THE JOINT
COMMITTEES THE COMMITTEE
BACKGROUND PAPER AND
STAKEHOLDERS AMONG THOSE
CHANGES THE BILL REORGANIZES
THE BILLS FEE STRUCTURE. AND
ALLOW SHELTER STAFF TO
ADMINISTER SPECIFIC VACCINES
AND MEDICATIONS BUT THE
PRESENCE OF A VETERINARIAN IF
CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE MET.
RESPECTFULLY AS YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH NUMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS. DEBATE CENTER
NIELSEN. MADAM PRESIDENT-
QUESTION THE AUTHOR IF I MAY
SAY ROUGHLY TAKE A QUESTION-
CERTAINLY TRY PLEASE FOR. THE
CHAIRMAN I I'M JUST CURIOUS
ABOUT THE PROVISION HERE IN
THIS AND SUNSET BILL WHICH
REMOVES A REQUIREMENT FOR THE
VETERINARIANS AND THE
TECHNICIANS TO HAVE A PASS A
STATE LICENSING EXAMINATIONS.
THAT'S A LITTLE UNUSUAL DO YOU
KNOW WHY THEY WOULD BE DOING
THAT. WELL I DON'T FRANKLY
REMEMBER OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
BUT- I CAN FIND THAT IN JUST
ONE SECOND YOU'RE- WELCOME IF
YOUR LEISURE THAT'S OKAY I WANT
TO HOLD THE WHOLE THING UP.
JUST FOR THAT VISION BUT IT'S
OF SOME CONCERN TO A LAY OFF
UNTIL I FIND OUT WELL LET ME
TRY TO EXPLAIN IT AS BEST THEY
CAN AS IT'S CURRENTLY DRAFTED
THIS BILL RESTRUCTURES THE
EXAMINATION REQUIREMENTS. AND
ELIMINATES THE CURRENTLY
UTILIZE STATE EXAMINATION IN
FAVOR OF A SINGLE. NATIONAL
EXAM AS I RECALL TO AVOID
COMPLICATIONS. THAT THAT GETS
TO THAT ANSWER. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON THANK YOU CENTER
ROB MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BASE I BECKER I
PORCHES. BRADFORD HI COME BY
ADAM I PROTECTING. I DALLY FIVE
DON I DRAW SO I EXAMINE. I
BELIEVE HER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HI HURTS BERG I WAS SO. HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MOON I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S I MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON I A TOTAL OF
BOTH I. TEN. I POURED IN GENOME.
I BROUGHT I REVIEW HI SKINNER I
STERN NUMBER HI I WORK OUT SKI
I WINNER I WILL. REMOVE THE
CALL MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR ROTH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AROUND US AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH FACILITIES
ETCETERA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT INDIVIDUALS SEEKING
EMERGENCY PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES
HAVE TIMELY ACCESS TO
ADDITIONAL CARE AND SERVICES
THAT MAY BE NEEDED BY REQUIRING
ALL HOSPITALS TO ACCEPT HIGHER
LEVEL PSYCHIATRIC TRANSFERS
WITHOUT REGARD. TO A PATIENT'S
ABILITY TO PAY A RECENT
AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I
ADKINS I BATES I BECKER HI
PORGES BRADFORD. I COME BY
OTHER I PROTESTED I DALLY. I
DON HI THERE ALSO I EGGMAN. HI
GLAZER. HI CONSOLIDATES. HI
GROWTH ARE YOU HURTS BERG I WAS
SO. HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
ORDER I LAYERED I LABOR HI THE
MOON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I
MEN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A
TOTAL OF BOTH HI PAM I FORTINO.
I ROCKED I REVIEW I SKINNER I
STERN ON BURKE ALL RIGHT HI WE
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
FOUR SENATOR- CHOCOBO MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS CENTER
CHOKE. MADAM PRESIDENT AND THAT
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AT TEN
FIFTEEN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO. WE ARE
ALL AWARE OF THE STRESS THE
PAST YEAR HAS PLACED ON OUR
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND IN
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE AN
ALREADY THIN WORKFORCE HAS BEEN
STRETCHED EVEN FURTHER.
CALIFORNIA HAS HISTORICALLY AND
CONSISTENTLY PRODUCED A HIGHLY
QUALIFIED NURSING WORKFORCE
HOWEVER NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
ARE STRUGGLING TO ADDRESS
DEMAND SPECIALLY REGIONAL
DEMAND. FOR NEW AND EXISTING
NURSING PROGRAMS TO HELP
FORECAST AND PROJECTED MANNED
AND AVAILABILITY OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS FOR NURSING
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE. OF
CALIFORNIA LOOKS TO ADDRESS
BOTH REGIONAL AND PROJECTED
STATEWIDE NURSING SHORTAGES THE
BEER AND YOU SHOULD BE USING
ALL AVAILABLE TOOLS TO ENSURE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE AND
ROMAN OF NURSING STUDENTS IN
PRE LICENSURE PROGRAMS. THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RECEIVING
ZERO NO VOTES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECT BELIEVE REQUEST- I
ABOUT THANK YOU SENATOR OCHO
BOTH NUMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE I WAS THIRTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WE
ARE NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY SIX SENATOR ROTH
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AN ACT
RELATING TO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES SENATOR ROTH. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THREE PRIMARY ISSUES
NUMBER ONE AND IT ENSURES THAT
NEW CANNABINOID DRUGS ONCE FDA
APPROVED ARE AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING FROM
DEBILITATING DISEASES LIKE
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS. TO SIMPLY
ALIGNS CALIFORNIA LAW WITH
EXISTING FEDERAL LAW THAT
EXEMPTS CERTAIN COMBINATION
DRUGS FROM FDA SCHEDULING. AND
THREE RESTORES THE ABILITY OF
YOU UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RESEARCHERS TO ACCESS SECURES
DATA IN ORDER TO CONDUCT
MEANINGFUL DATA DRIVEN RESEARCH
THE BILL AS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR NOVEL THANK
YOU CENTER ROF MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE I WAS THIRTY FIVE
NEWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY SEVEN SENATOR
HERTZBERG MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAY AS AN ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THEY EVEN PRESIDENT
THERE ARE MAJOR STATUTORY
INEQUITIES. IN SCHOOL LAYOFF
PROTECTIONS IN HEARING RIGHTS.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS MEASURE IS
TO STANDARDIZE THE LAYOFF
PROCESS IS SO THAT CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WILL RECEIVE THE SAME
LAYOFF NOTICE AND HEARING
RIGHTS AS TEACHERS AND
CERTIFICATED ADMINISTRATORS.
WITH INSURERS THAT THERE'S
THESE NOTICES EXIST IN EQUITY
IN THE PROCESS THAT'S THE
REASON THE BILLS HERE THAT'S
THE REASON I'M STANDING UP AND
THAT'S THE REASON I'M ASKING
YOU FOR NOT A VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
CHOKE. MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE FOUR THIRTY EIGHT THIS
MEASURE ALTHOUGH WELL INTENDED
SIGNIFICANTLY CURTAIL THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
TO MAKE LOCALLY INFORMED AND
ACCURATE BUDGET DECISIONS IT
DOES THIS BY ELIMINATING THIS
EXISTING SIXTY DAY LAYOFF
NOTICE REQUIREMENT FOR
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL STAFF IN A
LINE TO TODAY IN MOVABLE DATE
OF MARCH FIFTEENTH. JUST LIKE
ANY OTHER EMPLOYER PERSONAL
COSTS MAKE UP 8290% OF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S BUDGET AS A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I'M GREATLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES THIS WILL HAVE ON
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS SCHOOL
BOARDS. IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
THE STATE BUDGET. BY MANDATING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ACT UPON
NEARLY 90% OF ITS BUDGET THREE
MONTHS BEFORE STATE BUDGET IS
ADOPTED. IT WOULD ALSO RESTRICT
FUTURE LEGISLATURES BY
MANDATING THAT ANY FUTURE
NOTICING RIGHT. PROVIDED TO
TEACHERS WOULD AUTOMATICALLY
EXTEND IT TO CLASSIFIED STAFF
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE RIGHT
OR APPROPRIATE OR BENEFICIAL TO
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES. LASTLY IT
ALSO COMES AT A TIME WHEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BOTH LARGE AND
SMALL ENTER THE TESTING WINDOW.
WHICH IS ALREADY A CHALLENGING
TIME FOR EACH OF YOUR FOR
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND STAFF.
THIS WILL UNNECESSARILY
INCREASE THE DISRUPTION AND
UNCERTAINTY THAT ALREADY EXISTS
WITH THE MARCH FIFTEENTH
DEADLINE. PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WERE ALREADY
FACING DIFFICULT CHALLENGES
DECLINING ENROLLMENT THE
STATE'S LONG TERM PROJECTED
BUDGET DEFICIT. INCREASING
PENSION COSTS AND OTHER FISCAL
IMPACTS. I UNDERSTAND THE
DESIRE TO HAVE A DATE CERTAIN
LAW WHEN IT COMES TO LAYING OFF
NOTICING. HOWEVER THIS BILL
ALIGNS IT TO AN UNWORKABLE AND
HIGHLY PROBLEM PROBLEMATIC DATE
THEY WILL DO MORE HARM THAN
GOOD. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR CHOKE
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
REALLY DID STRUGGLE TO STAND UP
AND SPEAK ON THIS BILL. AS THE
ONLY TEACHER ON THE FLOOR. AS
THE ONLY MEMBER OF THIS BODY
THAT'S RECEIVED A PINK SLIP. AS
HAD THAT HAS GIVEN PINK SLIPS
ON THE ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE. I
DO BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. I
REMEMBER HOW DRAMATIC IT IS.
EVERY MARCH FIFTEENTH WHEN YOU
ARE PAYING SLIPPED. THE
DEPRESSION THAT COMES UPON YOUR
SCHOOL COMMUNITY. HOW TEACHERS
ARE WALKING AROUND SAD WITH
LONG FACES AND THERE'S NOTHING
YOU CAN DO AS A TEACHER
SUPPORTING OTHER TEACHERS. AND
AS AN ADMINISTRATOR TRYING TO
SUPPORT YOUR TEACHERS IT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT EASY FOR
ANYONE. AND I DON'T OPPOSE
ANYTHING IN THIS BILL IN TERMS
OF EQUITY I THINK THAT
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES SHOULD
HAVE THAT EQUITY. WHAT I TAKE
ISSUE WITH THIS BUT NOTICE
DATE. I THINK MARCH FIFTEENTH
IS SO EARLY TO TRY AND NOTICE
PEOPLE. ESPECIALLY AT A TIME
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEIR BUDGET IS. WHAT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE
ENCOURAGEMENT OF OVER THANKS
FOR LETTING PEOPLE. AND THOSE
FAMILIES THAT REALLY DEPEND ON
THIS. JOB TO PULL THROUGH THIS
EMOTIONAL ROLLER COASTER. THAT
I'VE HAD TO ENTER AS A TEACHER
I HAVE. HOLD A LOT OF MY
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES. AS WELL
AS TEACHERS JUST TO GET THEIR
INPUT. BECAUSE I KNOW THAT I'VE
BEEN OUT OF THE CLASSROOM FOR A
FEW YEARS JUST TO SEE WHERE
THEY STAND AND HOW THEY FEEL.
AND THEY WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SEE. THE DAY JUST BE PUSHED A
LITTLE FURTHER I KNOW THAT THE
DATE I BELIEVE IT WAS MARCH WAS
OFFERED AND WAS REJECTED. AND
FOR ME HAVING A DISTRICT THAT
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT THEIR BUDGET
IS IT'S JUST GOING TO ENCOURAGE
THE OVERPAYING SLIPPING OF OUR
TEACHERS I'M SORRY ARE ARE
CLASSIFIED. AND IT'S NOT AN
EASY THING TO DO. NOT IN MARCH
FIFTEEN WE USED TO HAVE THREE
POTENTIAL THREE MONTHS TO GOAL.
AND OUR CHILDREN ARE DEPENDING
ON THESE TEACHERS AND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES TO CARRY
THEM THROUGH THE END OF THE
YEAR. AGAIN I'M IN COMPLETE
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IF THE
DATE WOULD BE MAY. AT LEAST ONE
A MAY REVISE COMES AROUND SO
YOU'RE NOT AGAIN. GIVEN THESE
PINK SLIPS JUST BECAUSE THE
DISTRICT HAS TO PROTECT ITSELF.
TO US IT MAY BE EASY BUT
SOMEONE LOCAL. I. LOW WAGE
EARNER IN OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR
SCHOOL COMMUNITY THEY HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THIS EVERY YEAR JUST
BECAUSE WE SET UP THE SYSTEM.
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE NOTIFIED
I THINK IT REALLY IS
HEARTBREAKING. AND I JUST FEEL
THAT I DON'T WANT TO PUT. OUR
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES AND THE
EMOTIONAL ROLLER COASTER THAT I
HAD TO ENTER. AS A TEACHER. AND
I THINK WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE. THE DISTRICT A LITTLE
MORE TIME SO THEY'RE NOT JUST
OVERPAYING FLIPPING. THAT THEY
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THESE
EMPLOYEES. BUT I WILL BE VERY
CLEAR I AGREE WITH EVERY. PIECE
OF. SECTIONS IN THESE IN THIS
BILL I'M NOT OPPOSING THE BILL
I JUST A POST THE DATE. AND FOR
THESE REASONS I'M GONNA HAVE TO
STAFF TODAY THANK YOU.THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO SAID ROTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW BEFORE I TOOK A- THIS JOB
IF WE CALL THEM JOBS AND-
200-012-2000 THIRTEEN. I WAS UP
BATTLING THE HOLES OF THIS
PLACE- MEETING WITH PEOPLE TO.
TRY TO BUT JUST WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE JUST SPOKE ABOUT
WHICH IS THE ARTIFICIAL DATE OF
MARCH AT WHICH POINT SCHOOL
BOARDS DISTRICTS. AND OTHERS
HAVE TO PROVIDE THAT PINK SLIP
TO TEACHERS SORT OF ARTIFICIAL
IN THE SENSE THAT WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN BUT WE'RE TELLING YOU
YOU'RE GOING TO BE LAID OFF
BUT- YOU MAY NOT BE BUT YOU
KNOW. IT'LL BE AWHILE BEFORE WE
FIGURED OUT. WE WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL IN TRYING TO BRING
ABOUT REFORM. OBVIOUSLY SOME
DON'T WANT REFORM AND THAT'S
FINE BUT IN LOOKING AT THIS
BILL I'M SORT OF CONFLICTED
BECAUSE I DO AGREE THAT THE
MARCH DATE NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED
AND PUTS A BURDEN ON OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN OUR SCHOOL BOARDS
AROUND THE STATE- I HAVEN'T
THOUGHT THROUGH WHAT THE
VARIOUS ISSUES ARE I'M SURE
THEY'RE MANY AND I'M SURE IF WE
EVER GET AROUND TO IT HERE. WE
WILL EXPLORE THOSE FULLY. BUT
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT THE
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE NOT TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS. DON'T HAVE
THE PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BUILT INTO THE LAW.
HOWEVER ARTIFICIAL THAT DATE IS
THEY DON'T GET THE PINK SLIP
WITH PLENTY OF NOTICE. HOWEVER
DEPRESSING THAT MAY BE AN
UPSETTING. THEY ALSO HAVE
HEARING RIGHTS AS I RECALL AS
PART OF THE PROCESS AN HOUR.
OTHER NON TEACHER NOT
ADMINISTRATOR EMPLOYEES HAVE NO
HEARING RIGHTS AND SO WHAT
BOTHERS ME ABOUT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS THAT IT'S COMPLETELY
INEQUITABLE. AND CERTAINLY THE
LOWEST PAID. AMONG THE HARDEST
WORKING. WE'RE CERTAINLY
WORKING AS HARD AS THE OTHER
EMPLOYEES IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE ARE
THESE OTHER EMPLOYEES AND WHY
NOT PROVIDE THEM THE SAME
PROTECTION THAT WE PROVIDE THE
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS AND
IF THE DATE NEEDS TO BE
ADJUSTED BECAUSE IT'S
ARTIFICIAL ROOT CAUSES PEOPLE
TO BE UPSET OR DEPRESSED AS IT
WOULD. AND SHOULD I'M SURE.
THEN LET'S DO THAT BUT I HAVE
DECIDED EVEN THOUGH I WAS. CORN
I'VE DECIDED TO COME DOWN IN
FAVOR OF SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TO PROVIDE PROTECTIONS FOR
THOSE WHO WORK VERY VERY HARD
ENTER AT THE LOWER END OF THE
PAY SCALE IN JUST ABOUT EVERY
IF NOT EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU I'M OUT OF PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I. I RISE TO- TO JOIN
IN THE- THE ARTICULATE COMMENTS
FROM THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES WHO SPOKE EARLIER. ON
ISSUES LIKE THIS HAVING EACH OF
US I THINK TRY TO PUT OURSELVES
IN THE PLACE. OF THE EMPLOYEE
IN THIS CASE THE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEE AND IT WOULD THIS IS
HAPPENING TO ME- WOULD I WANT
TO HAVE THIS NOTICE AND
CERTAINLY THE ANSWER IS YES-
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND YOU THINK
ABOUT IT FROM A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER AND MANY MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR HAD BEEN SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS. AND YOU THINK ABOUT
THE DILEMMA THEY FACE WHEN THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE THEIR BUDGET
YET UNTIL. JULY FIRST AND
THEY'RE FORCED TO MAKE A
CHOICE. THAT WE'VE GOT TO GIVE
NOTICE IN MARCH FOR SOMETHING
IN WHICH IT'S SO DIFFICULT TO
HAVE. A REAL UNDERSTANDING OF
THAT BUDGET. AND SO FOR ME I
WANT AT LEAST EXPLAIN WHY THE-
TODAY DID NOT SUPPORT THIS
BILL. IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE SHOULD BE SOME
PROTECTIONS FOR EMPLOYEES.
WHETHER IT'S TEACHERS OR
CLASSIFIED STAFF ANDI THINK
THAT. IF THIS BILL IS SO CLOSE
TO BEING WHERE IT SHOULD BE.
BUT THE DATE I THINK IS TO
REJECT THEM DOES IT MEAN WE
SHOULD EXAMINE IT FOR. FOR
EVERYONE I'M OPEN TO THAT I
THINK THAT. WE HAVE TO BE
REALITIC AND WE DON'T WANT TO
CREATE THESE MORALE PROBLEMS
WHICH CURRENT LAW DOES PROVIDE.
FOR THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
WHO HAVE TO BE FORCED TO. GIVE
THESE NOTICES AND TO THE
TEACHERS THEMSELVES AND IN THIS
CASE. OF THIS BILL THE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES. TO CREATE
THAT SORT OF MORALE PROBLEM
BECAUSE- THEY'RE GOING TO THE
SCHOOL BOARD'S GONNA ERR ON THE
SIDE. OF HAVING TO PROTECT THE
DISTRICT WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE
TO SEND OUT MORE NOTICES THAT
IS REQUIRED. SO THAT THIS BILL
HAS THE BEST OF INTENTIONS. I
DO THINK THERE'S A GOOD EQUITY
ARGUMENT. FOR CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES AND TEACHERS. BUT THE
STATE IS NOT A WORKABLE DATE MY
FRIENDS. AND THEREFORE
RELUCTANTLY I WON'T BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZER SENATOR
CORTESE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE. IN SUPPORT OF A. BEFORE
THIRTY EIGHT AND A ONE OF A
SOCIALLY MY COMMENTS WITH. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE- IT
WITHOUT REPEATING A LOT OF WHAT
HE SAID- I'VE BEEN HERE-
THROUGH ALMOST ONE FULL.
SESSION AT LEAST THE FIRST YEAR
OF ONE WHAT I'VE LEARNED. I
THINK. ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ATTEMPT TO. RECTIFY AND
CHANGE. IS THAT. YOU HAVE TO.
TO TAKE THEM ONE STEP AT A TIME
IN THE STEP THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO TAKE TODAY IS PARITY. I
THINK- IN DEFENSE OF THE
AUTHOR. AND OTHERS WHO HAVE
WORKED ON THIS BILL. OPENING UP
THE DATE. WHICH I TOO BELIEVE
IS A PROBLEM. WHICH IS WHY I
ASSOCIATED. MY COMMENT SO WITH
MY COLLEAGUE- AND OTHERS WHO
WERE BROUGHT UP THAT ISSUE-
INCLUDING THE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CONTRA COSTA. IT IS A PROBLEM.
BUT IT INVOLVES. A WHOLE. OTHER
SET OF EXTENDED STAKE HOLDERS.
OF THE FRANKLY WOULD HAVE.
COMPLICATED THIS SINGULAR ISSUE
OF WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD
HAVE PARITY. RIGHT NOW ALL. OF
FOR ALL EMPLOYEES INCLUDING
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES SO. I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SITTING IN HEARING
NONE SENATOR HERTZBERG PLEASE
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS. MEMBER
FROM BALDWIN PARK IN YUCAIPA
SAN JOSE IN RIVERSIDE AND.
CONTRA COSTA SORRY ABOUT THAT-
PRECIADO DISCUSSION AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE OF THE
EARLY DAY. BUT THE INTENT AND
PURPOSE. AND MEANING OF THIS
MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY. IS NOT
ABOUT WHETHER THE DATE SHOULD
BE CHANGED OR NOT CHANGED. BUT
I THINK AS WAS INDICATED BY THE
SENATOR FROM GENERAL FROM
RIVERSIDE. BUT THESE WORKERS
TODAY NOT HAVE SHOULD NOT HAVE
THE SAME RIGHTS I THINK THAT
THE- SCHOOLS ARE AN ORGANISM OF
PEOPLE FROM ALL DIFFERENT JOBS
FROM TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ALL OF WHOM MAKE UP.
THE EXPERIENCE AND TO HAVE
THESE FOLKS BEING TREATED
DIFFERENTLY IF SOMEONE WANTS TO
HAVE THE DEBATE WHICH IS NOT
THIS MEASURE ON WHAT THE MARCH
FIFTEENTH MAY FIFTEENTH WHAT
THOSE STATES SHOULD BE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
TREATED EQUALLY AND FAIRLY BUT
THESE HARD WORKERS SHOULD BE IN
A POSITION THAT THEY'RE NOT
TREATED IN A DIFFERENT MANNER.
TO ME IS THE ESSENCE OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN THIS
MEASURE AND THE LAST POINT I
WANT TO RAISE WITH RESPECT THE
BUDGETING. AGAIN IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE. BUDGETING
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OF YOUR- WORKERS ARE PART OF
THE BUDGETING PROCESS AND YOU
DON'T HAVE. ONE SET OF RULES
APPLY. TO ONE GROUP AND ANOTHER
SIDE TO THE OTHER SO I WOULD
SUGGEST. THIS ACTUALLY MAKES IT
EASIER AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
WOULD ASK FOR AN IPHONE. THANK
YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA. HI AT KINS. HI
BABES. NO BACKER. GORGEOUS
RADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T.
CORTESE I DALLY NO DOG. I
TORONTO I EXAMINED EYE LASER NO
GONZALEZ I DROVE NO HERTZBERG I
WEAR SO. HER TADO HI JONES NO
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LABOR I
THE MOON. MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A
SHOW OF BOTH NO PAN. I FORTUNE
TINO. I. ROSS HI RUBIO. SKINNER
HI STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER I WILL. PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER
I PORCHES COME BY OTHER. WESSEL
THE MON. I RUBIO. STERN WILKE
EYES TWENTY SIX NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR WE ARE GOING
TO CALL THE ROLL ON THE SPECIAL
CONSENT COLOR BECAUSE IT AND A
NEW MEMBER JOIN US AND THEN
WE'LL BE LIFTING CALLS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY ONE ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTIONS AT. SEVEN TEN
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE OH ONE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I BASE
I BACKER. I PORCHES ADVERT I
HAVE A I DON'T I CORTESE I
DALLY I DON. HI THE RUSSELL I
ADMIN HI GLAZER ICONS ALL AS
HIGH GROWTH I HURTS BERG I WAS
SO HI HER TADO HI JONES. I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED. I LLEVA I THE
MAIN. HI WIRE I MELINDA'S I
NEED AN I. NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I
A TOWBOAT I CAN I PERSON TINA I
BROUGHT I RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN AMBERG HI LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. LOWS THIRTY SIX
NEWS KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED OUR MEMBERS
WE ARE NOW GOING TO LIFT CALLS
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM ONE OH EIGHT GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENT. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN FAITH HI BECKER I FORGES
DOLLY. GLAZER I NIELSEN. A TRUE
OF BOTH I RALPH I. STERN WINNER
I WILL. THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED FILE AND ONE OH NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ATKINS I BECKER I FORGES
DALLY. BLAZER I WHY SO I HER
TADO NO MELINDA'S. A CHOKE I.
RALPH I TURN WINNER I WELL.
HIGHS THIRTY THREE KNOWS ONE
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING TO FILE AND
ONE SIXTEEN SP FIVE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER I REGIS DALLY I
BLAZER I RALPH I. THE TROUBLE I
STERN WINNER I WILL FIVE THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN SP FOUR
THIRTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AND MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER.
I OR JUST LASER I RALPH HI A
TROUBLED I. STERN WINNER I WILL
HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO
DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FAT ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN SB
SEVEN NINETY PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AND MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER.
I PORGES GLAZER I TRIED BOTH I
RALPH I STERN WINNER I WILL
PRICE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY FOUR AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE OF
MEMBERS. ALAN BACKER I BARGES
LASER I A SHOW OF BOTH. I RALPH
I STERN WEINER I WILL FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FIVE AND. ONE FORTY FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
ACTOR I. FOR JUST COME BY OTHER.
GLAZER I. A TURBO I. RALPH HI
STERN WINNER I WILL PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN. FOR
JUST CUT BY EVER I. STERN WELL
I THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM. ONE
FIFTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
TWO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN BACKER I FORGES
GLAZER I- TELEVOTE I. RALPH I
STERN WINNER I WILL BUY THIRTY
SIX ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
FOLLOWED A ONE FIFTY FIVE A P.
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
BACKER I OR JUST GLAZER I WELL
BOTH I. RALPH I STERN WINNER I
WELL. FIVE THREE SIX TWO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FOLLOWING
THE ONE FORTY SEVEN EIGHTY SIX
SO TO PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER I OR JUST
GLAZER EYE GROWTH. HI THE
TROUBLE I. RALPH I STERN WINNER
I WELL I THIRTY SIX ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FIVE AND ONE
FIFTY SIX AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SIX PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER I FORGES
GLAZER I DROVE I. TROUBLE I.
RALPH I STERN WEINER I WELL I
WAS THIRTY SIX AND A ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FOLLOWED A ONE
THIRTY SEVEN A. B. SEVEN SEVEN
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER I FORGES
GLAZER. I GROVE. I CAN LONGER.
BUT YOUR VOTE I. RALPH I STERN
WINNER I WILL. I THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FOLLOW
THEM. ONE SIXTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER I.
FORGES GLAZER I DROVE. I CAN
LONGER. I A TURBO I RALPH HI
STERN WEINER I WILL I WAS
THIRTY SIX ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM. ONE SEVENTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE ZERO THREE
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER HI FORTUS.
BLAZER I. GROVE I WELL BOTH HI
RALPH I STERN WEINER I WELL
HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES AND. ONE SEVENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER I PORCHES DALLY.
GLAZER I ROVE I THE TROUBLE I.
RALPH I STERN WEINER I WILL. BY
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WELL ITEM. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER I PORCHES GLAZER I
GROVE I ALTHOUGH I RALPH I
STERN WEINER I WILL I WAS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY ALL EYES THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
AND ONE SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN BECKER I
FORGES BRADFORD. HI GLAZER I
GROVE I. A TURBO I ROTH I STERN
WINNER I WILL RISE THIRTY SIX
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES BUT
ITEM ONE EIGHTY AB TWELVE OH
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER. I PORCHES
GLAZER I ROVE HI PATROL BOAT I.
ROTH I TURN WINNER. I WILL FIVE
THREE SIX ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES PHYLUM ONE TWENTY S. R.
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER ALL
RIGHT FORTUS GLAZER I. STERN BY
THIRTY SEVEN DOES ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY THREE AB TWELVE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER I
FORGES GLAZER I STERN. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE AND ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
NINETY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AND MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER
I FORGES GLAZER I HEARD BURKE I
THE CHOIR I MELINDA'S I STERN
FIVE THREE SEVEN NINE ZERO THE
MEASURE PSSES FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY A. . TWO TWO NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER. HI FORTUS GLAZER.
EYE GROWTH. MELINDA'S I STERN.
FIVE THREE SIX NINE ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FELL ITEM ONE
NINETY TWO BABY ONE OF SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER I PORCHES LASER HI
HER TADO I MELINDA'S I STERN.
FIVE THREE SEVEN NINE ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FIVE AND ONE AT
NINETY FOUR A. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER I
FORGES GLAZER. I STERN. EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FIVE AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. ALAN FORGES HERTZBERG
HI WESSEL I STERN WELL. FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FIVE A. ONE NINETY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS. ALAN OR
JEFF HERTZBERG. I WAS SO I
STERN WILKE FIVE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. FIVE
ONE NINETY NINE EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN FOR JEFF
HERTZBERG I LEFT SO HIGH STERN
WELL I THREE SIX ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TWO
ZERO THREE AB ONE ZERO FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN FOR JUST HURTS
BERG I WEAR SO I WHEN DOES.
STERN WELL. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE MAJOR PASSES FALLON.
TWO ZERO FOUR EIGHTY FIFTEEN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AT MEMBERS. ALAN FOR
JEFF GLASS SO I STERN WELL THE
I. THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS LOOKING FOR
SENATOR SKINNER AND SENATOR
BRADFORD. SENATOR BRADFORD. YES
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY WILL MEET
IMMEDIATELY AFTER GERMAN AND
ROOM FORTY TWO OLD THREE FORTY
TWO OH THREE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
MEDIA AFTER GERMAN OF SESSION
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
CENTRE SKINNER. THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL MEET
AFTER WE HAD DURING AND AFTER
THE- FLOORS BENEATH PLEASE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS. MEMBERS REMOVING THE
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THERE
IS A RESOLUTION AT THE.
WITHOUT
OBJECTION PURSUANT TO JOINT
RULE THIRTY THREE POINT ONE
JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN FORTY BE RE AMENDED
AFTER THE DEADLINE THIS REQUEST
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS OF THERE IS
NO FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER
ACTIONS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK HOW IT FEELS LIKE
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY. I OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR TOMORROW WEDNESDAY
SEPTEMBER EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT TEN AM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL ALL
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS IS
RECEIVED AT THE DESK WE WILL
RECONVENE WEDNESDAY AT TEN AM.
THANK YOU MEMBERS HAVE A GOOD
EVENING.